NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT THE CENTER GATHERING
JENNY HERE TO OUR SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS TO
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY.
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE AN OLD STREET BUILDING AND
I ASKED ALL MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT. IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. SO WE CAN
STOP THE CORPSMAN BEGAN OUR
HEARING. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS FOR
AWHILE. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TWO DAYS
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TO. AT. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY OUR MODERATOR TO
DOUBT ONE THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AN OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR OPERATOR TO ASSIGN. YOU
A NUMBER A LINE NUMBER AND THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL BE A WAITING QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL THAT LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTE IT AND YOU'LL BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE. YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE FALL. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL REMAIN I WILL
TRY TO MAINTAIN DECORUM BUT-
TOUGH CROWD HERE. DURING THE
HEARING AS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
MEETING AT IN SERVICE AND HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS TO MUTE IT. WE
HAVE A BILLS TODAY- ON THE
AGENDA HOWEVER- SOONER JONES HAS
POURED S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY NINE.
AND SO WILL HAVE SEVEN THAT WE
WILL HERE BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR
TESTIMONY WE WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. MASSOUD COUNCIL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BRADFORD YOUR
BRADFORD HERE ADOBO. TROUBLED
HERE CALM WATER YOU'RE A LONGER
HERE SKINNER WIENER WE GOT A WE
HAVE A QUORUM IF ONE IS PRESENT
SO NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR AND AT SENATOR BATES YES
YES SB NINE OH FORCE INTERPRET.
THANK YOU I AM BERMAN BRADFORD
ACTUALLY I'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH
S. B. TEN SIXTY I'VE THREE BILLS
2% SO IF I COULD- GET THROUGH
THE IN MY WITNESSES ARE WAITING
ALL RIGHT WE'LL START WITH S.
THREE TWO IN SIXTY SB TEN SIXTY-
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB TEN SIXTY
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WHICH HAS
SPENT NOW TO A LIST OF DANGEROUS
DRUGS INCLUDING HEROIN AND
COCAINE WHICH ARE SUBJECT TO
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS. ON
WEIGHT. HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
MATCH FENTANYL'S POTENCY WHEN
COMPARED TO OTHER DRUGS THIS
BILL CREATES A NEW SET OF WEIGHT
ENHANCEMENTS. FOR FENTANYL THAT
ARE SEPARATE FROM THOSE
CURRENTLY LISTED FOR HEROIN
COCAINE AND METHAMPHETAMINE AS A
RESULT WAIT ENHANCEMENTS WOULD
BE TRIGGERED IF SOMEONE IS
CAUGHT WITH AT LEAST TWENTY
GRAMS OF FAT NOW. THIS BILL ALSO
INCLUDES OXY CODE OWN IN THE
CATEGORY OF DRUGS LIKE HEROIN
COCAINE AND METHAMPHETAMINE
WHICH ARE SUBJECT TO
ENHANCEMENTS BY WEIGHT DUE TO
THE FACT. THAT THEY ARE OFTEN
USED AS A CONDUIT BY TRAFFICKERS
TO DELIVER FENTANYL TO
UNSUSPECTING USERS. THIS IS MY
FIFTH TIME BRINGING A SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT FOR FIT NOW TO THIS
COMMITTEE I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL
AWARE OF THAT. BUT I'VE DONE
THAT BECAUSE IT CONTINUES TO
BUILD THE FENTANYL CONTINUES. TO
BE- A- HORRIBLE ARE IMPACT-
DEADLY ONE ON OUR COMMUNITIES
AND I THINK IT NEEDS A CONSTANT
REVIEW. IN THE FIRST TWO MONTHS
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
NARCOTICS TEAMS HAVE SEIZED OVER
TWO HUNDRED. AND FIVE POUNDS OF
SUSPECTED FENTANYL IN OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE THOUSAND
KILL SUSPECTED TO CONTAIN SOME
LEVEL OF FENTANYL. IN ONE RECENT
CASE THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE WORKS WITH FEDERAL
PARTNERS. AND SEES ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT POUNDS OF FAT
NOW FORTY TWO POUNDS OF METH AND
FIFTEEN POUNDS OF MARIJUANA. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
STATES THAT FENTANYL RELATED
OVERDOSES ROSE FROM TWO HUNDRED
AND ONE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. TO
THREE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX JUST SIX YEARS LATER
IN TWENTY TWENTY. IN OTHER WORDS
FENTANYL OVERDOSES JUMPED BY
MORE THAN 20001100% IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. THE RISE OF FENTANYL
OVERDOSES HAS ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ACCORDING
TO THE CDC THAT NO OVERDOSES
RATES FOR NON HISPANIC AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE UNITED STATES
AT THE LARGEST ANNUAL PERCENTAGE
INCREASE. FROM. TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AT ONE HUNDRED AND 40% PER YEAR.
FOLLOWED BY HIS. AT ONE HUNDRED
AND 18% PER YEAR IN OVERDOSES
FOR NON HISPANIC WHITE PERSONS
INCREASED BY NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
AND NINE PERCENT. THESE SOBERING
STATISTICS SPEAK VOLUMES TO THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL. SB TEN SIXTY
CRACKS DOWN ON DRUG CARTELS AND
HIGH LEVEL DRUG DEALERS THAT ARE
DISTRIBUTING TRAFFICKING OF
SELLING MASS QUANTITIES OF THIS
POISON. BECAUSE OF FENTANYL'S
HEIGHTENED POTENCY THE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENTS WOULD BE TRIGGERED
WHEN SOMEONE IS CAUGHT WITH A
MINIMUM OF TWENTY GRAMS OR MORE
OF THAT NOW AS OPPOSED TO ONE
GRAM. ONE MILLIGRAM ONE. CLOSE
TO ONE KILOGRAM OR MORE OF
HEROIN OR COCAINE. IT ONLY TAKES
TWO MILLIGRAMS FOR FENTANYL TO
BE FATAL FOR MOST PEOPLE TO
PLACE THAT AMOUNT INTO
PERSPECTIVE. TWENTY GRAMS OF FAT
NOW CONTAINS TEN THOUSAND LETHAL
DOSES. THIS REFLECTS. THAT KNOWS
LARGER POTENCY WHICH IS UP TO
FIFTY TIMES MORE POTENT THAN
PHARMACEUTICAL GRADE HEROIN IS
OFTEN MIXED INTO HEROIN AND
OTHER DRUGS WITHOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OF USERS THAT CAN BE
DEADLY SIMPLY IF IT BECOMES
AIRBORNE. MAKES CONTACT WITH THE
SKIN AND POSES SIGNIFICANT
DANGER TO FIRST RESPONDERS IT
DOES NOT CHANGE SENTENCE FOR END
USERS OR FOR THOSE USING MEDICAL
THAT NOW FOR IS LEGITIMATE AND
PRESCRIBE PURPOSE. AND IT GIVES
LARA LAW ENFORCEMENT A NEEDED
TOOL TO PREVENT AN EPIDEMIC OF
DEATHS AND OVERDOSES THAT WE SEE
HAPPENING THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE RIVERSIDE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND THE ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE AND I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY. AS THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE
RIVERSIDE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
REPRESENTED BY DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. ATTORNEY ROBERT HOW
HOW TO HIGHTOWER IN ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF DON BARNES. ALL
RIGHT IF YOUR WITNESSES ARE
PREPARED WILL PROVIDE THEM TO
MANAGE EACH WE HAVE- ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF DON BARNES AND WE
HAVE. RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY I TO OUR SHOW. YOUR
FARM JERRY PREPARE. YES MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- THIS DRUG EPIDEMIC
OF THE NATION'S MOST SIGNIFICANT
LONG TERMPUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
AND PUBLIC SAFETY CRISIS OF OUR
TIME. FOR THE FIRST TIME THE
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD NATIONWIDE
DRUG RELATED DEATHS EXCEEDED ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND BETWEEN APRIL
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY IN APRIL TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND THREE OR
SIX AMERICANS LOST THEIR LIVES
TO DRUG RELATED DEATHS. THE
LARGEST COMPONENT OF THAT NUMBER
IS SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS LIKE
FENTANYL DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
PERSPECTIVE THIS IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF TEN BOEING SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN AIRLINE JETS
CRASHING EACH WEEK EVERY WEEK
FOR A YEAR STRAIGHT. AT THAT
MANY AIRLINE CRASHES OCCURRED WE
WOULD DO SOMETHING IMMEDIATELY
TO FIX THE PROBLEM. SB TEN SIXTY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP OUR
FENTANYL PROBLEM. I KNOW THIS IS
A SIMILAR BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE SEVERAL
TIMES I'VE BEEN REJECTED- EACH
TIME THIS VERSION HOWEVER IS
PERHAPS THE MOST. POWERFUL TO
CREATE AN ENTIRE SEPARATE
CLASSIFICATION OF PENALTIES FOR
FENTANYL TRAFFICKING. NOT THE
END USERS FOR THE TRAFFICKING
THE SUBSTANCE. THE RECOGNIZES
THE POTENCY OF THIS DEADLY
SUBSTANCE. I REMIND YOU THAT
THIS DALY SUBSTANCE THAT CLAIMED
MORE LIVES EACH AND EVERY DAY.
IN MY COUNTY ALONE THE NUMBER OF
PANEL RELATED DEATHS WAS THIRTY
SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND ROSE TO SIX HUNDRED NINETY
THREE. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
WOULD STILL SIXTY TWO CASES
PENDING. I KNOW CAN A BIRD
INCREASE SENTENCES I AGREED AN
INCREASED SENTENCE ALONE WILL
NOT WORK. WE ALSO NEED EDUCATION
AND TREATMENT THESE ARE MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF OUR EFFORTS IN
ORANGE COUNTY. WITH REGARD TO
EDUCATION OR ABOVE THE INFLUENCE
DRUG EDUCATION PROGRAM WHICH I
BELIEVE WILL BE A NATIONAL MODEL
WAS UNVEILED THIS YEAR FOR
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS. TREATMENT
SIGNIFICANT ASPECT OF WHAT WE DO
AS WELL OUR COUNTY SUPPOSE HE
CARES PROGRAM BUT THE INTEGRATED
SERVICES. AND MEDICINE ASSISTED
TREATMENT IN OUR JAILS ARE
WORKING TO HELP ADDICTS MAKING
IT A PRIORITY. ON ANY GIVEN DAY
WHICH WE HAVE THE SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE CAME OUT TO THE TUNE OF
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF
THIS FUNDED OUT COUNTY FUNDS.
NOT THROUGH STATE OR FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. THE IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. BUT WHAT WE ARE TO
EDUCATE ENTRY WE ALSO KNOW THE
MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCE FOR DRUG
TRAFFICKERS IS NEEDED THAT THAT
ASPECT OF THE SOLUTION. FLOODING
OUR COMMUNITY THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ASSISTS TWO HUNDRED FIVE POUNDS.
INTROSPECTIVE ONE OR FORTY THREE
LIST OF PILLS THAT CONTAINED
FENTANYL. CAN WE DO SOMETHING
WITH A LONG TO ENSURE THOSE MOST
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE INCREASED
DEATH FACE SOME CONSEQUENCES FOR
THEIR ACTIONS. WHAT IS THE
OBJECTION TO SIGNIFICANT JAIL
TIME FOR SOMEONE WHO WOULD
WILLINGLY TRAFFIC TO THIS DEADLY
POISON AT THE EXPENSE OF
CALIFORNIA LIVES. AS ONE OF THE
WORST WITH OVER THREE DECADES OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE EXPERIENCE I
KNOW THE LAW WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE
ONLY ENCOURAGES BAD BEHAVIOR.
DISPIRITING CONSEQUENCE FOR
HEROIN AND CONSEQUENCE FOR
FENTANYL MAKES THIS CLEAR. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY HEROIN DEATHS
INCREASED 27% WELL THANKS NO
DOUBT TO INCREASE FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. THE LACK OF CONSEQUENCE
ALONG WITH THE EASE OF
MANUFACTURING THE DRUG DRUG
WHICH IS CHEAPER AND EASIER TO
TRAFFIC THAN OTHER DRUGS. COOL
CLEARLY INCENTIVIZE THE
TRAFFICKING OF THIS MORE POTENT
SUBSTANCE. I BELIEVE WE CAN ACT
TODAY PLEASE HELP US HELP
CALIFORNIANS BY PASSING. THIS
COMMONSENSE SOLUTIONS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU KNOW GOOD TURNOUT TO
WITNESS. YEAH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ROBERT HI
CAROLINE KENNEDY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. AT
THE RIVER BATES POINTED OUT- IT
ONLY TAKES APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLIGRAM ATTENTIONAL TO BE
FATAL AND OFTENTIMES WE COULD BE
EVEN LESS THAN THAT DEPENDING ON
THE SIZE AND WEIGHT OF THE
PERSON TAKING IT AND THEIR
FAMILIARITY WITH THE DRUG. IN
ADDITION AND ALL IS SIMILAR TO
MORPHINE BUT IS FIFTY TO A
HUNDRED TIMES MORE POTENT THAN
MORPHINE IT. BUT MEAN I KNOW.
THE REGIONAL PRODUCED. BY DRUG.
THAT WAS RELEASED ANY KIND OF
RECAP. HOWEVER ADDED THAT THIS
DRUG HAVE BECOME MORE MORE
ADDICTIVE THAN MORE MORE
POPULAR. LAUGHTER NOW PRODUCING
THIS PRODUCT WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT. OF THE TRYING TO LEAVE
CAPITAL MEANING THAT THE FACTOR
OFTEN MIXED WITH OTHER DRUGS
SUCH AS OXYCONTIN. AND
METHAMPHETAMINE. I INDIVIDUALS
WERE A DRUG A OF THOSE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO THIS HIGHLY
ADDICTIVE DRUGS. HANG UP ON THEM
AND NOT UNDERSTANDING I TO
POTENCY OF THE DRUG ACTUALLY
MAINTAIN THAT IS THE REASON WHY
INSTANCE AWAITED ENHANCEMENTS
ARE NECESSARY. THEY DID NOT AND
LEGISLATION AIMED AT
INCARCERATING THOSE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO DRUGS BUT RATHER
THOSE WHO ARE- PRODUCING THIS
DRUG WITHOUT ANY THOUGHT OR
UNDERSTANDING HOW POLITICALLY
CAN BE- AND BAKER THAT USEFUL
MEASURE TO DETER- THOSE
INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT A. HAT WILL
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
OUR MY- INTO THERE'S OUR OUR-
ANY WITNESSES HERE PRESENT
WHOSE- IN SUPPORT. OF ODDS SB
TEN CAN SOON STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH LARA BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE QUICKNESS. GOVERNOR CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO EARLY ON
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND WE SUPPORT THEM.
THANK YOU. NOW I MOVED TO OUR
MODERATOR AND SHIFTERS FOLKS ON
THE PHONE LINE WHOSE WISHING TO
SUPPORT OUR TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TEN SIXTY
MODERATOR PLEASE. UNITED STATES
SUPPORT OF- SB TEN SIXTY MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME OF
COURSE WE GO TO LINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THAT'S SHOWING SHOWING WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE
TO COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO
DO AT THE TIME. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO LINK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW WILL GO TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES LISTED WHAT ONE
PRIMARY WOULD CONSERVE BELIEVE
LIST IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE GENET ZANNA
PATTEN- FROM THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE AND WE HAVE CAT THIS
YEAR CHAU I HAVE GENET IS READY
WE WILL TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY AT
THIS. NOT AT THIS MOMENT. GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DIRECTLY BUT BEING THAT
I THINK HEALTHCARE DIRECTIVES
THAT'S ALL OF THE ALLIANCE. I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY AS A FACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS SB SIXTY WHICH WOULD
IMPOSE AN ADDITIONAL TERM OF
IMPRISONMENT UPON A PERSON
LOOKING A GOOD FOR THE VIOLATION
. OR CONSPIRACY TO VIOLATE-
BETTER BY. PROVISIONS OF LAW
WITH REGARD TO. I THINK ARE-
ORGANIZATION THE IMPACT OF THE
DRUG USER HAD ALL THE LIFE USER
ARE FAB THAT THOSE HAVE LONG. I
LOVE GOING TO OVER. CAL VOTERS
HAVE REPEATEDLY SIGNALED THAT
PRACTICAL AWAY FROM FAILED
CARCERAL POLICIES OF THE PAST.
INSTEAD SHE DOESN'T USE AT THE
HEALTH CRISIS THAT IT IS.
REVERTING BACK TO CRIMINAL
PENALTIES NOT ONLY FIGHTING WITH
EACH OF WALKABLE FREE
REGULATIONS THAT ALSO LOOKS.
PRUDENT TO BE BAD PUBLIC POLICY
SB KERR SIXTY RELIED ON.
OUTDATED WAR ON DRUGS MENTALITY
ONE THAT HAS ALREADY HAD A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF USING JAIL
THE PRESIDENT TO DEAL WITH A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE I THINK IN
DECADES YOUR BEGAN TO UNRAVEL
THE MEASURE WOULD THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BACK FROM A MORE
PUBLIC HEALTH CENTRIC APPROACH.
HARSHER SENTENCING DOES NOT
REDUCE DISTRIBUTION THAT WOULD
PREVENT OVERDOSE IT'S NOT REDUCE
THE SUPPLY OF DRUGS OR THE
DEMAND FOR THEM AND WORK COULD
ACTUALLY DISCOURAGE EFFECTIVE
METHODS OF DEALING WITH THE
OPIOID CRISIS. MANY PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE INCORPORATED BY THE
BILL- ARE ARE BOOKS THAT ARE I
THINK THAT THEMSELVES OF BUREAU
OF JUSTICE BUT- OF. YOUR
OBJECTIVES REPORT ON THAT 20% OF
PEOPLE INCARCERATED FOR GOOD
PATH TRAFFICKING IN STATE
PRISONS. USE DRUGS PRIOR. TO
BEING A RECORD EVEN THE VISUALS
OFTEN SELL DRUGS NOT FOR PROFIT
THAT THE WAY TO SUPPORT. THEIR
OWN SEPTIC YOU THINK. YOU
STARTER. OFTEN THE SELLERS NOT
HIGH MEMBER OF ANY. RIGHT IF YOU
THINK THAT RATHER. FURNISHING A
NARCOTICS TO FRIENDS WITH
MEMBERS- ANY. AS AS THE SUPPORT
STATED IT IS WE HAVE SEEN HER
THOUSAND. THAT AS A RESULT OF
THIS OVER CRAIG AND THE TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD ENDING IN A- TWO
TWENTY. FURTHER PROOF THAT
IMPORTANT FOR APPROACH IS TO TRY
ARE NOT WORKING AND FACT
CRIMINALS. ARE FEELING OVER THE
CRISIS PUSHING. INTO THE SIX
CHOI SAYS I. AND MAKE PROGRESS.
UNDER AND- BUT COUNTLESS LIFE AT
THE- I THANK SOMETHING INTO OF
THE- AND LOOK AT A- OF. TO
DESTROY RELATED. BY MAKING
EVIDENCE TREATMENT AVAIL ON THE
AND TO INFO HARM. POLICIES WHAT
DRUG CHECKING TO HELP MAKE YOUR
AT ALL ACCEPTED. AND GETTING
OPIATE OPIATE OVERDOSE ANNA LOCK
INTO THE OF THE LOOK LIKE THE
FACT THAT WATER PERSON IS
SUFFERING AN OPEN. IT IMPERATIVE
THAT HELL. CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
CREEPING THING. AND MARGINALIZED
DRUNK SO USE AND ESTABLISH
POLICY THAT GUIDE TO AWAY NEEDED
TO. HELP AND HARM REDUCTION. FOR
THE REASONS THE CALL OF LIFE FOR
QUITE TO KNOW WHAT ON IT B.
SIXTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
WE'LL GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS.
AND UP TO. GOOD AFTERNOON HAPPY
FOR A DEAL YOU CAL ACT WE NOT
OPPOSE SB SIXTY- I THINK THE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN I BE BRIEF
INCREASE TRANSIT INCLUDING THE
SENSE TEN HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
BILL AND DOING WORK TO REDUCE
DRUG SALES A DRUG USE. INSTEAD
THEY ACTUALLY DO HARM BY DRIVING
AWAY FROM THE THEY NEED ALLEN BY
THE RECALL LIKE BE USED TO
PROVIDE THE START. IF YOU WANT
TO COME BACK THE RESULTING FROM
YOU. MAKE SURE THAT REDUCTION OF
DRUGS TREATMENT SERVICES THEY TO
AND WHO FROM AND FOR DESTROYING
. DISINVEST AND MATTHEW TO RACE
. WE RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU NOW WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE HEARING
INSURANCE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- CAN SIXTY
HERE IN THE ROOM. IN NINETEEN
NINE MODERATE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW AND ASK THE
THOSE WHO QUEUED UP. TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION YOUR TIME IS NOW.
HE LED BY OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME-
FIRST TWO LINE. WELL THESE
CLIENT. ONE TWELVE THE LINES
OPEN. IT'S LIKELY CALDWELL
HOUSTON. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY FIVE IS FINE. MAKE A
MULTI POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER AND
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE SP TEN SIXTY. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALREADY ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE ACTED IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
GOODNESS. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ACROSS
ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I WILL GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
COLBY LANDS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU HAVING EXHAUSTED ALL
OUR WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE
WILL NOT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. REGARDING THIS ISSUE
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN
NINETEEN NINETY OUT OUT SENATOR
JOE BOOK. SO- NO I UNDERSTAND
THAT MUCH OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW ARE COMING
FROM THE NOTION THAT THE WORD
DRUG DID NOT WORK AND THAT THIS
BILL WILL BE WOULD BE A
CONTINUATION ON THIS WAR- CENTER
BASED IN YOUR OPINION WAS THERE
ANY PART OF THE WAR ON DRUGS
THAT- WAS THE FACT THAT YOU
BELIEVE WAS EFFECTIVE BASED ON
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN. WORKING WITH
THE SPELL ENDED THE SENTENCES
AND HUSBAND HAVE ANY POSITIVE
EFFECT BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S-
THAT'S A COMMON THEME THAT I'M
HEARING HERE IN IN COMMITTEE
AND- WE HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ON THAT END- WHAT
IS YOUR EXPERIENCE. I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY BETTER DIRECTED
TO OUR EXPERTS WHO REALLY ARE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFF OBVIOUSLY
SENT FINANCES HAVE TO DO WITH
OF. JAIL AND PRISON AND OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WHO ARE
PROSECUTING THOSE CASES I JUST.
BELIEVE THAT WHEN YOU SEE A
REDUCTION IN HEROIN USE AND A
REDUCTION IN COCAINE USE AND YOU
HAVE THIS EXPLOSION AND FOUND NO
USE WHERE THERE'S NO SENSE IN
HOUSE WENT TO GET ON THE OTHER
TWO. THERE ARE MAYBE THAT'S AN
INDICATION THAT SENSE
ENHANCEMENTS TO DO WORK FOR
CERTAIN KINDS OF. A DISTRIBUTION
AND MANUFACTURING THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE LARGE
AMOUNTS. WHEN YOU WHEN I
INTRODUCED THE BILL IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN FOR SENSE ENHANCEMENTS.
IT FAILED UNDERSTOOD. OFF FIVE
YEARS LATER WE HAVE A 20001100%
INCREASE IN FENTANYL
DISTRIBUTION AND TRAFFICKING.
THAT SAYS SOMETHING WAS WORKING
WHEN THE OTHER TWO DRUGS HAVE.
ACTUALLY KIND OF FALLEN OFF THE
RADAR. UP I GUESS SIMPLY
SPEAKING. AND THIS DRUG IS
BECOME- THE ONE THAT'S BEING
IMPORTED MANUFACTURED IN HUGE
AMOUNTS WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE PEOPLE. WHO ARE REALLY
ATTICS ARE I LOOK AT THIS IS A
THREE LEGGED STOOL YOU GOTTA
HAVE EDUCATION. YOU GOT TO HAVE
TREATMENT BUT YOU GOTTA HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AND I BELIEVE A
YOUNG MAN WHO SPOKE AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE LAST WEEK. R. WHO'D
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
INCARCERATED. REALLY SPOKE VERY
FERVENTLY ABOUT THE ONLY REASON
HE GOT OUT- INTO- EIGHT A JOB
HE'S A BUSINESS OWNER BECAUSE HE
HAD CONSEQUENCES. AND THOSE WERE
GIVEN TO HIM WHEN HE WAS
INCARCERATED BECAUSE HE GOT
EDUCATION AND TREATMENT WHILE HE
WAS IN. INCARCERATED SO I THINK
WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT JUST
NOT GENERALLY SAYING SINCE
ANNOUNCEMENTS DON'T WORK. MAYBE
WE NEED TO STUDY- THAT REALLY
LOOKS AT THE KINDS OF SENSE AND
HANDS MOST THAT HAVE WORKED WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE
LARGEST THREE. DISTRIBUTORS THAT
THE CARTELS BUT I'D LIKE TO ASK
WHY EXPERT WITNESS AND THAT
WOULD BE SURE OF MARS TO TALK
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE HE HAS.
BASICALLY I'D I UNDERSTAND AND
BECAUSE I'M ORANGE COUNTY AND
WHAT SHARE OF MARS IS DONE WE
BASICALLY HAVE A JAIL IT'S
BECOME ALMOST A TRIAGE CENTER TO
GET PEOPLE WHO ARE. THE ADDICTS
THE USERS INTO TREATMENT BUT
HE'S NOT ABLE TO REACH BEYOND
THAT AND GET THE BIG GUYS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE SO. I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO
DIRECT THAT QUESTION TO SHARE
FARMS. HERE YEAH. SHE FARMS
WHICH QUESTION. YES THEY GIVE
CHAIRMAN RESERVE THE COMMITTEE
AS CENTER BATES REFERNCED
PERSON FOREMOST THE REFERENCE
THAT THE WAR ON DRUGS HAS FAILED
LET ME DRAW A DISTINCTION WARS
ARE FINITE BUT NOT INTENDED TO
BE- INFINITE- THIS IS NOT A WAR
THIS AND FOR SOME OF OUR STATE'S
LAWS IS A DISTINCT DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO YOU CAN'T PROVE
A NEGATIVE I THINK IF WE WERE TO
JUST GIVEN UP YEARS AGO WE WOULD
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT CONDITION WE
WOULD BE IN TODAY. BUT AS
SENATOR BATES HAS TESTIFIED TO-
I BELIEVE IT'S COMPLETELY TRUE
REGARDING FENTANYL WITHIN OUR
STATE IF YOU GO BACK TO DATA-
PRESENTED BY CDC IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN OF ALL THE DEATHS
NATIONALLY 4% OF THOSE THE
PREVAILING DRUG THEY CALLED THAT
DOUBT WAS SPENT IN L. THAT FIVE
YEARS LATER IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IT HAD RIPPED 40% OF
DEATH NATIONALLY THEY'LL BE OUR
CONTENT SPECIFICALLY. OVER 70%
SO LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY IS
ACTUALLY CURSED IN MY BELIEVE
THE TRUTH THE. TRAFFICKING OF
NARCOTICS. AND STORE NOW. THAT
THE THREE PRONGS OF THIS AB TRUE
. IN MY JAIL THE ORANGE JAIL. I
IN ANY DAY UNDER. POPULATION
CIRCUMSTANCES PROOF BEFORE
COVERED. A HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY PEOPLE ARE BEING
MEDICALLY SUPERVISED DETOX. OFF
OF NARCOTICS THEY DIDN'T COME TO
MY TL TO GET DRUG TREATMENT THEY
HAPPENED UPON MY JAIL. BREAK RUN
THE BEST HOSPITAL WE CAN WHILE
WE HELP THEM. BUT THESE.
BELIEVES THAT- BIRTH AS A RESULT
OF PROP FORTY SEVEN PROP FIFTY
SEVEN OTHERS THAT IF WE HAD-
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO GET ON
TREATMENT THAT'S JUST NOT
HAPPENING IN THE STATE. AND THIS
IS NOT AIMED AT THOSE WHO ARE
ADDICTED THIS IS NAMED AIMED AT
STOPPING. THE NARCOTIC THE
KANEMI THAT HAPPENS IN THE
STATE. WHERE DO YOU DRUG.
ORGANIZATION SOUTH OF GOING TO
WRITE THE AND MEET THE- NORTH OF
THE BORDER. I DON'T LIKE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE NARCOTICS
ADDICTED PEOPLE WITHIN THE JOB
BUT THEY'RE NOT GETTING
TREATMENT ON THEIR OWN. ANYMORE
MORE ADDICTED EVERY DAY. AND IF
ANYTHING THIS SHOULD BE IN
PERHAPS ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO
INTERRUPT AND DISRUPT THE DRUG.
THE DRUG TRAFFICKING. PROBABLY
TO THE BENEFIT OF SAVING
CALIFORNIA LIVE TO LEASE TO SLOW
IT DOWN. IF WE WERE TO DO THAT
SO I BELIEVE FIRMLY THAT THIS IS
IN OUR- AN APPROPRIATE. APPROACH
IN MY BELIEF OF ANNOUNCED
ALMOST. THIRTY THREE YEARS OF
BEING IN POLICING IN THE STATE.
THERE HAS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY
PASSED THE OFFRAMP JUST YOU WAIT
TO GET THE DRUGS. THE STOCK
FLOW. FROM SOUTH OF THE BORDER
TO NORTH OF THE BORDER AND THIS
IS ONE OF THE KEY. AREAS IN
WHICH WE CAN DO THAT- AND I
BELIEVE FROM ME THAT THIS WOULD
BE AT HAVE A DIRECT POSITIVE
RESULT IF WE WERE TO PASS THIS
BILL. AND ALL THE CATHOLICS WERE
TRAFFICKING NARCOTICS. NOT THOSE
WHO ARE THE END USERS. THANK YOU
. YES. SO I LIKE TO FOLLOW UP
WITH SOME QUESTIONS SOME SOME
COMMENTS AND- YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
ACTUALLY BLESSED TO HAVE AND MET
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS IN MY LIFE
THAT I CALL FRIENDS WHO HAVE
SERVED TIME AND THEY HAVE DONE A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT. YOU KNOW
COMPELLED NOT COMPEL THEM BUT-
DIRECTED THEM TO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND SERVE TIME AND I CAN
THINK OF A GENTLEMEN- A FRIEND
OF MINE. WHO WHO SAID YOU KNOW
THANKS TO THE THREE STRIKES LAW
I ACTUALLY DID A- CHANGE IN MY
LIFE BECAUSE HE SERVED TIME HE
REALIZED THAT IF. HE DID
SOMETHING ELSE HE WAS GONNA BE
OUT FOR A LONG TIME AND THIS IS
A GENTLEMAN WHO. WAS VERY ROUGH
AND I'LL YOU KNOW I CALL NO MORE
FOR THE VERY NOW BUT- BY YOU
LOOK AT HIM AND YOU WOULD BE
VERY INTIMIDATED BECAUSE OF
THINGS THAT HE'S DONE IN THE WAY
HE SPEAKS AND SO FORTH BUT- HE
TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND HAVING
CERTAIN- PARAMETERS THAT HE HAD
TO FEAR IN ORDER FOR HIM. SHAPE
UP IN SANTA I'M GONNA CHANGE MY
- I THINK OF- PASTOR BRIAN- IN
MY DISTRICT AS WELL WHO ALSO
SERVED TIME. AND ALSO SAID YOU
KNOW THERE WAS A TIME AFTER HE
WAS. CONVICTED I THINK WAS THE
SECOND TIME- WHERE HE MET A
GENTLEMAN AND SAID YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD I NOT HAVE THOSE PARAMETERS
IN THOSE FEARS I WOULD NOT HAVE.
DECIDED NO THAT'S NOT THAT'S HOW
I'M GOING TO END UP WITH DON'T
YOU MAKE A CHANGE SO THERE
SOMETIMES AND EVEN AS A PARENT.
YOU KNOW I I'VE READ MANY BOOKS
AND DISCIPLINE AND TALKS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
PARAMETERS HAVING- THINGS THAT
YOU- BOB FRANKEN GOING TO ALL
THE LITTLE DETAILS BUT IMPORTANT
HAVING CONSEQUENCES. AND HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE HAVE YOU.
FOR- AND THEN. JUST THE WORDS
THAT IN RIGHT NOW IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE ON ONE SIDE
WE HAVE A LOT OF. LAWS
PROHIBITING AND- CREATING MORE
MORE LAW. WE IT COMES TO. GUN IN
THE STATE. BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
INCREASE OF- HOMICIDES OR
WHATEVER MAYBE YOU KNOW THERE'S
A TENDENCY TO HAVE THAT IN
PLACE. BUT YEAH WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS PARTICULAR. TOPIC WHEN IT
COMES TO VOTE AND ALL. AND THE-
DEATHS THAT WE'RE- SCENE. AND
AND EXPERIENCING WITH ARE YOU
DYING. JUST THIS WEEK AND I HAVE
TO SHARE- I HAD- MY SON WAS
RACING AND ARE THERE IS A SON IN
A IN A IN A FATHER RIGHT NEXT TO
US. AND THE IN THE SUN SAID HE
GOES YOU KNOW IN OUR IN OUR
POCKET YOU KNOW THERE'S A
THERE'S A SMBOL TO SUPPLEMENT
YOUR SON CAN TAKE TO HELP THEM
GET. GOING TO KEEP GOING. AND-
AND WAS INTERESTING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW I WAS BEING VERY POLITE BUT
HAVING SAT ON THIS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND HEARING THE
STORIES LAST YEAR BUT. I DID
LAST YEAR. I GREW UP TO SEPT CAN
WE FEEL GREAT WERE THAT NOISES
COME FROM THANK YOU. AND-
SERVICE YOU KNOW THIS DAD AND
SON SHARING THEIR SUPPLEMENTS
WITH ME AND I AND I YOU KNOW WAS
BEING POLITE GRABBED IT I WAS
READING AND LOOKING AT THE LABEL
AND SO FORTH AND ALL I COULD
THINK OF WAS THOSE PARENTS LAST
YEAR. IN THINKING I HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE THIS IS COMING FROM. I'M
AS GOOD WILL INTENDED AS THIS
WAS FURTHER FROM THIS DAD AND
SON HERE I CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE. YOU KNOW USE THIS
BECAUSE I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT
IS BUT ALL I COULD THINK OF. WAS
THE STORIES OF THOSE PARENTS
WHOSE CHILDREN. UNBEKNOWNST AND
TOOK SOMETHING. OUT MANY OF THEM
THINKING PAIN MEDICATION WAS
LACED WITH FENTANYL AND I
THOUGHT NEVER. AND I DON'T WANT
TO BE DISRESPECTFUL NINETY WHEN
IT YOU KNOW SHARE MY STORIES OF.
THE FEARS THAT I HAVE BUT I DO I
LIVE WITH THAT FEAR EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AND AFTER WHAT HAPPENED
THIS WEEK THIS WEEK IN IMPORT AT
WITH THOSE BECAUSE I CAN'T
IMAGINE. WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
IF WE FEEL COMPELLED THAT WE
HAVE TO DO. SOMETHING WITH WITH
GUNS BECAUSE THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM I'M SORRY BUT FENTON ALL
RIGHT NOW. IS AN EPIDEMIC IN
BECAUSE IF IT'S COMING TO PEOPLE
UNBEKNOWNST TO THEM. I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT WITH THIS
BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE USERS PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY SUFFERING FROM
ADDICTION BUT FOR PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY ARE DISTRIBUTING. OR
MANUFACTURING THE BIG BIG PEOPLE
THERE BECAUSE I THINK THEM THERE
IS NO INTENT. BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT WHAT YOUR MANUFACTURING AND
DISTRIBUTING HAS THE ABILITY TO.
KILL SOMEONE. IT'S DIFFERENT IF
YOU'RE USED TO YOU'RE JUST DOING
IT DEALING AND I CAN UNDERSTAND
MIKE MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THINKING THAT THIS IS JUST THE
BUSINESS FOR THEM IT'S A MEANS
TO PROVIDE FOR THEMSELVES OR
WHATEVER IT MAY BE. BUT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING BIG AMOUNTS WE'RE
TALKING DISTRIBUTING AT THIS
LEVEL. HE GOES TO BED IN I'M
SORRY THAT IS. INTENDED THEIR-
AND THEY SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. WITHOUT A
SHADOW OF A DOUBT AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT MANY PARENTS. MANY
MEMBERS IN OUR COMMUNITY ACROSS
THE STATE IF THEY KNOW THE
CONSEQUENCES THEY WERE.
ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIED IF WE DON'T
ARE HOLDING THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE DEALING WITH THE BIG BIG
NUMBERS OF. BIG SHIP IS INDUSTRY
READING. NOT BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
. I'M SORRY IS A PARENT I'M DONE
. AND I THINK WE NEED TO DO
BETTER IN THE STATE HOLDING THIS
BIG PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE. START
SOMEWHERE. PARENTS LIKE MYSELF
SHOULD NOT MAYBE TERRIFIED. MY
KIDS WERE ACCIDENTALLY TAKE
SOMETHING LACED WITH. TERRIBLE
THINGS. AND I'M PLEADING WITH MY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE. THAT WE
GO AFTER THESE BIG PEOPLE THAT
ARE USERS NOT THE WHAT THEY'RE
SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION BECAUSE
THAT IS ANOTHER IT AND I HAVE
COMPASSION FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ADDICTION I REALLY DO AND I'M
WORKING ON NOT IN THIS WORLD.
BUT NOT THE BIG DISTRIBUTORS THE
PEOPLE WITH ILL INTENT. THEY
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE WHEN
I HOPE I HOPE IN A PLEA WITH YOU
. BUT YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR HEART
TO GO AFTER THESE BIG PEOPLE.
AND NOT UNDERMINED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND- MCCAULEY FROM SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY AYE- I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
THE FEAR BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO TAKE THE
DRUGS I THINK IT'S A PERCOCET OR
OR WHATEVER AND THEN IT HAS
DENTAL AND SENTINEL IS SO TOXIC
AND IT IS TERRIFYING TO KNOW AND
I WILL HAVE A LIVE PEOPLE MIGHT.
LIVE OVER THE YEARS TO DROP MY
CHILDREN BUT PEOPLE WHO I LOVE
WHO HAVE USED AND KNOWING THAT
THEY COULD RECEIVE DRUGS THAT
ARE LACED AND COULD END UP DYING
IT IS ABSOLUTELY TERRIFYING AND
IT'S A PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER-
IT ABSOLUTELY IS. AND YOU KNOW
IF I IF I THOUGHT BAG IN THE CAR
SURVATION WAS GONNA SOMEHOW LIKE
AND THIS IT'S SOMETHING. TO
CONSIDER BUT WE- THE TRAGEDY. A
SPECIAL IN THE BEATING BILLS
LIKE THIS IS THAT WE KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE. WE KNOW FROM LIKE
REAL LIFE EXPERIENCE OVER THE
LAST FIFTY YEARS THAT THESE
ENHANCEMENTS AND HARSHER ARCHER
SENSES DON'T ACTUALLY REDUCE
DRUG USE AND DON'T REDUCE
OVERDOSES- YOU KNOW WE HAD AN
NINETEEN EIGHTIES EPIDEMIC OF
CRACK COCAINE- AND A LOT OF
WHICH WAS FOR DYING PEOPLE WERE
IT WAS A LOT OF HARM BUT WAS
COMING. FROM CRACK COCAINE USE
AND SO IN THIS COUNTRY WE UP THE
SENSES AND JUST STARTED JUST
HACKING OUR JAILS- FULL OF
PEOPLE AND IT DOESN'T REDUCE
DRUG USE AND NOW WE HAVE
DIFFERENT DRUGS THAT PEOPLE ARE
USING AND THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
ARE DYING FROM. AND SO I CHEST I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS APPROACH
IS ACTUALLY. GOING END UP SAVING
PEOPLE'S LIVES BECAUSE FROM
EXPERIENCE WE KNOW THAT HARSHER
JAIL SENTENCES OR DON'T END UP
CHANGING. DRUG USE OF PEOPLE ARE
IS LONGER IF PEOPLE ARE ADDICTED
THEY'RE GOING TO USE ARE GONNA
FIND A WAY TO USE. AND THE
HARDER WE MAY GET ACTUALLY THE
MORE DANGEROUS IT IS BECAUSE IT
BECOMES MORE AND MORE ALYSSA
ANALYSTS AT PLUS. WAY OFF THE
BEATEN TRACK AND PEOPLE GET
DESPERATE FOR THE DRUGS AND THAT
IS SERVED THIRTY YEAR NASTIER
KINDS OF DRUGS AND MORE
CONTAMINATED DRUGS- AND- AND AS
LONG AS THERE IS DEMAND. THERE
WILL BE SUPPLY. AND THEY'LL FIND
A WAY FOR THE SUPPLY- TO BE
THERE AS FAR EVEN IF WE MAKE
THINGS HARSHER. THIS BILL IN
ADDITION. DOES GO BEYOND I THINK
THE KING PENS- IT STARTS AT
TWENTY GRAMS AND I'M NOT SAYING
TWENTY GRAMS OF SOME TINY AMOUNT
OF DRUGS BUT THAT IS. THAT'S
NOT. PICKING PAN TWENTY GRAMS-
AND IT DOES NOT REQUIRE. MY
READING OF I DOES NOT REQUIRE
KNOWLEDGE. THAT THE DRUGS ARE
LACED WITH FENTANYL- FOR EXAMPLE
SO IT'S NOT DISCIPLINE DRUG THIS
BILL IS NOT LIMITED TO I AM
INTENTIONALLY STE. COMMITTING
FRAUD BY SAYING I'M SELLING YOU
A COCAINE ADDICT COCAINE. LACED
WITH FENTANYL I INTENTIONALLY
MISREPRESENTING THAT TO YOU THE
STOCK BUILD IS NOT REQUIRE THAT
LEVEL KNOWLEDGE IT'S JUST THE
FACT THAT AND THAT'S NOT EVEN A
SALE. IT'S FURNISHING IT'S
GIVING C. GIVE SOMEONE. IN AND
AMOUNTS THAT'S NOT A DRUG
KINGPIN AMOUNT AND YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT I HAVE SPENT ON A AND
YOUR ON THE HOOK AND YOU'RE
GONNA GET A MINIMUM OF THREE
ADDITIONAL YEARS- AND STATE-
INSTEAD PRISON- THIS. IS OUR THE
FRONTAL- THERE IS A DENTAL IS A
TRAGEDY AND MIKE IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO ABOUT TWO PEOPLE OR
DIE A DAY OF DRUG OVERDOSES NOT
ONLY FUNCTIONAL IT'S ALSO FROM
THE MATH OR COULD BE HER WIN BUT
A LOT OF IT IS POSSIBLE TO
PEOPLE DAY AND BY- LITTLE ITTY
BITTY CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO ARE
DYING OF THIS- AND- IT IS- IT'S
JUST HAVING HUGE IMPACTS AND
HONESTLY IT'S GETTING WORSE
BECAUSE- THERE ARE I WAS ON- I
SEE A SEMINAR FOR THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATORS
AROUND ADDICTION. THERE ARE FOR
THE OLDER STUFF THIS IS WORSE
THAN CONTENT ALL LIKE SENATOR I
THINK BECAUSE- LEGISLATOR ON
THIS REPORT CARFENTANIL AND
OTHER SYNTHETICS THAT ARE EVEN
WORSE A LITTLE THERE ARE NO
MARKETS IN THIS COUNTRY WERE YOU
CANNOT GET HER AWAY ANYMORE YOU
CAN'T GET HER WHEN IT'S ONLY
SYNTHETIC FOOD SO MUCH CHEAPER-
AND SO WE NEED MORE AGGRESSIVE
AND STRATEGIES BUT I THEY NEED
TO BE STRATEGIES THAT ACTUALLY
WORK AND I JUST DON'T THINK THAT
HARSHER HARSHER SENTENCES WORK-
IN REDUCING DRUG USE AND WE KNOW
FROM PRACTICE THAT THAT THAT
THEY DON'T SO. THAT'S WHY I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
CALM WATER. THANK YOU AT THE
RISK ECHO A MUCH OF WHAT- MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SHARED- I TO WANT TO- STATE
THAT- YOU KNOW IS DISASTROUS TWO
WEEKS AGO I WAS TALKING TO A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO LOST HIS SON
TO- AN OVERDOSE. COCAINE LACED
WITH FENTANYL- IT'S A VERY GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE- AND IT IS A
PERSONAL AND- A DEEPLY PERSONAL-
PAIN. I ALSO AGREE THAT WE DO
NEED TO DEVELOP A THREE LEG AID-
RESPONSE TO THIS ISSUE- THAT
SHOULD INCLUDE EDUCATION
TREATMENT AND CONSEQUENCES I
THINK THE QUESTION FOR ME IS
WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE AND THAT WILL
WORK. YOU KNOW FENTON ALL- IS
CHEAP I MEAN THAT'S WHY FOLKS
ARE NECESSARILY USING COCAINE OR
SOME OF THESE OTHER SUBSTANCES
IT IS IT'S A SYNTHETIC IT IS
CHEAPER TO MANUFACTURE AND IT IS
MUCH MORE POTENT AND FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE ADDICTS THE GOAL IS. A
RICH HI IMPORTANT HAI AND I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT AND WANT AS
MUCH HELP AS POSSIBLE I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU DRASTICALLY CURTAIL OR STOP
SUPPLY I'D AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT DEMAND.
NOT DEMAND YES DEMAND AND SUPPLY
BECAUSE IF YOU GET RID OF ONE
PERSON THERE ARE GOING TO BE TWO
OR THREE OR FOUR WHO ARE GOING
TO READILY STEP UP TO FILL THE
VOID IN THE MARKET PLACE AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT- THE
ENHANCEMENTS SUGGESTED IN THIS
BILL. ARE EQUAL TO- FOUR TO
THREE AND A HALF POUNDS WHICH IS
SMALLER THAN THE EXISTING WAIT
ENHANCEMENTS AMOUNTS WHICH- ALSO
FOR ME YOU KNOW CALLS INTO
QUESTION YOU KNOW. IS THIS
REALLY GOING TO ATTACK THE
NARCOTICS ECONOMY- YOU KNOW ARE
THERE WAYS THAT WE CAN EMPLOY A
REAL HARM REDUCTION PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES- SO THAT WE ARE YOU
KNOW DEALING WITH THE CRISIS AT
HAND WHICH IS ADDICTION. YOU
KNOW AND WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I
DO ACTUALLY HAVE TO PUSH BACK ON
YOU KNOW CALLING THOSE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO TASK AND HOLDING
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO FIGURING OUT
HOW TO YOU KNOW MANAGE THROUGH-
THE DEMANDS AND COME TO SOME
PEACE THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO
MOVE AWAY FROM THE DEAD. I WAS
READING JUST TODAY. ANOTHER BIG
THING YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO MENTIONED OTHER-
ILLICIT DRUGS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
MORE READILY AVAILABLE AND ARE
ARE KILLERS. A TOP KILLER IS
ALCOHOL LAST YEAR THERE WAS A
25% INCREASE IN ALCOHOL RELATED
DEATHS. WE'RE NOT GOING AFTER
THOSE THAT SELL ALCOHOL. YOU
KNOW AND THEY'RE KILLING ALCOHOL
HAS KILLED FOLKS ACROSS AGE
RANGES ETHNIC RANGES GENDER
RANGES INCOME LEVELS. AND SO
ULTIMATELY HOW ARE WE WORKING TO
CREATE POLICY. THAT ADDRESSES
THE ADDICTION THAT ADDRESSES THE
SUPPLY AND THAT DOES IT IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T GO AFTER A SMALL
PERCENTAGE- OF FOLKS THAT CAN
EASILY BY BE BACK FILLED BY
OTHER FOLKS JUST WAITING TO JUMP
IN AND TAKE OVER- THAT
PARTICULAR MARKET PLACE AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT THIS. WILL
ACHIEVE IT IN A WAY THAT I THINK
THE AUTHOR AND PROBABLY THE
SPONSORS WANT TO SEE ACHIEVED-
AND SO THAT'S WHY I WILL BE.
ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS PARTICULAR
MEASURE AND WHILE I WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR- AND FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO BE PART OF POLICY
MAKING THAT CAN TRULY ATTACK YOU
KNOW THE ISSUE THAT'S AT HAND.
Q. IN ADDITION SENATOR THE
TROUBLE. SO SORRY I. I'M GOING
TO GO BACK TO THE TO THE NOTION
TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT THIS IS
WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME LET ME
GO BACK AND SAY IF THE AMOUNT
THAT IS ADDRESSING TO INTO THE
IN THIS BILL WITH REGARDS TO
WHERE PEOPLE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IF WHAT IS CURRENTLY
IN IN PLACE IN THE POLICY DOES
NOT FIT YOUR CRITERIA OF BEING
SOMETHING WORTHY OF A
MANUFACTURER DISTRIBUTOR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL CAMPAIGN- I
HAND THEN WHAT IS THE AMOUNT
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED BECAUSE
I THINK WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BEAR WITH THIS PARTICULAR DRUG
WITH FENTANYL THE AMOUNT THAT IS
THAT IS LETHAL AND I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT I DON'T KNOW BUT EACH
INDIVIDUAL DRUG I'M JUST TALKING
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR DRUG YOU
DON'T NEED MUCH IN ORDER TO.
KILL SOMEONE. SO IF THIS IF THE
AMOUNTS SPECIFIED IN THIS BILL
DO NOT MEET YOUR CRITERIA OF A
DISTRIBUTOR MANUFACTURE WHAT IS
THE AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED ONE THEY SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW AND PERHAPS MAYBE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE AUTHOR MIGHT
CONSIDER REVISING ON THERE TO
HOLD THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
IF YOU KNOW IF THE COMMITTEE
WISHES TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW BECAUSE I
THINK THEY SHOULD BECAUSE THAT
IS INTENTIONALLY THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE TRYING TO ADDRESS AND
SECOND. WE CONTINUOUSLY TALK
ABOUT IN IN THESE IN THESE BILLS
WITH SENTINEL WE TALK ABOUT THE
USERS AND WITH THE USERS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU WE SHOULD HAVE
MORE PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
ADDICTION. BY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS HOPING TO ADDRESS THE
DISTRIBUTORS AND MANUFACTURERS
AND IF THAT IS THE IF THAT IS
THE CONCERN. THEN PLEASE I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE ON RECORD WHAT IS
THE AMOUNT THAT. CAN BE PUT IN
STATUTE TO HOLD THESE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE TO ENHANCEMENTS- I'M
- BECAUSE THAT THAT THE TRULY IS
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE. IN A
WINNER TOOK A COUPLE OF
IMPOSSIBLE THIS IS I'VE BEEN ON
THE SCREEN THIS IS MY SIXTH YEAR
ON THIS COMMITTEE I THINK IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY I'VE VOTING ON
THIS BILL EVERY YEAR I'VE BEEN.
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
AS I MEAN I COMMENCED THE AUTHOR
FOR HER- I ALWAYS I HER
PERSISTENCE- THAT ID I RESPECT
ANY LEGISLATOR WHO IT WHETHER I
AGREE OR DISAGREE WHO JUST
REALLY BELIEVES IN ENSURING
JUST. KEEPS FROM COMING BACK AND
COMING BACK BECAUSE YOU TRULY
BELIEVE IN THIS AND I RESPECT
THAT SO THIS BILL IS BEFORE US
MANY TIMES ARE MANY UP AND I
KNOW IT'S CHANGED A LITTLE BIT I
THINK EVERY YEAR- AND YOU KNOW.
IF THE AUTHOR BRINGS ABOUT NEXT
YEAR MAYBE IT'LL- I SEE AUTHOR
I'M SORRY WON'T BE HERE NEXT
YEAR BUT IN TERMS. OF THE
AUTHOR- TO PASS IT ON ANOTHER
AUTHOR- FIVE OF THE AUTHOR IF
YOU'RE INSEVERE. BRING A- THERE
COULD BE OTHER CHANGE. BUT I
ALSO TO SEE. KNOW THAT THE TERMS
OF WHEN WE THINK KING CAUSE A
LOT TIMES WHEN. THESE AND WHEN I
SAY SMALL AND SMALLER. TO WHAT
WE WOULD. DO IS TO THE TRUE LIKE
CAMPAIGN OF. I CELLS. THESE
FOLKS ALSO ADDICTED OFTEN. AND
THE AND THE BILL IS NOT LIMITED
TO THOSE SALES IT'S ALSO IT'S
VERY BROAD IT'S GIVING
FURNISHING- AND SO IT DOES SWEEP
AND- PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDICTED.
AND IN TERMS OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRULY YOU KNOW THE FOR LACK
OF AND OR THE KING AND THE REAL.
BIG FISH. THEY ARE I MEAN. DRUG
DEALING IN CALIFORNIA FIRST OF
ALL IS SUBJECT TO STATE PRISON.
CURRENTLY AND FOR THOSE BIGGER.
FISH IT'S STILL HARSH SENTENCES
THE FEDERAL SENTENCES ARE
INCREDIBLY HARSH. FOR DRUG SALES
ESPECIALLY THOSE HIGHER LEVELS
THERE'S ALREADY. HARSH SENTENCES
AVAILABLE AND ADDING ON NEW
ENHANCEMENTS I DON'T. I JUST
DON'T THINK IT CHANGES ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT BUT THE BIG FISH I
CAN ALREADY BE HARSHLY PUNISHED
COMPLETELY RESPECT. WELL SENATOR
IS COMING FROM AND I THINK IT'S
YOU. I TOTALLY RESPECT WERE
COMING FROM SEVEN DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. A SIR CALM WATER YEAH ME
AND I ALSO JUST THINK I THINK
THERE'S ALSO A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BETWEEN SELLERS
MANUFACTURERS AND DISTRIBUTORS
AND YOU KNOW. THE DOPE GAME IS
ACTUALLY A VERY HIERARCHICAL AND
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX AND THERE ARE
FIREWALLS BETWEEN EACH STEP IN
THE GAME AND SO I AM INCREDIBLY
INTERESTED IN A POLICY THAT WE
COULD CRAFT AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT COULD PROBABLY BE
COORDINATED WITH FEDERAL.
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO
ALLOW US TO GET TO THE HEAD OF
THE SNAKE AND I DON'T SEE HOW
THIS ACTUALLY BY PASSES CORNER
HUSTLERS AND OTHER FOLKS WHO ARE
LIKE YOU KNOW HAVING A PIECE OF-
YOU KNOW A PARTICULAR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR COMMUNITY OR OR
OR SWAP OF REAL ESTATE. TO GET
TO THE FOLKS WHO ARE MASSIVELY.
MANUFACTURING THIS KILLER DRUG I
MEAN I THINK THAT'S HOW YOU GET
TO IT AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
STORIES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO
GET TO THOSE FOLKS AND SO THE
MIDDLE MEN AND THE FOLKS ON THE
STREET THOSE PEOPLE ARE A DIME A
DOZEN THEY CAN BE REPLACED THEY
CAN BE REPLACED THEY CAN BE
REPLACED AND WE'RE ON A HAMSTER
WHEEL OF TRYING TO GET THOSE
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS WHEN AND
HOW YOU CAN CREATE POLICY THAT
WILL GIVE THE AMMUNITION THAT IS
NEEDED TO LONG FOR SMITH. TO GET
TO THE FOLKS AT THE TOP SO
THAT'S HOW I THINK ABOUT THIS
WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON- AND I BELIEVE THAT FOLKS
KNOW. I MEAN I THINK PEOPLE
KNOW- WHO. THE PEOPLE ARE SORT
OF MANAGING THE CARTELS- AND SO
I THINK IT DOES REQUIRE
SOMETHING MUCH MORE
SOPHISTICATED AND ALSO HONEST
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE OBSTACLES
THAT WE ARE ALL UP AGAINST IF
WE'RE TRYING TO ATTACK THIS
PROBLEM AND I ALSO THINK THERE
IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TO MANAGE THOSE WHO
ARE ADDICTED. AND THEN THOSE WHO
ARE REALLY AT THE TOP WHO ARE
CONTROLLING BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS- AND ARE NOT
THE ONES OFTENTIMES THAT ARE
GETTING ARRESTED AND GOING THAT-
STATE OR FEDERAL PRISON. GUARD
THANK YOU AT I WANT TO THANK-
SENATOR FOR CONSISTENCY AND
PERSISTENCE IN THIS ISSUE AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S SINGLE MEMBER
HERE REGARDLESS OF YOUR VOTE WHO
SUPPORT DRUG USE AND WHEN WANT
TO GET A DEADLY DRUG LIKE
FENTANYL OFF THE STREET BUT I
THINK IF WE'VE LEARNED ANYTHING
OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS. THE
WAR DRUGS JUST HASN'T WORKED
THERE ONLY REASON AGAIN ASKING
ME MY COLLEAGUES OF TOUCH UPON
IT THAT YOU SEE A DECREASE IN
HEROIN AND COCAINE USE IT IS
BECAUSE FUNDING WAS FARM CHEAPER
THAN HEROIN AND COCAINE. AND
IT'S BEING MADE AVAILABLE AT A
RATE THAT YOU NOTICE IS.
POPULATING OUR STREET BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IT'S ABOUT GETTING TO
THE HEAD OF THE B. SAYS EVERYONE
IS STATED. AND I DON'T KNOW A
SINGLE STREET. DEALER WHO WANTS
TO KILL THEIR CLIENTELE. I MEAN
IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE OF
MANY OF THESE FOLKS ARE ARE
SELLING DRUGS ON THE STREET
LEVEL THAT THEY'RE UNAWARE THAT
ITS LEASE WITH THIS DEADLY
POISONOUS BECAUSE AGAIN- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT BUSINESS IS THAT YOU
SEE I WANT TO GET READY MY
CLIENTELE IT'S THE GUYS UP TOP
WHO SAY. I DON'T CARE ABOUT THEM
BECAUSE I'M SELLING AT SUCH
VOLUME AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS. I DON'T
REMEMBER SINGLE- DRUG CARTEL OR-
ALL RIGHT HEAD OF A DRUG CARTEL
ARRESTED OTHER NAIL SHOP THAT'S
THE ONLY THING THAT HAS MADE
NATIONAL NEWS. OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS ANY ESCAPED.
MULTIPLE TIMES. HE IS SO YEAH
I'D SOLD POINT IS HERE. WHAT WE
I THINK ADDICTION IS AN ISSUE
HERE AND WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT AND AT THE CORE BUT AGAIN.
TO ADD ADDITIONAL TIME AND IN
THE STREET FOLKS I MEAN WE THERE
ARE STILL. INDIVIDUALS
IMPRISONED ODAY FOR SELLING
COCAINE AND THEY HAD. WHAT'S AN
OUNCE. I MEAN TILL I AYE A
DIDN'T STOP COCAINE USE AGAIN
THE FACT THAT THIS IS CHEAP IT'S
READILY AVAILABLE IS WHY WE HAVE
THIS ACT UP BACK AT THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD TODAY OF DEATH
ON THE STREET AND- WE SHOULD ALL
BE CONCERNED BUT AGAIN I JUST
DON'T THINK THIS IS DANCERS SO.
WELL LET LATER DATE THANK YOU-
FOR THIS VERY IN DEPTH
DISCUSSION NOW SPIRITED ONE. I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A FEW CLOSING
COMMENTS WE'RE NOT THE USER'S I.
C. R. OR THE VICTIMS THERE THE
VICTIMS OF. THE PURVEYORS OF
POISON- THAT ARE ACTUALLY
MANUFACTURING THESE HUGE AMOUNTS
AND GETTING THEM INTO OUR
COUNTRY. ARE IS A VERY
INTERESTING COMMENT THIS COME UP
ABOUT THE SUPPLY. WHEN YOU LIMIT
THE SUPPLY THE COST OF THE
PRODUCT GOES UP WE'RE SEEING
THAT WITH GAS RIGHT. SAME
PRINCIPLE HERE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS WE'RE TRYING TO
LIMIT THE SUPPLY REDUCE THE
SUPPLY AND THE SUPPLY. IN WE
CAN'T DO THAT UNLESS WE START IF
WE LOOK AT A PYRAMID. YOU START
WITH THE BOTTOM LEVEL OF THE
PYRAMID AND YOU START
ELIMINATING ONE BY ONE BY ONE
INTO YOU FINALLY GET TO THE TOP
AND I WOULD ASSUME THAT'S GOING
TO BE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL. BUT
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING TO
START AT THAT LEVEL AND LIMIT
THE SUPPLY THIS BEING AVAILABLE
TO OUR STREETS YOU KNOW
MERCHANTS. ARE IT WILL NOT STOP
THIS INCREASE THAT WE SEAT TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE PERCENT. OF WHEN
THERE'S NO SENSE ENHANCERS YET
THE OTHER DRUGS WAS SENTENCED
HIM SPENCE HAVE FALLEN OFF
YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S COST OKAY
THE LET'S MEET THE COST OF FELT
NOW BY PUTTING SENSE
ENHANCEMENTS ON THOSE. OF LARGE
PRODUCERS SO IT COSTS THEM MORE
INSULT PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO BE
BUYING THEM THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
LEASE IT INTO THE OTHER DROPPED
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO. CONSIDER
WHAT THE PRICE OF POINT IS
BECAUSE THAT IS THE WAY TO-
START WITH SENSE ENHANCEMENTS ON
LARGE SEN BY THE WAY WE PICK
TWENTY GRAMS HERE BECAUSE- THE
POTENCY. GREATER VALUE THE ONE
KILOGRAM OF THE FIVE KILOGRAMS
ON THE OTHER SENSE ENHANCE
DRUGS. THAT'S WHY TWENTY GRAMS
AND AS I MENTIONED THAT SAW IT
IS THAT TIME TWO THOUSAND TEN
THOUSAND LETHAL DOSES. IN TWENTY
GRAMS OF FENTANYL THAT'S BEING
OF VALUE FACTORED IN
DISTRIBUTED- MAYBE WITH SMALL
DISTRIBUTORS BUT IT'S STILL OUT
THERE SO LET'S MAKE IT COSTS
MORE. LET'S LIMIT THE SUPPLY BY
GETTING SENTENCING HOUSE MY ON
THE DISTRIBUTORS SO. WE BUT I DO
WANT. FORTUNATELY WITH JUSTICE
REFORM AND- REHABILITATION
THAT'S GOING ON IN OUR- JAILS
AND PRISONS WERE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE THERE I BELIEVE- WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY- HARD
STATISTICS ON THAT. BUT I DO
BELIEVE IN WITH OUR HOMELESS
PROJECTS IN OUR OF BILLS WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW HUGE
WRAPAROUND AND THAT'S GOING TO
SERVICES THAT'LL BE AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE ADDICTS. THAT
WE NEED TO REDUCE THE SUPPLY AND
WE CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS ON THE BIG
PRODUCERS. MANUFACTURERS AND
DISTRIBUTORS SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. JANDA AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BECAUSE I'VE
BROUGHT THIS BACK AND BROUGHT
THIS ABOUT. IS BECAUSE IT HAS
CONTINUED TO INCREASE IN THE
IMPACT. IN THIS DISTRIBUTION IN
ITS DEADLY DEADLY AND- ARE FOR
THOSE. WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED
BY YES THREE MILLION PORT AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY ON YOU CAN. M. S.
AT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. YES
WE HAVE A MOTION ADMISSION TO
THE WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
JOE BOOK. SB TEN SIXTY DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD NO
RED FOR NO CHOI BOGUE HIGH
TROUBLE GUY COM LONGER NO LONGER
NO SKINNER. SKINNER NO WIENER
WIENER NO ONE TO FOUR THANK YOU
THAT'S ONE TO FOR THE MEASURE
FAILED NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO SB
TEN FIFTY THREE. THE NEW BATES
IN MAY I. S. RECONSIDERATION. WE
WILL GRANT RECONSIDERATION THANK
YOU. AND THIS IS US SENATE BILL
TEN FIFTY THREE. ARM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND I DO
BELIEVE SENATOR WINNER SOME OF
YOUR COMMENTS ACTUALLY ADDRESS
THIS BILL. ALL THIS IS THE LAND
THAT REQUIRES- READ MOLLY INJURY
I THINK THAT'S THE ONE THAT HAS
THE THREE YEARS BUT WHEN WE WHEN
I COMPLETED MY INTRODUCTION I
YOU MIGHT WANT TO COMMENT FOR
SOME OUT. BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ON THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB TEN FIFTY THREE
ANOTHER APPROACH TO COMBAT THE
DEADLY TRAFFICKING AND
DISTRIBUTION OF HIGHLY POTENT
AND LETHAL NARCOTICS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS I MENTIONED
OVERDOSE DEATHS FROM OPIOIDS AND
DRUGS LACED WITH FENTANYL HAVE
BEEN ON THE RISE THE RECENT
SPIKE IN OPIOID OVERDOSES IN
CALIFORNIA DEMANDED SWIFT
RESPONSE FROM THE STATE IN ORDER
TO HELP PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
FROM PERPETRATORS. WHO SELL
THESE DEADLY NARCOTICS TO
INDIVIDUAL BUYERS THE VICTIMS
THE BILL WILL REINSTATE PENAL
CODE PROVISION ONE TWO OH. TWO
TWO POINT SEVEN ARE PROVISIONS
THAT A PERSON COULD RECEIVE A
GREAT BODILY INJURY ENHANCEMENT
IF A PERSON IS SOLD FURNISHED
ADMINISTERED OR GAVE AWAY A
PROHIBITED MCCARTY. AND ITS USE
RESULTED IN DEATH OR SERIOUS
INJURY THAT PERSON COULD BE
CHARGED WITH A GREAT BODILY
INJURY ENHANCEMENT PURSUANT TO
THE PENAL CODE. WHICH GAVE THE
COURT THE OPTION TO IMPOSE A
THREE YEAR ENHANCEMENT TO A
SENTENCE AND CLASSIFIED THE
OFFENSE AS SERIOUS AND VIOLENT.
HOWEVER THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT RECENTLY RULED IN PEOPLE
VERSUS OUR LOW THAT IN ORDER FOR
THE ENHANCEMENT TO APPLY IN THIS
IS AN EXISTING ENHANCEMENT A
PERSON WOULD NEED TO PERSONALLY
IN MINUTES ADMINISTER THE
NARCOTIC OVERRULING SEVERAL
DISTRICT COURTS OF APPEAL THAT
HELD OTHERWISE. THE NARROW
INTERPRETATION WOULD ALLOW MOST
DRUG DEALERS TO ESCAPE
PUNISHMENT WHEN THE DRUGS THEY
SELL LEAD TO DEATH OR SERIOUS
INJURY AS MOST DRUG DEALERS DO
NOT PERSONALLY ADMINISTER
NARCOTICS TO THEIR BUYERS. SB
TEN FIFTY THREE CLARIFIES THAT
ANY PERSON WHO SELLS FURNISHES
ADMINISTERS OR GIVES AWAY A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE PERSONALLY
INFLICTED. GREAT BODILY INJURY
WHENEVER THE PERSON SOLD
FURNISHED ADMINISTERED OR OR
GIVEN THE DRUGS SUFFERS AN
INJURY FROM USING THOSE DRUGS
THE BILL WOULD NOT AND I'D LIKE
TO EMPHASIZE THAT IT DOES NOT
CREATE IN ENHANCEMENT RATHER.
RULE PEOPLE VERSUS OUR LOW AND
ALLOWS JUDGES TO IMPOSE EXISTING
ENHANCEMENT AS CURRENTLY
PROVIDED IN THE PENAL CODE.
JUDGES WOULD RETAIN FULL
DISCRETION WHETHER TO IMPOSE
ENHANCEMENT ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. BY DOING SO THIS BILL
HELPS ENSURE THE PUNISHMENT FITS
THE CRIME BY TARGETING THOSE WHO
SELL INFORMATION THESE DEADLY
NARCOTICS. THE SAN DIEGO
RIVERSIDE AND ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES. ARE
CO SPONSORS OF THE MISSION OF
THE MEASURE AND I HAVE TO
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY TODAY. THE
FIRST IS CHIEF DEPUTY PATRICK
ESPINOSA WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND THAT WOULD BE
FOLLOWED BY DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ROBERT HIGHTOWER WITH
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AND THEY
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO HELP AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ARE WOULD THIS IS
PREPARED I WILL PROVIDE YOU TO
MANAGE EACH OF TOTAL FOR MANAGE
OR YOUR TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT.
OF SB. TEN FIFTY THREE. REALLY
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE CAN MY NAME
IS PAT S. ON THE CHEAP GAS IN
THIS CAL DISTRICT OFFICE. THE
SENEGAL OFFICE IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR THAT'S TWO FIFTY THREE
IN EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE PAIN
ALL CRISIS RESULTING OVERDOSE
DEATHS THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THE
NATION. THERE ARE MANY
APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING THE
CRISIS SB TEN FIFTY THREE
FOCUSES ON HOLDING THOSE WHO
PROVIDE DRUGS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERDOSE DEATHS THAT RESULT AS
WELL AS AS WELL AS A SERIES
PROBABLY INJURY THAT RESULTS
FROM- DRUG USE ARE DRUG. DEALING
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THEIR ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE STATE AND ALL
RELATED DEATHS IN STUDIO COUNTY
ACCORDING TO THE MATH MEDICAL
EXAMINER THERE WERE FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE SEVEN OPERATED DEBTS
IT IN OUR COUNTY TWENTY TWENTY
TRIPLE THE NUMBER FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. WE BELIEVE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE TOTAL WILL
BE MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
DEATHS. ADDICTS SUFFERING FROM
OPIOID ADDICTION DON'T REALIZE
THAT THEIR. ADJUSTING A FATAL
DOSE IN MOST CASES. THANK LAW.
PROHIBITS BECAUSE- OR CRASH. OF
GOODS SUBSTANCE FOR SALE.
PROVIDES PUNISHMENT FOR A
VIOLATION HOWEVER CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CONSEQUENCES BUT DEFENDER. RUGBY
OR WHO SUPPLY THESE DRUGS. OKAY
THE PERSON USING THE DRUG
SUFFERS DEATH WITH GREAT BODILY
INJURY OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
SB TEN FIFTY THREE RECOGNIZES
THAT THE CRIME THE PERSIAN DRUGS
SHOULD BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY.
THAN MERELY PENSION- THEN THE
PERSON DROPS THE RESULTS FOR
HARM SUCH AS DEATH OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY. PROTECTION COUPLE
TO TWO POINT SEVEN EIGHT ALREADY
EXISTS AND ADDS THREE YEARS TO
ANY FELONY RESULTING IN DEATH
GPI. THIS SENSING ALLEGATION HAS
BEEN A TOOL THAT IS ADDED TO
FELONY CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
CRIMES. TO ENSURE THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE PROPORTIONAL TO
THE HARM CAUSED SIMPLY PROVIDING
DRUGS SHOULD BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY. THE PROVIDING DRUGS
THAT ACTUALLY RESULT IN DEATH OR
INJURY. S. B. TEN FIFTY THREE
WOULD CLARIFY THAT PERSONAL
INFLICTION OF GPI INCLUDES
SELLING. FURNISHING
ADMINISTRATIVE OR GETTING DRUGS
THAT RESULTS IN BODILY INJURY OR
DEATH. THIS WILL ADDRESS THE
RECENT HOLDING OF THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT IN PEOPLE VERSUS
ALTHOUGH. WITH THE COURT HELD
THAT A PERSON MAY BE HELD LIABLE
FOR IT ADMINISTERING A DRUG.
THAT RESULTS IN AN OVERDOSE
DEATH. BUT WOULD NOT BE LIABLE
FOR ADDITIONAL. PENALTY OR
PUNISHMENT WHEN THE PERSON
PROVIDED THE DRUGS THAT RESULTED
IN THE OVER OVERDOSE DEATHS THE
VICTIM IN THAT CASE WAS THE
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL WHO
OVERDOSE FROM USING COCAINE.
LACED WITH THAT NOW SB TEN FIFTY
THREE WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW THE
EXISTING. PROPERTY TWO POINT
SEVEN. AND A HALF MEN TO REMAIN
A TOOL TO BE USED TO ENSURE THAT
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE PROPERLY
CALIBRATED. TO THE ACTUAL HARM
INFLICTED WITH ASPIRIN I BOTH.
WENT SB TEN FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. HELLO OF
THE COMMITTEE HAS AS WELL MR
CHAIRMAN HOW AGAIN NOW MANY
ROBERT HI WITH RIVERSIDE DISH
ATTORNEY OFFICE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
GALLOPED DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE PRODUCTS- CO SPONSOR-
AFTER THE SENATE BILL TEN FIFTY-
HAS- THIRTY EDUCATED VILLAGES
FIX THE PEOPLE OF ALL DECISION.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THOUGH I THINK
WHAT DISPLAY DOES THE FOR OF THE
ISSUE THAT WERE BROUGHT UP- BY
SENATOR LEADERS WALTER COME
WATER BECAUSE THIS DOES YOUR
ADDRESS THOSE UP THE CHAIN WHO
HAVE AVOIDED RESPONSIBILITY
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
THE ONES IN FACT DISTRIBUTING TO
THE USERS. AND WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO RECOGNIZE WITH
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME OF THESE
DANGEROUS DRUG FENTANYL IS NOW
IN EVERYTHING IT IN COCAINE IT
IS AN DANYCH IT IS IN INDIA MAY-
IT IS INHERENTLY AND- WHAT
PEOPLE DIED IF IT IS BECAUSE
IT'S HIGHLY ADDICTIVE READING
INCREASES THE DEMAND WHERE
DEALERS BABY ONLY WERE ABLE TO
FELLOW GRAMMAR TO EVERY WEEK OR
EVERY THREE WEEKS- NOW THEY'RE
ABLE TO SELL THAT ON A REGULAR
BASIS BECAUSE IT RESULTING IN A
HIGHLY HIGHLY ADDICTIVE
SUBSTANCE- AND DEALERS ARE
RELEASING THEIR CLIENTELE SHOOT
THROUGH THE ROOF AND THEY'RE
ABLE TO SELL MORE AND MORE. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE WERE PAYING
THE PRICE ARE NOT THE DEALERS
THEMSELVES ABOUT ARE THOSE WHO
HAVE BECOME ADDICTED TO DRUGS
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY ARE LACED WITH FENNEL
IN ORDER TO MAKE THEM MORE
DECADES THAT WOULD INCREASE
DEMAND AND INCREASED ADDICTION
MEANS THAT IT TAKES VERY LITTLE
UP FOR A DRUG- FELLER TO
PROSPECT GETTING HUGE HUGE
AMOUNT- WHAT THE BILL WILL DO
WHAT IS UP. WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
I GAP THAT EXISTS WITH THE GREAT
BODILY INJURY ALLEGATION AND
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
SELLING AND FURNISHING THIS DRUG
ARE RESPONSIBLE WHEN SOMEONE
DOES DIE OR IF YOU'RE LOOKING TO
PASS IT AS A RESULT A PANEL THAT
IS MASS PRODUCED I IN FEDERAL
WAY THAT COULD HARM. IN KILL
PEOPLE WITHOUT I THINK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I. THANK YOU KNOW
MOVING BACK TO COME HEARING OR-
WITNESSES INSTEAD. OF SB TWO.
FIFTY THREE BUT AFTER MR CARRIM
WHO SHALL FOR A BEHALF OF THE K.
STATE THIS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THAT. HIM STONE ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THE COW JUST ATTORNEYS
IS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THE
QUICKNESS. HELLO DOLLY ON ON ON
BEHALF OF HER SECOND SURE AS
PART IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES HERE
AND TWENTY TWO HUNDRED NOW
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO OUR PHONE
LINES AND SHIFTER. INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FIFTY THREE. THEY
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
THREE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST TO GET ONLINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI THIS IS RATE GOING UP WITH
THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WANT TO AND
IF YOU LIKE TO COMMENT. YOU LIKE
TO COMMENT SUPPORTING IT PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
MYSTERON MODERATOR NOW WILL GO
TO OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. ALL
I MEAN I'M SORRY I'M SORRY WE'RE
GOING TO OUR WITNESSES NOW IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
MISSION SURE AND WE HAVE. I AM
ALWAYS GONNA MISS THE NAME OF
THE SENATE PAYTON AGAIN SO
THEY'RE READY THEY'LL- THEY MAY
DO SO NOW. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME IS GENET
TWENTY FIFTEEN A HIGHLY CAL THE
FACT THAT ALL OF THE ALLIANCE.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY AGAIN AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
FIFTY THREE. FOR THE FAILED TO
SPECIAL EFFECT NOW EXPAND DEATH
OF WEEK FINALLY INJURY-
CONCLUDED HIMSELF. AND MANAGERS
ARE GIVING AWAY CONTROL
SUBSTANCE. EPA INTERNATIONAL.
PROMOTING DRUG POLICIES GRAVITY
SCIENCE COMPASSION HEALTH AND
HUMAN RIGHTS. ORGANIZATION
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPACT THAT DRUG
YOU CAN HAVE A OF USERS.
FAMILIES AND THOSE. WHO HAVE
LOST A LOVED ONE TO THE OVER-
HOWEVER IF THE PEOPLE BECAUSE-
WOULD NOT REDUCE YOUR- OR USE
KNOW NO PREVENT- OVERDOSE. IN IT
WOULD UNDERMINE AFTER. TO
ADDRESS CRISIS DRIVING WHO USE
DRUGS AWAY FROM HEALTH SERVICES
AND ENCOURAGE MORE WITH YOUR
TRACKING ACTIVITY TO AVOID
DETECTION OR PROSECUTION. FOR
FINANCIAL EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATES
THAT CRIMINAL PENALTIES DO NOT
HAVE ANY EFFECT ON REDUCING
EITHER THE SUPPLY OF DRUGS OR
THE DEMAND FOR THEM. INCREASING
PENALTIES FOR FENTANYL RELATED
SUBSTANCES ECHOES THE FAILED WAR
OCT UP POLICIES ENACTED DURING
THE EIGHTIES AND NINETIES ABOUT
CRACK COCAINE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
PEOPLE OF COLOR. OVERCROWDED
PRISONS. ACROSS LIFE. THE US
COMMISSION FOUND NEARLY SO
PERCENT OF THOSE PERFECT.
ANALOGUES WERE BLACK OR MATTE
NEXT DESPITE THE RECENT
EMERGENCE OF FENNEL IN THE LEGAL
MARKET LENGTHY SENTENCES HAVE
BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR DECADES
YET HAVE NOT STOPPED THE SPREAD
OF SENTINEL AND THREATENED TO
EXACERBATE. RACIAL DISPARITIES
WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. IN NOVEMBER THIS YEAR
THE CDC FOUND. THAT WE HAVE LOST
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND GAS IN A
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD ENDING IN
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AGAIN THIS IS FURTHER PROOF THAT
THE ENFORCEMENT FIRST APPROACH
IS TO DRUGS ARE NOT WORKING AND
IN FACT CRIMINALIZATION CONTINUE
TO FUEL OVER CRISIS. BY PUSHING
PEOPLE INTO AGAIN MORE RISKY
SITUATION ISOLATION AND MAKING
THE DRUG SUPPLY UNREGULATED AND
UNSAFE. SB TEN FIFTY THREE AND A
GOOD POSITION OF HARSH PENALTIES
FOR DISTRIBUTION COULD UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA GOOD SAMARITAN LAW
LIFESAVING LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PASSED IN ORDER TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO CONTACT EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN CASE OF AN OVERDOSE.
THE MOST COMMON REASON PEOPLE
CITE FOR NOT CALLING NINE ONE
ONE IN THE EVENT OF AN OVERDOSE.
YOUR FEAR OF POLICE INVOLVEMENT
RECOGNIZING THIS BARRIER.
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH THIRTY
NINE OTHER STATES AND- THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA AFTER NINE
ONE ONE GOOD SAMARITAN LAWS
WHICH PROVIDE LIMITED IMMUNITY
FROM PROSECUTION FOR DRUG
RELATED OFFENSES. FOR THOSE WHO
SEEK MEDICAL ASSISTANCE. BUT-
BECAUSE THEY- WHAT PRIVATE IT'S
KIND TO SAY THAT'S- THE FAILED
INTO THE OF THE- I LOOK AT IT.
CULTURE TO READ TRAVEL HA. BY
MAKING BASED TREATMENT OF ON THE
GRANT AND TEMPLE THAT HARM.
REDUCTION POLICIES SUCH AS
FACILITATING DIRECT CHECKING
INCLUDING PROTECTING MACHINES
AND NOT LOOK AT DRUG TESTING
STRIPS. HI THERE ARE FIVE.
ADULTERATED SUBSTANCES AND
GETTING THE OPIOID OVERDOSE
ANTIDOTE NALOXONE INTO THE HANDS
OF THOSE MOST LIKELY TO BE
PRESENT WHEN A PERSON IS
SUFFERING FROM AN OVERDOSE. WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO INCARCERATE
OUR WAY OUT OF THE OVERDOSE
CRISIS AND MUST RESPOND TO THIS
CRISIS DISSOLUTION. THAT OUR
FAITH IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND.
GROUNDED IN EVIDENCE RIGHT.
FORTY THREE THE PA OR JUST NO
VOTE ON AT. FIFTY YOUR- Q. NOW
WE'RE MEANT MORE ON TO- KATHY
SURE. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS KATHY SURE FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION WE
RESPECTFULLY MASAKO OPPOSE SB
TEN FIFTY THREE AM I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT THAT I
THINK THAT THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- NEED A
RATHER COMPELLING CASE FOR
DECRIMINALIZATION OF VARIOUS
KINDS OF JOBS BECAUSE- IF YOU
WANT TO STOP SELLERS FROM
ADULTERATED THEIR PRODUCT YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BRING. TO
REGULATE THEM AND THAT'S JUST
NOT POSSIBLE UNDER THE EXISTING.
THAT SAID. OF COURSE WE SHARE
THE GOAL OF STOPPING THE DEATHS
THAT WERE SEEN HAPPENING FROM
PEOPLE TAKING DRUGS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADULTERATED WITH.
UNFORTUNATELY THE IMPOSITION OF
THE SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS
PROPOSED IN SB TEN FIFTY THREE
RUNS EXACTLY COUNTER TO WHAT WE
KNOW WOULD WORK TO. REDUCE
INJURIES AND DEATHS STEMMING
FROM DRUG USE. WE KNOW THAT IN
HOLDING SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS
DO NOT WORK TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
SELLING DRUGS OR SELLING
ADULTERATED DRUGS OR FOR THAT
MATTER FROM ENGAGING IN ANY
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. STUDY AFTER
STUDY SHOWS THAT INCREASED
SENTENCES DO NOT HAVE A
DETERRENT. INSTEAD THE INCREASED
LENGTH OF SENTENCES NOT ONLY
HARM THE PERSON SUBJECT TO THE
SENTENCE BUT ALSO THAT FOR
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY. THE
POINTLESSNESS OF IMPOSING THESE
ENHANCEMENTS AS PARTICULARLY
EGREGIOUS HERE WHERE THE PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
ENHANCEMENT LIKE WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW THAT THE DRUGS THEY HAVE
PROVIDED TO SOMEONE WERE
ADULTERATED. SENTINEL GENERALLY
ADDED TO OTHER DRUGS EARLY IN
THE PRODUCTION PROCESS- SO
INCREASING SENTENCES FOR LOW
LEVEL STREET DEALERS WHO DON'T
KNOW THAT THEY ARE SELLING AND
ADULTERATED PRODUCT WILL DO
NOTHING TO AFFECT THE BEHAVIOR
OF THE UPSTREAM DEALERS. WHO ARE
THE ONES ACTUALLY ADDING THE
SENTINEL TO OTHER STUFF. THE
TRAGEDY HERE IS THAT WE KNOW
WHAT WORKS TO COMBAT THE HARMS
OF DRUG MISUSE. TREATMENT WORK
HEALTH AND HARM REDUCTION
SERVICES WORK. IMPOSING LONGER
SENTENCES OF THE PROPOSED IN SB
TEN FIFTY THREE WAIT. WAIT
RESOURCES THAT COULD BE SPENT ON
THOSE SERVICES. AND BY FURTHER
DECRIMINALIZING DRUG USE DRIVES
PEOPLE AWAY FROM THESE SERVICES
BUT THEY- WE WERE. ASK FOR YOUR
TELEPHONE. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES HERE AND TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED WHO WISH T TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN
FIFTY THREE. SEEING NONE WILL
MOVE TO OUR PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE UP ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF US
THREE TEN FIFTY THREE. SURE- IF
YOU LIKE TO COME IN OPPOSITION
YOUR PRESS ONE OF THE- AT THIS
TIME- WILL DECLINE A FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU GO RIGHT
AHEAD. HI I'M. STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK THANK YOU NEPTUNUS THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REGNI ON BEHALF
OF AN ISSUE DRASTIC AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MEXICO TO LINE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
DON'T USE THEM FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. UNEXPLODED LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL BE
LUNCH FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR NOW
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
AS IT RELATES TO SB TEN FIFTY
THREE. SKINNER COMMA. THANK YOU
I JUST I HAD A QUESTION MAYBE
THE- THOSE ON THE LINE- COULD
ADDRESS IT. I WAS WONDERING AND
I WASN'T ABLE TO FIND THIS AND
THAT AND THAT TAX THROUGH THE
ANALYSIS. DOES THIS BILL
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN SOMEONE THAT
IS KNOWINGLY SELLING. WITH THE
INTENT TO HARM OR KNOWINGLY
SELLING A DRUG OR KNOWING THAT
IT IS LACED WITH FENNEL. AND
HAVING SOMEONE WHO'S JUST
SELLING WITHOUT KNOWING THAT
SOMETHING IS LACED WITH FENTANYL
WERE SELLING WITHOUT THE INTENT
TO HARM DOESN'T MAKE THOSE JUST
STING WISH SAYING. DOES THAT
INCLUDE THOSE KINDS OF
DISTINGUISHES. THE WORD.
I THINK OF THE QUESTION ACTED
SIGNATURE QUESTION NO IT DOES
NOT MAKE THOSE DISTINCTIONS AT
THE ROYAL COURT CASE TO
CALIFORNIA'S SUPREME COURT
DIDN'T MAKE DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN
PERSONAL INFO IS STRIVING
PERSONAL CONNECTION BETWEEN
MINISTERING RUG IN FURNISHING A
DRUG AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL-
ADDRESSES IS THAT DISTINCTION
PREVIOUSLY WE ABLE TO CHARGE A
PUBLIC TO TWO POINT SEVEN
ALLEGATIONS THIS SET DECISION-
IT PACKS ARE GOING TO DO THAT
YOU AGES THAT THE POINT EARLIER
ABOUT HOW ALCOHOL IS TREATED AND
THIS CALL TWO TWO POINT SEVEN
ALLEGATION IS USING ALCOHOL
CASES COURT FOR DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE. SO IF THERE IS
HARMONY DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE CASE EQUAL TO TWO
POINT SEVEN ALLEGATION CAN BE A
LEGEND IS COMMONLY ELECTION SO
WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO HAVE THE
SAME PARITY THAT WOULD BE THAT
THIS ALLEGATION THIS TOOL COULD
BE USED IN A FELONY DUI CASES AS
WELL AS A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
FELONY. HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. IT DOES THANK ALTHOUGH
I ARGUE THE IT DOESN'T STOP
PEOPLE FROM DRINKING AND DRIVING
IT AND CERTAINLY INCREASES. THE
COST AND THE PENALTIES AND
CREATES ADDITIONAL BARRIERS BUT
I DO APPRECIATE- THAT RESPONSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEED
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
BY THE COMMITTEE. I MEAN TO NONE
CENTER VEGETAL THANK YOU HOUSE.
SORRY YES I JUST WANT IT TO BE
REALLY CLEAR THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T ADD ADDITIONAL
ENHANCEMENTS IT SIMPLY OVERTURNS
THE IF ALLEGEDLY LEGISLATIVE FIX
FOR THE ALLERGY CASE AND- ON THE
ISSUE OF CAUSATION REQUIREMENT
IS SIMPLY STATES THAT PERSONAL
INFLICTION WILL INCLUDE THE
SELLING FURNISHING ADMINISTERING
AND GIVING AWAY A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE THE PROSECUTION IS
STILL REQUIRED TO PROVE BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THAT THE
DEFENDANT SOLD FURNISHED
ADMINISTER GAVE AWAY THOSE WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING. THAT IT WOULD
. GOOD CREATE GREAT BODILY
INJURY JUST LIKE WITH THE SALE
OF ALCOHOL AND- LIQUOR STORE SO-
KNOWING THAT A LEGISLATIVE FIX
IS KIND OF A SIMPLE WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THE CONSEQUENCE
THAT'S CURRENTLY THERE. IN THIS
PENAL CODE REMAINS AND- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CONSEQUENCES- SB
TEN SIXTY DIDN'T MAKE OF THIS A
CONSEQUENCE BILL THAT'S
CURRENTLY OF CONSEQUENCE PENAL
CODE THAT'S CURRENTLY IN PLACE
SENATE FINANCE MEANT THREE YEARS
NO CHANGE JUST MAKING SURE THAT
THE CAUSATIVE. OF PERSONAL
INFLICTION- CAN BE FOUND WHEN
SOMEONE ACTUALLY IS APPROVED A
PURVEYOR OF- ONE OF THESE DRUGS
SO WITHOUT AYE. I URGE YOU TO
GIVE AN IDOL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WERE SEEKING IN MOTION A TO
DO PASS FIRST AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SO MOVED. BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
TO A BALK. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL INDUSTRY GEN FIFTY
THREE. SB TEN FIFTY THREE DO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BRADFORD.
BRADFORD NOT VOTING A TROLL
BOGUE I HAD TROUBLE GUY COME
LONGER NO FROM LONGER KNOWS
SKINNER. WINNER WINNER NO. THE
MEASURE HAS WON VOTERS TO KNOWS
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THAT SOME MEMBERS AND IF IT
DOESN'T HOUSE LIKE. IN OTHERS
ASKING FOR RECONSIDERATION WE
WILL GRAB THAT NOW WE'RE MOVING
IN SB NINE OLD FOUR. AND THIS IS
THE EDUCATION COMPONENT OF MY
BILL PACKAGE TODAY AND I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB NINE OH
FOUR WHICH CLARIFIES THE
STANDARDS OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE EDUCATION AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS FOR
DIVERSITIES OF PROBATIONERS AND
PRISONERS WITH STRUGGLE
VERDOSES ON THE RISE IN
CALIFORNIA ADDITIONAL ACTION
NEEDS TO BE TAKEN TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUALS BATTLING. SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS ARE RECEIVING
PROPER TREATMENT AND EDUCATION
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
PROBATIONERS AND DIVERT TO USED
TO COMPLETE EDUCATION AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS UPON
CONVICTION OF A DRUG ABUSE
RELATED OFFENSE HOWEVER
DEFINITION AND SCOPE OF THESE
PROGRAMS IS VERY VAGUE AND
UNDEFINED THE AMBIGUITY IN THE
LAW LEAVES MANY PROBATIONERS AND
DIVERSITIES WITH LITTLE
DIRECTION FOR EDUCATION OR
TREATMENT OPTIONS THAT ADDRESS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. AND HELP THEM
WITH THEIR ADDICTIONS SO SB NINE
OH FOUR WOULD REMOVE THE M. YOU
GUIDED AMBIGUITY AND REQUIRE
PROGRAMS TO INCLUDE EDUCATION ON
THE DANGERS OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES UNLESS OF COURSE THEY
ARE TAKEN UNDER APPROPRIATE
MEDICAL SUPERVISION. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THESE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TO INFORM PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS ABOUT THE PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS IN WITH EDUCATE
INDIVIDUALS ON THE GRAVE HEALTH
RISK TO THOSE WHO INGEST OR OR
OR ARE EXPOSED TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES ALONG WITH THE
EXTREME DANGER. TO HUMAN LIFE
WHEN SAID DRUGS ARE MANUFACTURED
OR DISTRIBUTED IT IS VITAL THAT
WE TAKE ACTION TO ADDRESS THE
OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA
SB NINE OH FOUR IS THE SIMPLE
PREVENTIVE MEASURE THAT
ACCOMPLISHES THIS WE HAVE
INTRODUCED AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT WHO
DESIGNS AND IMPLEMENTS. THE
APPROVAL PROCESS. FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE THAT YOU CATION IS
WELL AS THE OF THE PROGRAM. THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO REMOVE OF
SOMETHING THAT WAS A QUITE
OBJECTIONABLE THAT'S THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND AGGRAVATION
THAT HAS BEEN REMOVED- THROUGH
AN AMENDMENT. FURTHERMORE THE
NEW LANGUAGE WILL OF REFLECT
THAT AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY WHICH
PASSED. UNANIMOUSLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
THIS PAST WEEK. THE SAN DIEGO
AND RIVERSIDE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES ARE BOTH CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE AND
AGAIN MY WITNESSES ARE CHIEF
DEPUTY PATRICK ESPINOSA WITH THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ROBERT HOT HIGHTOWER THEY WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR VERY WELL WELL AND WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE TWO MINUTES FOR
EACH OF OUR WITNESSES WE'VE FOR
JOB I GUESS- MISTRUST FOR THOSE. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN TO THE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN MY NAME IS PATRICK
ESPINOSA I'M THE CHIEF CAPTAIN
THIS ANNUAL COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE SAN DIEGO
DA'S OFFICE IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
SB NINE OH FOUR IN AN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS THE FEDERAL CRISIS. AS
CENTER KAMATA MENTIONED THERE
THERE ARE THREE APPROACHES
EDUCATION TREATMENT CONSEQUENCES
AND SB NINE OH FOUR FOCUSES ON
PROVIDING EDUCATION TREATMENT
INDIVIDUALS PLACED ON PROBATION
FOR A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
OFFENSE THE EDUCATION WOULD
INCLUDE LECTURES CLASSES GOOD
DISCUSSION AND COUNSELLING THE
GOAL OF THE EDUCATION TREATMENT
TO STOP CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND SAVE A LIFE BY
EDUCATING INDIVIDUALS. IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ABOUT
THE RISKS AND DANGERS ASSOCIATED
WITH CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES SUCH
AS THE ALARMING INCREASE IN THE
LEGALITY AND AVAILABILITY OF
FAKE PRESCRIPTION PILLS I THINK
THAT NOW. IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE D. EIGHT WAR
PUBLIC ABOUT A SIGNIFICANT
NATIONWIDE SURGEON COUNTERFEIT
BILLS THERE ARE MASS PRODUCED I
COULDN'T DRUG NETWORKS
DECEPTIVELY. AND MARKETED AS
LEGITIMATE PRESCRIPTION PILLS
THAT ARE KILLING UNSUSPECTING
AMERICANS IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS
SIX MEN AND A WOMAN SUFFERED
THAT NOT OVERDOSE AND A FLORIDA
VACATION HOME DURING SPRING
BREAK THEY WERE USING COCAINE
THAT WAS LACED WITH THAT AND
ALL. FIVE OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
REPORTED TO BE WEST POINT CADET
EXAMPLE RECENT FATAL COUNTY CASE
INVOLVED A NINE ONE ONE CALL
REPORTED UNRESPONSIVE NINETEEN
YEAR OLD MALE MEDICS ARRIVED
ATTEMPTS TO REVIVE THE YOUNG MAN
BEFORE HE WAS PRONOUNCED DEAD.
INVESTORS THE INVESTIGATION
REVEALED THE YOUNG MAN HAD USED
COCAINE AND ECSTASY ECSTASY THE
PREVIOUS NIGHT DETECTIVES
IDENTIFIED THE PERSON WHO
PROVIDED THE COCAINE ECSTASY AND
DETERMINED THAT THIS PERSON
BLACK HILLS IT TESTED POSITIVE
FOR THAT NOW HE GAVE THE BILLS
TO THE YOUNG MAN WHO DIED.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THERE WERE THREE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX DEATHS
RELATED TO FENTANYL. OVERDOSE IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY. BUT NO THE
HUNDRED WHAT. WORKING FIFTY TIME
STRONGER HEROIN. THE SAN DIEGO
DO YOU OFFICE ATTACK THIS ON
STUFF FRONTS. WORKING WITH
SENATE WHICH SUPPORT AND THIS
COUNTY POLICE CHIEFS AND- OF.
JUST FOR A WARINESS. ABOUT BUT
NO THAT USING SO MEDIA AS A TO
EDUCATE YOU TO. THANK HILL CAN
BE A- DEADLY ARE IS ALSO
PARTNERED WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
GREAT SAN DIEGO WHAT YOU'RE A
PROJECT DESIGNED TO EDUCATE
CHANGE BEHAVIOR AND ULTIMATELY
TO REDUCE OVERDOSE DEATHS IN
YOUR COUNTY. DECEMBER OUR OFFICE
AND COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
POSTED ONLINE SUMMIT TO ADDRESS
DANGER BUTTON ALL LOCAL MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
THIS EVENT ADDRESSED THE
PERVASIVENESS OF BENGALI STREET
DRUGS. SB NINE OH FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THESE EFFORTS TO
RAISE AWARENESS AND EDUCATE
INDIVIDUALS ABOUT THE REST OF C.
DRUGS OR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
BEING LACED WITH THAT NOW AND
OTHER DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE USE OF CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE.
WE WITH RESPECT TO THE QUESTION
I VOTE. FOR SB NINE OH FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'RE
NOW MOVING TO MISTER HIGH. GONNA
SHOOTER- BUT HERE TO MINUTES
POLICE YOUR CUSTOMER. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN- SB NINE OH FOUR
ADMITTED MENTIONED- BY AT THE
DEBATE AT YEARS IN EDUCATION
COMPONENT OF WHAT I WOULD LIKE
TO REALLY TOUCH UPON IS THAT
OFTENTIMES BANAL AID FREAKING
HABIT AMONG TEENS THAT NO
OVERDOSES ACCORDING TO A HARVARD
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH. NO
OVERDOSE DEATHS HAVE TRIPLED
AMONG TEENS AND SURGE FIVEFOLD
AMONG AFRICAN AMERICAN TEENS
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS. IN
PARTICULAR I WHAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ABOUT THIS BILL THIS
BILL REALLY ADDRESSES THE
PROBLEM OF THE OUTDATED
EDUCATION I THINK HE WOULD HAVE
TO HEAR THE JUVENILE PROSECUTOR
IN OFTENTIMES JUVENILES WERE
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN TREATMENT.
DISTRICT PROGRAM ARE I THINK
JULIE TREATMENT PROGRAM ANY OF
US RECALL FROM THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES WERE SAYING NO TO DRUGS
IS ACTUALLY THE BASIS AND CORE
OF THE TREATMENT THIS TRULY
ADDRESS TODAY'S PROBLEM WHICH IS
OFTEN TRYING. TO BEING TOLD WHAT
THEY THINK ARE IN BEGINNING OR-
AND PANIC AND ONE FACTOR LACED
WITH- NO WHICH CAN BE DEADLY
THEY WILL EDUCATE- ALL
INDIVIDUAL ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
TAKING. THESE ILLICIT DRUGS.
WHAT IS CRITICAL IN MANAGE
ADDICTS. EVERY SINGLE DAY.
EDUCATION WHEN WE DON'T HAVE TO
MORE BILL PROPER PRODUCT THE
MOST PUBLIC DEFENDER PUBLIC
SAFETY OF ONE OF THE MEMBERS
HAVE HIGHLY THE FACT THAT WHEN
SHE- SHE HAD. DIABETES ONE OF
THE FIRST THINGS THEY- THEM
ASIDE TO DO WITH THE TEN EDUCATE
CLASS. IT SHOULD BE NOTED WHEN
IT COMES TO ADDICTION OF THIS
RIGHT WHICH TRULY IF I HADN'T.
AND WE NEED TO BRING IT. OUT
INTO THE FOREFRONT AND SHELF
LIFE FOR THE PEOPLE HAVE A REAL
EDUCATION THEY CAN HELP YOU.
OVERCOME THIS PROBLEM. AS I
MENTIONED IT DIDN'T INCLUDE ANY
PUTER MEASURES AND WE ARE PROUD
TO SPONSOR THIS BILL AND I AFTER
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NOW. WILL
MOVE Q. WITNESSES- AND OPT INTO
PORT HERE IN THE ROOM. KIM STONE
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS WHO LITERALLY ON A
SUPPORT- IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT YOUR AND TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. G. NONE NOW WILL MOVE
TO OUR OUR PHONE LINE MODERATOR
OR THEIR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF S. B. NINE OH FOUR. YOU LIKE
TO COME IN SUPPORT OF SB THAT'LL
FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME- PERSONAL TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT. GO AHEAD. THIS
CHEN MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION. FOR THE NEXT TO GO
TO LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT. WE CAN HEAR
YOU GO RIGHT AHEAD. RIGHT SORRY
ABOUT THE ARMENIAN MISSION A LOT
FOR CALLING AGAIN I DON'T THINK
. FOLLOWING FAVOR AT THE AIRPORT
AND I WANT TO RESET WHAT I
EXPECT FOR USER FELT YOU SHOULD
NAME THE ORGANIZATION JUST YOUR. NAME AND ORGANIZATION THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MATHIS ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE UP POINTS AND
I ALSO WANT TO REGISTER SUPPORT
OR AT TEN FIFTY THREE WHICH
WORKED OUT PUT ON YOURSELF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S ASHLEY WILLIAMS AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF NINE OLD FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL I AM ALSO SUPPORT
OF TEN FIFTY THREE AM AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU. UNDER
SOMEONE ELSE THANK YOU. OKAY NOW
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION S. B. NINE OH FOUR WE
HAVE GENET ZANUCK PAT TEEN AND
WE HAVE LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
SO MR PETTINE. I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME IS
DIRECTLY BUT BEING THAT I'M
HELPING AS A DRUG DIFFICULTY
ALLIANCE I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SENATE
THOUGH NINE ZERO FOUR- THE
AUTHORITY TO ORDER SUCH
TREATMENT ALREADY EXISTS HOWEVER
THIS BILL WOULD NARROW THAT HAVE
TO TREATMENT AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS TO PREVENT KIDS
PRECIPITATED. PROVIDED BY A
COURT ORDER ALSO THE BILL WOULD
GET ALL COMMITTEE APPROVAL FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS USE OF THE COUNTY
SURVATION DEPARTMENT IN
CONJUNCTION- WITH- THE COUNTY
DRUG OUR PROGRAM COORDINATOR-
OUR CONCERN IS THAT YOU KNOW
PROBATION COULD NOT BE THE ONE
TO CREATING DRUG EDUCATION.
PROGRAMS AND FAILED- YOU ARE
HERE TO GUIDELINES FOR WHAT TYPE
OF PROGRAM OR PROVIDERS- THEY
CAN CHOOSE THEIR WORK WHERE
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
VOLUNTARINESS AND PARTICIPANTS
BY AN ARC HE COULD BENEFIT FROM
TREATMENT EFFORT IS A BETTER
OUTCOME NARROWING OPTIONS AND
REPEATING. WHAT YEAH CAN TAKE IN
THAT SHOOTING. USED YOUR
COUNTERPART. QUITE GOOD
TREATMENT SHOULD BE KERN.
AFFECTED TO TREAT THOSE WHO
THOUGHT WITH THAT CAN THE NUMBER
THE FACT WAY. AND THE SPREAD
MUST BE BASED WITHIN. STANDARD
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE- BUT HE
WENT INTO THREE BEING AT WITH A
GIRL DAY THE HAS NEEDED A
PICTURE. WHERE PEOPLE ARE FAR
TOO OFTEN PEOPLE THEIR HELP YOU
NEED TO SHORE YOUR ON SUPPORTING
. AND NOT USE TREATMENT. AND A
CURE EXTENSION OF. AT ONLY IF
COULD RECORD AT ALL ANOTHER TO
FOR AT THE SPEAKS. OR A HEALTH
PROVIDED BY. AS QUICK AS- HEALTH
FOR. YES OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM CONTINUES TO RELY ON
THEM. PEOPLE WHO USE DRUGS. HI
NEED OPTION BETWEEN. WHO CAN
HELP MEDICATED TREATMENT NON
ETHNIC BASED INTERVENTION AMONG
OTHER. IT THE OVERDOSE CRISIS
INSTEAD OF FURTHERING HARMFUL
BACTERIA BUDGET YOU RECOMMEND OF
THE STATE AND- FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL YOU FIVE TO PRIORITIZE THE
EXPANSION OF ACCESS TO EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT VOLUNTARY FOR
THE FUTURE REPORTER TREATMENT
AND HARM REDUCTION SERVICES LIKE
OVERDOSE PREVENTION PROGRAM.
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
ACCESS TO OTHER HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD NOT HAVE A HANDS OF
TREATMENT PROVIDERS SHOULD BE
FREE TO PURSUE BUT EVEN OPTIONS
BASED ON SCIENCE AND- THE
PROPHETIC. WE REGARD TO THE
EDUCATION. AND TRAIN EDUCATION.
YOU WE WILL THE COMPONENT ALSO
LET THE UNDER IF THE CORPS YEAR
IF ULTIMATE. FATAL LIFE
EDUCATION FOCUS ON HOW REDUCTION
AND YOUR FIVE AND EVIDENT. THE
FIFTEEN CURRICULA FOR USE IT IS
A GOOD THE KIND OF THE CARPET
ACTION. WHEN IT COMES TO DRUG
EDUCATION A HARM REDUCTION
APPROACH BURKE IS YOUNG PEOPLE
FROM USING ALCOHOL AND OTHER
DRUGS. IT OFFERS MORE THAN THE
ABSTINENCE ONLY APPROACH BECAUSE
IT ALSO PROVIDES YOU KNOW YOU'RE
PUTTING INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
KEEP THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FRIENDS STATE. IF AND WHEN. THEY
DO ENCOUNTER THESE SUBSTANCES.
RIGHT ASK. A SHOOTING LOSE YOUR
TEST IF YOU CAN PLUG. YOU CAN
FINISH UP HERE- FORTY THREE THEN
WE URGE A NO VOTE- THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
LAS TO CALL HOUSTON POLICE. YEAH
AND HERE AGAIN MANY MY NAME IS
LESLIE CALDWELL HUGHES AND I'M A
RETIRED CHIEF DEFENDER OF SOLANO
COUNTY AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB NINE ZERO FOUR WE DO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR REMOVING
ADDITIONAL PUNISHMENT FROM THIS
BILL. AS THE DEFENDER OF THE
INDIGENT DEFENDANTS FOR NEARLY
FORTY YEARS I HAD TO LEARN A LOT
ABOUT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER THE
TREATMENT OF SUCH AND WHAT LEADS
TO THE EXCEPT FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL. FIRST AND FOREMOST I
LEARNED THAT VOLUNTARINESS AND
PARTICIPANTS BY AND ARE THE KEYS
TO EFFECTIVE TREATMENT A PERSON
SUFFERING FROM SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER MUST BE READY TO ACCEPT
TREATMENT. I ALSO LEARNED THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
DIFFERENT MANNERS OF TREATMENT
FROM ONE ANOTHER WE MUST NOT
NARROW OPTIONS OR DICTATE THE
APPROACH A PROGRAM MUST. WE MUST
GIVE THE LEAD HERE COURTS HAVE
FLEXIBILITY. MUST HAVE
FLEXIBILITY- AS RECEPTION ABUSE
. THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE SKEWS ME
IN ORDER TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS TREATMENT PROVIDERS
MUST BE FREE TO FOLLOW EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES AS WELL AS WORK
WITH THE LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
BOTH COUNCILLORS AND THE PEOPLE
THEY WORK WITH. WELL THE FOR
POST BILL IS WELL INTENTIONED
IT'S NOT THE ANSWER TO OUR
TERRIBLE OF YOUR HEART CRISIS OR
EVEN PART OF THE ANSWER WE NEED
TO LOOK TO THE EVIDENCE BASED
AND CLINICALLY PROVEN STANDARDS.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE SCIENCE
WE'RE LEARNING MORE EVERY DAY
AND LISTING NOW WHAT CAN AND
CANNOT BE DONE IS NOT
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL TO WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM WHO ARE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE OH FOUR. SHE NONE NOW
MODERATOR WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES. AND LATER ON IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. BUT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE THREE IN OUR
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH NUMBER
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS EMMA SHE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND A CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NEXT IS NUMBER
SIXTY. KATHY SURE FOR A BILL YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION
. THANK YOU. NEXT TO ME NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT. CORRECT ME ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE ACCESS
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. I WILL WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE. ANY OF THE KARAGANDY
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S PRETTY
LITTLE JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE. THANK YOU NOW WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS CENTER
WINNER. THANK I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- SO I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS EITHER ONE
CLARIFICATION ON I'VE I AM I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR. BRING
YOUR BILL FOR THE FOCUSES ON ON
TREATMENT- AND I KNOW IT THEY'RE
NOT IMPRINT BUT I THINK I'VE
I'VE SEEN- MEMBERS OF THE AUTHOR
INTENDS TO TAKE. THE BASIC
CONFORM THE BILL TO A. B. R.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY- INTO THAT.
DEFINITELY THE MERGERS OF ONE OF
MY CONCERNS WITH WAS THE
CRIMINALIZATION AND IF YOU
DON'T. SUCCEED SO THANK YOU FOR
AGREEING TO REMOVE THAT- BUT
THE- THE TWO OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS FOR A BILL IN THE FIRST
THANK THE KIND OF TREATMENT. AND
THEN THE I THINK THE REQUIREMENT
FOR SUCCESSFULLY. TREATING IS
ALSO GOING TO BE IN THE BILL.
THAT THAT REALLY REFERS SENATOR
WINNER JUST COMPLETING THE
PROGRAM IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL SUCCESSFUL AS
DEFINED MEANS THAT YOU TOOK ARE
YOU COMPLETED THE PROGRAM OKAY
WHY I'M SO I'M SERVICE SO WHAT
HAPPENS IF. IF YOU COULD WE KNOW
LIKE AS MUCH AS WE WANT PEOPLE
TO YOU KNOW PUT THE NOSE THE
GRINDSTONE AND- UNDERSTANDING
FROM WHAT SO IF YOU'RE SOMEONE
WHO IS. DEEPLY ADDICTED AND THEY
GOT PUT INFORMATION AND SENSE
ONE OF THE RIVER MET MANDATED TO
A TREATMENT PROGRAM. UNLESS HAVE
A FALL OUT BECAUSE THEY START
USING MAYBE THEY WERE. BECAUSE
THEY WERE THEY WERE DELAYING THE
ARREST OF ANOTHER USING AND THEY
FALL OUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM OF
THEIR FALL OUT. NOTHING MEANS IF
THE L. WHATEVER THEY'VE BACK
BEFORE THE JUDGE HE HAS THE
DISCRETION ON THE KIND OF
TREATMENT I THINK THERE WAS A
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT THE BILL
LIMITS THE DISCRETION OF THE
JUDGE IT DOES NOT OF COURSE SO
PERHAPS STARTING THE TREATMENT
PROGRAM ALL OVER AGAIN SOME
PEOPLE ARE VERY. A CONTRITE THAT
THEY FELL OFF. THE WAGON AND-
YOU. GO THROUGH IT AGAIN. BOB
EVANS THE LOSS FROM. AND NOW
THING THAT. A MISCARRIAGE. BY
THE OP. ON THERE. YOU TOO
AMENDMENTS SO THERE'S A WHOLE
CAL. OF INTO. WHO ARE A
TREATMENT BAY. SCIENCE BAY WHO
ARE NOW PART OF THE DECISION OF
WHAT THE EDUCATION PROGRAM IS
GOING TO INCLUDE. SO IT IS NOT
MANDATED THAT IT HAS TO BE A
CERTAIN KIND IN FACT. ALL THE
TREATMENT PROVIDERS CAN I
DETERMINE THAT THAT I THINK THE
EDUCATION COMPONENT OF IT. OUR
SHOULD BE INCLUDED. IS INCLUDED
WITH THIS BILL. GET TO THE TITLE
TREATMENT I DO HAVE ABOUT. BUT
JUST IN TERMS OF A NOTS.
COMPLETING BECAUSE THAT IS
REFERRED TO IN HERE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION- BUT I ONE OF. THE
WILL THIS INCREASE. THE
POSSIBILITY OF SOMEONE BEING CAR
SERRATED SO THEY GET THEY GET.
PROBATION WITH THIS TREATMENT
BASEBALL OFF OFF THE WAGON THERE
ARE USING A GUN FOR WHATEVER
REASON THEY'RE JUST NOT. YOU
KNOW YOU CAN KIND OF JUDGES I'M
I'M REVOKING HER PROBATION
SENDING YOU TO JAIL. YOU KNOW
LESS ALKALINE FOR SMITH I DON'T
SEE THAT AS PART OF THIS BECAUSE
IT'S CLEARLY STATED IN THE BILL
THAT SUCCESS MEANS THEY
COMPLETED THE PROGRAM WHY
THEY'RE ON PROBATION. ALL IF YOU
ARE INCARCERATED YOU'RE REQUIRED
TO TAKE IT IS PART OF WHAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE IF YOU ARE IN
PRISON BUT THOSE WHO ARE AYE
DIVERT HE'S CENTERS RUN%
PROBATION YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
HAVE THE PROGRAM AND YOU HAVE
JUST SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE IT.
MEANS YOU HAVE TO TAKE THE
ENTIRE COURSE THE GATE AND THEN
LET'S SAY YOU WERE SITTING AND
WHAT HAPPENS TO YOU THEN ARE
WITHOUT BE THE JUDGE'S
DISCRETION I WOULD ASSUME SO. I
WOULD HE WOULD MAKE THE PERSON
TAKE THE COURSE AGAIN WOULD HE
INCREASE- THE TIME IF YOU YOU
KNOW YOU ARE. YOU'RE YOU'VE
VIOLATED YOUR PROBATION YOU
VIOLATE YOUR PROBATION BY NOT
GOING TAKING THE TREAT THE- THE
PROGRAM THAT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOUR PROBATION IS AWAITED.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S- ROBERT HI
WITH YEAH COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE JUDGE HAS
THE- HE DEEMS SOMEONE HAVING.
COMPLETED A EVEN IF THE THING
ACTUALLY COMPLIED WITH IT-
FEDERAL COMPLETION HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IN THE LANGUAGE IMPACTED-
IT'S A TERM OF ART THE VIEWS IN
THE LEGAL SYSTEM EVERY DAY TO
DETERMINE. WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEONE IS COMPLYING WITH
PROBATION THE COURT HAS- THE
JURISDICTION AND THE DISCRETION
TO ORDER INTO A NEW PROGRAM OR
TO SIMPLY FIND HEY I YOU KNOW
EVEN THOUGH YOU HAVEN'T
COMPLETED IT. IF YOU
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLIED WITH THAT
TERMINATE ATTEMPTED TREATMENT-
THEN THE COURT CAN BE MET THAT
IF I CAN FIND NO VIOLATION OR
EVEN. TERMINATE THEM FROM
PROBATION ACTUALLY EVEN IF THEY
HAVEN'T COMPLETED IT YEAH I'M
JUST I GUESS THE ISSUE IS ANYONE
WHO HAS A PROVISION. OF THE
RECIDIVIST THERE ARE DIFFERENT.
IN YOU CAN VIOLATE SECOND. CAUSE
A PROBATE GROUP AND YOU GO TO
THAT'S SIX SAYS. MY QUESTION IS
WHETHER WE ARE NOW PUTTING ONE
ADDITIONAL WAY. FOR THE
PERSONNEL THAT HAVE THEIR
PROBATION BE REVOKED AND GOING
TO JAIL THAT DOESN'T EXIST NOW
AND THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS
TO MANDATE. THREE MEN AS PART OF
PROBATION. AS A DOES IT CREATE
YET ONE MORE BASIS TO REVOKE
PROBATION IN AN INCARCERATED
PERSON. YOU KNOW IT DID NOT GET
CONVICTED THAT REQUIREMENT IS
ALREADY PUT IN PLACE AFTER A
COURT ORDER TO ORDER EDUCATION
OR TREATMENT. THE PROBLEM WITH
THE WAY THE CURRENT LAW IF THAT
UP. UNFORTUNATELY WHAT IT PUTS
THE ONUS ON IT ON A DEFENDANT.
WHO'S GOING ON PROBATION THE
FEET AND MAINTAIN THEIR OWN
TREATMENT. THAT THAT PART ABOUT
THAT IS THAT OFTENTIMES IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TREATMENT THIS
WOULD ACTUALLY PUTS THE ONUS
BACK WHERE IT BELONGS WHICH IS
BACK ON THE GOVERNMENT. TO FIND
APPROPRIATE TREATMENTS FOR THE
ATTIC NUMBER ONE THEY DON'T HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
RECOVERING FROM THE ADDICTION
AND TRY TO FIND THEIR OWN
TREATMENT. AND WHAT WE'RE REALLY
SPEAKING TO- INSURER IS THE ONE
WHO GOES INTO COURT IN SANTA
MONICA HOW. IN COMPTON HAS A ON
THIS. THE COURT. DO YOU. THE
MOBILE THEM- BUT RIGHT NOW AS IT
CURRENTLY THE CORE IS THE TO
ORDER A- SO DEFINITELY IT
DOESN'T A NEW- KITTED MEASURE WE
IT CAN TO DOES THIS. FIRST OF
ALL IT UP DATE OKAY BECAUSE AND
TREATMENT PARKER WITH MY CRACKED
AND ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IS TO
HAVE TO TREATMENT EDUCATION BUT
BUT IF THAT'S IF THE ISSUE IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE ON THEIR OWN NOW
TO FIND WHATEVER TREATMENT THEY
CAN FIND WE WANT CONSISTENCY AND
WHAT. THE VERY COUNTIES TO BE
PROVIDING THAT WOULD IN THE
BILLS. AS REQUIRED COUNTIES TO.
THE EXPIRES THE- TREATMENT I'M
JUST A LITTLE CONFUSED CONSUMERS
THIS IS CREATING A NEW.
PROBATION A NEW ELEMENT OF
PROBATION. SO IT DOES NOT CREATE
A NEW ELEMENT TO PROBATION
ALREADY CURRENTLY EXIST IN THE
CURRENT CODE. WHAT IT DOES IS
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE WHERE
IS RIGHT NOW IT'S GOING ON THE
DEFENDANT IT IF POSSIBLE. BUT
RIGHT NOW IT IS IT IS CURRENTLY
IN THE COLD THAT THE COURT SHALL
IF IT IS AVAILABLE THAT THIS
COURT SHALL ORDER A DEFENDANT I
COULD PARTICIPATE IN AN
EDUCATION OR TREATMENT PROGRAM.
OKAY BUT I'M NOT ELECTED NOT AN
ADDITIONAL MEASURE RIGHT THANK
YOU ON MY SECOND- QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THE TYPE OF TREATMENT AND
I- I AM. SENSITIVE TO MY
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE DECIDED BY
THE- PROBATION DEPARTMENT. OR
WHATEVER AND I. WHAT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY TREATMENT IS
COME TRULY BE SCIENCE BASED AND
M. AND FOR EXAMPLE LIKE. ABSENCE
ONLY HE DOESN'T WORK FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE MAY WORK FOR SOME
PEOPLE- BUT DOESN'T WORK FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND IT SETS THEM
UP FOR. FOR VALUE THAT'S WHY I'M
I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
ARGUMENTS RAISED BY THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE OUT HERE FOR A
LOT OF HARM REDUCTION IS GOING
TO BE. WHAT BERKSTEN TERMS
GETTING PEOPLE UNIT STOP USING
OR TO USE LESS OR TO BE. SAFER
AND HOW THEY- USE SO CAN YOU
COMMENT ON ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
YOU'RE MAKING THESE AMENDMENTS.
WHO WILL BE DECIDING WHAT. THE
TREATMENT AS- OF WHAT EXACT
AGENCY OR OFFICIAL. AND WHAT.
ARE THEIR IS THERE A BILL OR AS
IS A DISCUSSION CABINS IN SOME
WAY OR CAN THEY- DECIDE I'M
GOING WITH APPS ONLY FOR
EVERYONE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I
BELIEVE IN. NO I THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SENATOR WIENER AYE
TO- GIVING IT JUST OF THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT WE TOOK AN
AMENDMENT WHEN I SAW THAT
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
TREATMENT PROVIDERS. WHO ARE
VERY INVOLVED WITH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT BEST PRACTICES
NEW METHODS ARE HAVE TO BE PART
OF IT SO THERE ARE MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WILL COME
THERE TO DETERMINE WHAT
SPECIFICALLY THE STANDARDISATION
OF THIS PROGRAM. IS ABOUT AND
THAT WAY IT WOULD BE
STANDARDIZED AND IS VERY BIG NOW
IS YOU. HIGHTOWER EXPLAINED SO
IT IS LAWS SPECIFICALLY AMENDED
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S IN THE
BILL NOW BECAUSE OF THE LATE
AMEND THAT WE WERE PUTTING IT
TOGETHER BUT IT'S INTENDED TO.
BE AMENDED SO THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE STAKEHOLDERS AND IT IT
IS SAKE- COLLABORATIVE PROCESSES
YOU LOOK AT THOSE VERY THINGS
YOU PRODUCT SCIENCE BASED. BASED
BEST PRACTICE WITH THOSE I'M
SORRY REALISTICALLY MAYBE IF
IT'S IF IT'S IN THE BILL I
APOLOGIZE I MUST HAVE MISSED IT
BUT I. I KNOW THERE WERE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE NOT IN THE
BILL YEAH. IN THIS ONE SAYS
SPECIFICALLY OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY WILL BE- ON STATE
THE A MEMBER STATE OF THE COUNTY
DRUG PROGRAM AN ADMINISTRATOR.
REPRESENT IS THAT THE COURT THE
CONFIRMATION. DEPARTMENT SINCE
YOU. PROVIDED WITH DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT AN APPROVAL AND
RENEWAL PROCESS FOR THE
EDUCATION TREATMENT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY REQUIRE
MACABE DRUG PROGRAM AND I'M
SORRY DO SO. NOW I POLITICS YEAH
CAN BE PROGRAM STRIP. IS THAT
WHAT THEY HAVE POST ARE YOU.
LIKE HEALTH- OUT AGENCY OKAY
OKAY IS NOT AN OFFICIAL. VETR
LIKE DEFINITE. IT MAY ON A DRUG
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR MAY BE
THEY HAVE THOSE NOW I'M NOT
FRANKLY I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
ALL THE COUNTIES I KNOW THAT.
THEIR SITE THERE IS THE
SPECIFICITY THAT'S NOW GIVEN TO
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS BASICALLY
RUNNING THOSE DRUG EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. CAN WE JUST HAVE AG
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE-
THE MOST RATE OR WHATEVER THE- I
JUST- I'M JUST A LITTLE IS VERY
LITTLE LOOSE AND I WORRY THAT
THERE ARE SOME COUNTIES.
DEPENDING ON WHO PARTICIPATES IN
IT IT'S UNCLEAR WHO ACTUALLY
pMAKES THE FINAL DECISION AND
WHAT PROVIDERS ARE BOB THERE ARE
REALLY REALLY GOOD- US OF THESE
TREATMENT PROVIDERS AND AS YOU
KNOW BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'VE DONE
SOME WORK ON THIS OR SOME REAL
SHADY. OPERATORS AND THEIR
PEOPLE TO USE NON SCIENCE BASED
. APPROACH AS I JUST WORRY THAT
DEPENDING ON WHAT COUNTY IS AN
UNFORTUNATE IN THE COUNTIES.
THAT ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE YOU
KNOW PURSUING HARSHER DRUG
PENALTIES ARE ALSO THE ONES.
THAT ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE
PURSUING OPTIONS ONLY- OR
ABSTINENCE FOCUSED ON JUST CALL
AND POINTED OUT IT'S I THINK THE
REALITY- AND SO I THINK THIS.
WOULD BE SOME TIGHTENING FELT
THE LONG TO SHORT IS THE MMC
MADE UP HERE. MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I REALLY
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE IT- I
THINK WITH THE WAY IT IS RIGHT
NOW IT'S NOT TIGHT ENOUGH FOR ME
AND I WORRY THAT I COULD GO. NOT
BE IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY AND SO
IF BROUGH WITH BOAT. THIS
LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW I THINK I
DON'T THINK I COULD SUPPORT
TODAY IF IT WERE TO LEAD TO A
FUTURE HEARING. WITH SOME MORE
WORK ON THE LANGUAGE- I MIGHT BE
ABLE TO GET THERE SO I JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT OUT. I WILL LAUGH AT
THIS BECAUSE IT'S IDENTICAL TO
THE LANGUAGE THAT IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION STATUTE- THAT
IS ESSENTIALLY IT'D BE COUNTY
DRUG ADMINISTRATOR WITH INPUT
FROM SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROVIDERS UNDER PENAL CODE
SECTION TWELVE ELEVEN. BILL WAS
PUT IN THERE TO NEARTHAT BUT
THAT WAY ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
HAD A STAKE. IN DETERMINING THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'VE USED FOR
DRUG DIVERSION. SO IN THOSE
OTHER ONES IN THE DECIDER IS- HE
THOUGHT WERE THAT CERTAIN FORMER
PRESIDENT OR THE DECISION MAKER.
IS THE DRUG PROGRAM COUNTY DRUG
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR. BECAUSE
HERE THAT THEY'RE NOT THE
DECISION MAKER. IT'S LIKE A CELL
THEIR PROCESS. WITH PROBATE
APART EVERYONE ELSE IT DOESN'T
WHO DECIDES. ULTIMATELY GOING TO
BE ON PROBATION AS WELL OF THE
COURT BUT THE PROGRAMS
THEMSELVES WILL BE WILL BE
DEVELOPED- BY THE COUNTY DRUG
ADMINISTRATOR WITH INPUT FROM
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE. TREATMENT
PROVIDERS SO AGAIN IT'S GONNA
EXACTLY NEAR RIGHT NOW WHAT WE
HAVE IN THE DRUG DIVERSION
STATUTE. SO THAT WAY IF THE SAME
TYPE OF TREATMENT PROGRAMS
THEY'RE GONNA BE PROVIDED AS A
BEING PROVIDED A DIVERSION. SO
THAT AND AGAIN PROBATION WOULD
ULTIMATELY BE THE ONE WHO WOULD.
BE AND LOCATE THOSE PROGRAMS FOR
THE DEFENDANT BUT ULTIMATELY THE
COURT'S GOING TO COME DOWN TO
MAKE THE ULTIMATE DETERMINATION
S TO WHETHER OR NOT THAT THE
APPROPRIATE PROGRAM AT THE
BEGINNING FROM A PROBATION. OKAY
THANK YOU. CENTERS SKINNER.
THANK YOU TO YOUR ARM. I DON'T
THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO. PUT INTO STATUTE
CONTENT OF SUCH PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THAT IS NOT OUR EXPERTISE. SAY
THAT TO ESTABLISH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS TO ESTABLISH THAT THERE
SHOULD BE OPTIONS FOR TREATMENT
BUT TO DEFINE THE CURRICULUM OF
IT IS NOT OUR EXPERTISE AND MY
EXPERIENCE PASSED. THERE ARE
PASSED STATUTES WHERE WE IN FACT
THE LEGISLATURE DICTATED WHAT
THE CURRICULUM WAS AND THEY HAVE
A WORK. BECAUSE EXPERTISE AND
THAT'S WHAT I TAKE FROM THE-
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION NOT ALL
IT'S NOT OUR DECISION TO
TREATMENT PER SE IT IS TO
DEFINING WHAT THAT. WHAT THE
CURRICULUM IS OR HOW IT'S HOW IT
IS DONE AND SO- AND IT SEEMS
BECAUSE THE BILL PART OF IT'S MY
MOTIVATION IS TO GET THAT VERY
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ABOUT FENTANYL
OUT THERE- AGAIN I WANT PEOPLE
TO BE AWARE FEDERAL THOUGH I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS
PARTICULAR. MECHANISM IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO FOR US TO PUT
INTO STATUTE DATE THE CURRICULUM
OF THE PROGRAM SO I'M I CAN'T
SUPPORT IT AS WRITTEN. I DON'T
SEE THAT WE PUT INTO STATUTE A
CURRICULUM WE PUT INTO STATUTE-
A- PROCESS BY WHICH THEY WILL
DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT MEETS THE
CORDS- IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
SENTENCING AND JOG. FOR THEIR
VERSION- IF OF A PROGRAM THAT
PEOPLE WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
THEM BUT WE'RE NOT SAYING IT HAS
TO BE EXPLAINS THE IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE CONTENT AS I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR TREATMENT
PROVIDERS TO HAVE A GREAT IT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN ON BEING
ON BEST PRACTICES. OF THINGS
THAT ARE ARE WORKING SCIENCE
BASED AND OUT AND THAT'S NOT
EVEN CALLED OUT IN HERE JUST
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THESE EXPERTS
NEED TO COME TOGETHER TO DEVELOP
A PROGRAM THAT IS AVAILABLE YES
BUT I ALSO FIND SOUND DEFINES
THE NUMBER OF HOURS TO DEFINE
DEFINES A VARIETY OF THINGS
WHICH IN EFFECT. WELL MAYBE IT'S
NOT THE TOTAL CONTENT IS STILL
IT IS STILL GOING INTO AN ARENA
OF DEFINITIONS THAT IS NOT OUR
EXPERTISE. IN MY OPINION. MA'AM
BASED ON THE LEVEL OF A RATING
THIS THAT I SEEM IT SEEMS EXIST
RIGHT NOW WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED
SENATOR BATES IF WE JUST PUT
THIS OFF FOR ANOTHER WEEK AND
LET YOU FINE TUNE THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE KINDA HE'S
OUR OUR MEMBERS CONCERNS YES I
WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT AND WORK
WITH SENATOR WINNER BECAUSE I
THINK THE THINGS THAT HE HAS
BROUGHT UP ARE VERY RELEVANT AND
CONCERN ELEVEN YEAH THANK YOU
AND OUR PRICES AS GOOD MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE STAFF TO BE
VERY. INVOLVED IS WHAT WHATEVER
CURRENT LAW IS MAYBE THAT YOU
KNOW MAYBE IT'S NOT TIGHT ENOUGH
AND SO I JUST MIGHT YEAH RABITA
TO TAKE A SIDE RIGHT SO IF YOU
HAVE NO OBJECTION WILL JUST HOLD
THIS- ITEM OVER TO OUR NEXT
HEARING OR TO OPPORTUNITY A FEW
HEARINGS DOWN TO THE APPLE TIME
TO WORK NOT. ONLY WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF BUT WITH- THE BRIDGE TO
MAKE SURE OUR- WE GET. THAT
EVERY COME WITH THANK YOU OKAY
YOU FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU SENATOR BYRD FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY GIVEN BACK THANK YOU.
THE OUR MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM AND-
IT'S- BY SENATOR. SKINNER SB.
NINE SIX ZERO. YOU ENTERED YEAH. NINE SIX ZERO. ALL.
PEOPLE.
SKINNER SKINNER WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE- ARM SO I'M PRESENTING SB
NINE SIXTY WHICH WAS BROUGHT TO
MY ATTENTION BY THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA- LEAST APARTMENT
WHERE THEY HAD. BUT PEOPLE ENTER
THEIR CADET PROGRAM THAT THEY
THEN HEN COUNTERED THEY WERE NOT
ABLE TO OFFER A POSITION TO THEM
BECAUSE THERE IS- WE HAVE
CURRENT PROVISION IN OUR LAW.
THAT WOULD. RESTRICT THE ABILITY
FOR A PERSON WHO IS NOT A
CITIZEN BUT HAS LEGAL WORK
AUTHORIZATION NOW WHEN I SAY
LEGAL WORK AUTHORIZATION THAT
MEANS FOR EXAMPLE A GREEN CARD.
A VISA PERMANENT RESIDENCY
VARIOUS THINGS THAT. WHILE ARE
NOT CITIZENSHIP DO GIVE YOU THE
ABILITY TO LEGALLY WORK IN THE
U. S. AND TO FOR EXAMPLE IN
CALIFORNIA BE A MEMBER OF THE
BAR SO PRACTICE LAW. YOU KNOW
BUT PLATE HAVE- YOU PART OF. ANY
NUMBER OF FORTY ONE PROFESSIONS
WITHIN OUR BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE A WHOLE VARIETY
OF THINGS BUT BECAUSE OF THE WAY
OUR STATUTE AS WRITTEN YOU WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO BE A PEACE
OFFICER. AND SO WHAT MY BILL
WOULD DO AND THERE'S A- IT DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR ANY PERSON WHO IS
UNDOCUMENTED OR NON CITIZEN TO
BECOME A POLICE OFFICER THIS
BILL IS SUCCESSFUL BUT RATHER.
YOU MUST BE A PERSON IS LEGALLY
AUTHORIZED TO WORK. YOU HAVE
THAT LEGAL PAPERWORK. AND THEN
IN CALIFORNIA IF THIS BILL
PASSES YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO BE A
SWORN OFFICER. SO THAT'S ITS
INTENT. AND THE- SO WE MIGHT SAY
WELL WHY WOULD IT NOT BE WHY
DON'T WE STILL REQUIRE THEM TO
PURSUE CITIZENSHIP. BUT ACTUALLY
THERE'S MANY REASONS WHY SOME
PEOPLE DO NOT PURSUE
CITIZENSHIP. THERE'S IF YOU
HAPPEN TO BE FROM A COUNTRY THAT
WOULD ALLOW YOU TO RETAIN YOUR
YOUR EXISTING CITIZENSHIP A U.
S. CITIZEN THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR PEOPLE
BUT IN SOME COUNTRIES YOU HAVE
TO DENOUNCE IT ENTIRELY. THERE'S
ALSO- CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE I MEAN
THERE'S ANY NUMBER OF
CIRCUSTANCES WHERE SOMEONE
CHOOSES TO RETAIN THE
CITIZENSHIP OF THEIR HOME
COUNTRY BUT THEY ARE PERMANENT
RESIDENTS HERE. AND SO. THIS
WOULD ALLOW FOR THEM TO BE. A
SWORN OFFICER WHICH OF COURSE
WOULD HELP US WITH THAT CULTURAL
ISSUES DIVERSITY ISSUES IF
YOU'VE GROWN UP IN- YOU KNOW
CERTAIN COMMUNITY AND YOU WANT
TO SERVE IN THEIR COMMUNITY. THE
THIS PROVISION AND THE OTHER
INTERESTING THING IS THIS
PROVISION WAS NOT IN OUR LAW
FROM THE TIME WE STARTED OUR-
POLICE OFFICERS IT WAS ADDED.
AND I HAVE DEEP TO FIND THE- OF
GET TO THE YEAR IT WAS ADDED YOU
KNOW SO WAS SEMI RECENTLY WITHIN
THE LAST- TWENTY THE LAST THIRTY
OR SO YEARS. ANYWAY I WANT TO
HAVE MY- PEOPLE AND WHO ARE MY
EXPERTS TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY
BUT I WANTED TO RAISE THAT. WHEN
WHEN WE GET INTO THE DISCUSSION
THERE SPEND SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
WHAT WHAT WOULD THIS PREVENT
SOMEONE FROM BEING ABLE TO TRUST
TO GET A BACKGROUND CHECK AND BY
NO MEANS IN MY TRYING TO CARRY A
BILL THAT WOULD. CAUSE SOMEONE
TO BE ABLE TO BE A SWORN OFFICER
WHO WE COULD NOT DO A BACKGROUND
CHECK ON ME WE OBVIOUSLY KNOW
THAT MANY OF THE PROFESSIONS.
THAT ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE IN THE SAME CIRCUMSTANCE
WERE LEGALLY AVAILABLE TO WORK
THEY HAD TO PASS BACKGROUND
CHECKS SO I KNOW THAT THERE IS A
WAY THAT WE CAN CONSTRUCT THIS
THAT WOULD GIVE THE ABILITY FOR.
A PERSON WHO IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL
WITH THAT CHANGE IN LAW THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO WOULD HAVE TO
WOULD BE BE. ABLE TO HAVE A
BACKGROUND CHECK DONE ON THEM IT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SO I AM
TOTALLY WILLING TO WORK ON
MAKING SURE THAT. IF THAT IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE FIX IT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD BUT LET ME GO TO-
MICHAEL BIGARD FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
JONATHON. FELDMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS. THIS
ARE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND THEN WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY MR FELDMAN WITH TWO
MINUTES AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL BUT ARE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU SEE IF PROUD TO SPONSOR
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY WHICH
WOULD DELAY THANK YOU CREDIT
REQUIREMENTS. FOR BEEF UP JUST
TO BE OUT THERE WITHIN. THE
UNIVERSITY. SPONSORED THE BILL
BECAUSE AS WITH THE LETTER
EXPLAINED. WE HAVE EXPERIENCE
WITH STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN OUR CADET PROGRAM WHEN CAMPUS
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ONE TALK ABOUT WHAT. WE
OFFER ADDITIONAL UC DAVIS HE-
WAS INELIGIBLE THERE HAS
UNDOCUMENTED STATUS. BACK EVERY
YEAR WE HAVE OUTSTANDING COULD
ACT LIKE THAT WE CANNOT HIRE.
NINETY NINE IF YOU ARE MOVING
THE FAIR WHICH IS GROUNDED IN
ALLOCATED THINKING ANSWERS NOW
GOING TO BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSE. YOU ALSO A LINE
CALIFORNIA WITH ALMOST EVERY
OTHER STATES BY ELIMINATING THE
ANTIQUATED THINKING FROM THE
WALL. AND ALLOW ANY QUALIFIED
RESIDENT TO CALIFORNIA SERVICE
DO YOU THINK YOU MEAN IT IS.
WHAT THEY WERE. RATE AND YOU CAN
WITHIN LESS. WE NEED TO EVEN USE
THE AMHERST. REQUEST YOUR I. AND
IT'S ONLINE SIX. THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN. SURE JONATHAN FOR WITH
STRATEGY ON BEHALF THE POLICE TO
THIS. AND SUPPORTED- OR TO START
BY OF POLICE CHIEF CENTERS THE
COME OF THIS ISSUES AND FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAWS AND LAWS AROUND
FIREARM POSSESSION- BUT WE'RE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT BECAUSE
THE CHIEFS FUNDAMENTALLY- ALL
AGREE THAT ITIZENSHIP IN AN OF
ITSELF SHOULD NOT BE A BARRIER
TO SOMEBODY BECOMING A PEACE
OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
ELEVEN MILLION IMMIGRANTS IN THE
STATE MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE COME HERE AS CHILDREN MANY
OF THEM HAS AS MR BADAR
MENTIONED SERVED AND CADET
PROGRAMS AND BEEN VERY WORTHY
CANDIDATES ONLY TO FIND OUT
LATER ON. THEY COULD NOT PURSUE
THE CAREER THAT THEY WERE
FOCUSED ON BECAUSE OF THE
CITIZENSHIP REQUIREMENT- AND
THERE'S BEEN PLENTY OF POLICE
CHIEFS OF REYES THIS INTERNALLY
WITH US AND INSIDE THE
ASSOCIATION OF A YEARS ALTHOUGH
THE COMPLEXITIES OF ALWAYS
GOTTEN IN THE WAY. AND SO I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER FOR
ACTUALLY FINALLY- BEING WILLING
TO CHAMPION THIS WANT TO PUSH
THE ISSUE. SO WE CAN FIND OUT
WHAT CAN WE DO- ESPECIALLY THE
TIME WHERE RECRUITMENT AT AN ALL
TIME LOW. AND WE NEED A DIVERSE
GROUP OF CANDIDATES THAT
REPRESENT THEIR COMMUNITIES THIS
IS SOMETHING WE ALL FALL TALKED
ABOUT OVER THE YEARS. THIS BILL
DEFINITELY. ASSIST IN THAT
ENDEAVOR- AND LAST I WANT TO
MENTION THAT NOTHING IN SB SIXTY
ROADS. THE STANDARDS FOR
ACADEMIC MORAL CHARACTER OR
PHYSICAL ABILITY- THAT WE HAVE
IN CALIFORNIA. EVERYONE OF THESE
CANDIDATES WOULD HAVE TO PASS
THE SAME STRINGENT. REQUIREMENTS
THAT EVERYONE ELSE HAS TO GO
THROUGH ITS JUST THE CITIZENSHIP
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULDN'T GET IN
THE WAY- AND CONCERNING
BACKGROUND CHECKS IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE DEFINITELY TALKED
ABOUT- I THINK. YOU KNOW IF. AND
THIS IS THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH IT WITHIN THE
ASSOCIATION IS THAT IF SOMEONE
HAS. MAYBE ONLY TWO YEARS ON THE
RECORD THAT THEY'VE BEEN HERE
AND THAT'S ALL THE ONLY
BACKGROUND THAT WE HAVE IN THE
REST COMES FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY
THEN THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET
HIRED. BECAUSE THE AGENCY IS NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SATISFY THAT
THEY'VE DONE A GOOD JOB ON THE
BACKGROUND CHECK TO IDENTIFY.
ANYTHING THAT COULD BE AN ISSUE-
SO- YOU KNOW IF IT AS LONG AS
THERE'S A BODY OF EVIDENCE ABOUT
THE INDIVIDUAL- THEY WILL BE
ELIGIBLE. AND THE CHEESE CAN
MAKE A DECISION AT THAT TIME IF
THEY'RE GONNA HIRE THEM NOTHING
HERE SAYS THAT THEY HAVE TO BE
HIGHER THIS IS JUST ABOUT
ELIGIBILITY- SO. WE'RE PROUD TO
BE IN SUPPORT TODAY AND CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE YOU KNOW
IT'S AS THERE ARE GONNA BE SOME
COMPLEXITIES THAT WE HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH. A BUT AGAIN THANK
THE SENATOR FOR AUTHORING THIS
MONTH. THANK YOU. THE MODERATOR
WILL GO DOOR WELL ARE AMONG THE
FIRST ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM THAT.
WAS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF SB
NINE SIXTIES SCENE NINE NOW WILL
GO TO OUR PHONE LINES MODERATOR.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES. IN Q.
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE SIXTY. AT LEAST JOHN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE. WELL FIRST
GO TO LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT MY WIFE CAN YOU HEAR
ME- YES AGAIN AREA. OKAY THIS IS
REALIZE FROM FLETCHER COUNTY AND
I'M ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION OTHER
STOP. ALL RIGHT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR WITNESSES SUPPORT THANK
GOODNESS. BUT WILL NOW GO TO
NUMBER SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
. BUT PUT CALDWELL HOUSTON
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. WORK THANK YOU. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE. GREAT NOW WILL GO TO
WITNESSES OPPOSITION WE HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS WITNESS JULIO DE
LEON. AND IF MR DALY OWNERS-
HE'S HERE IN PERSON SO WILL
ALLOW HIM TO SUGGEST MONEY AT
THE START THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JULIA THE
LEON. I'M SORRY WITH THE- MERCED
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
I OVER HAVE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT. PROFESSIONAL I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S MARIN AND ON
BEHALF OF SHARES AT THE UNCLE-
WE'RE HERE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION SB NINE SIXTY. ON
TO SPECIFIC GROUNDS NUMBER ONE
THERE'S AMPLE LEGAL PRECEDENT.
TO SUPPORT OPPOSITION NUMBER
TWO. THERE ARE SOME SERIOUS
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUES
INVOLVED. THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
DANGER CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
SAFETY IF THIS BILL WERE TO PASS
AS WRITTEN- BEFORE BEGAN. AND I
TO CLEAR STATE OUR POSITION HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE FOR
IMMIGRANTS OR MIGRANTS AND WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO- HIRING DACA
RECIPIENTS WERE THOUSANDS OF
HARD WORKING. MEN WOMEN TO COME
TO THIS. A CITY CALIFORNIA WORK.
THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY. YOU
SEE I KNOW THE STRUGGLES OF
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE I'M THE SON
OF AN IMMIGRANT OF IMMIGRANT
PARENTS MY PARENTS CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY FROM A SELLER. IN THE
MID NINETEEN SEVENTIES I KNOW
THE STRUGGLES THAT IMMIGRANTS
FACE FIRST HAND. HOWEVER THIS
BILL ELIMINATES A CITIZENSHIP
AND LEGAL PERMANENT RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS FOR PEACE OFFICERS
HOWEVER. IT DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY STATE. WHAT FORMER
WORK PERMIT WOULD BE A
SUBSTITUTE AND THAT IS WHERE WE
ARE HAVING SOME ISSUES WITH THIS
BILL- SOME OF THE FIRST ROUND
OPPOSITION. WHICH IS THE- MORAL
CHARACTER WE'VE HEARD SOME
TESTIMONY BEFORE ABOUT WHAT
MORAL CHARACTER MEANS. HOWEVER
IF SOMEONE APPLIES FOR LEGAL
RESIDENT LEGAL RESIDENCY. OR
WORK PERMITS. THE FEDERAL WORK
PERMIT. R. OR CITIZENSHIP THAT
PERSON THE SUBJECT TO A
BACKGROUND CHECK FROM THE U. S.
C. I. S. UNITED STATES
CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES- AMONG OTHER THINGS.
THEY ARE TODAY THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO DEMONSTRATE GOOD MERIT GOOD
MORAL CHARACTER. AND LOYALTY IN
PRINCIPLE SO YOU GUYS THIS
CONSTITUTION HOWEVER. THEIR
DEFINITION OF GOOD MORAL
CHARACTER IS A LITTLE BIT OF
NARROWLY TAILORED. AND MORE
DEFINED TO NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERNS CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS DID NOT
HAVE THAT ABILITY AND ACCESS TO
FEDERAL RECORDS AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES- AND FEDERAL DATABASES
THAT THEY USED TO SCREEN.
APPLICANTS FOR NATIONAL
NATURALIZATION CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THAT
OPTION- THEY HAVE FINGERPRINT
FBI FAVOR CHECKS WHICH WE DO
HOWEVER WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
CONSULAR LOOKOUT AUTOMATED
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. MISSTATES ACUTE
ADVISORY OPINIONS. WILL HAVE
ACCESS THE TESTIMONY DURING THE
INTERVIEW. AND WE ALSO DON'T
HAVE ANY- ABILITY TO.
INVESTIGATE LEADS FROM OTHER U.
S. GOVERNMENT AGENCIES OR
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS HAVE NO
JURISDICTION OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CANNOT GO TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY OUTSIDE OUR
BORDERS AND ASK THEM FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
CITIZENSHIP AND WHAT THEY DID.
ARE TO COME TO NICE THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT I SEE IS A IS A
WITHOUT SPECIFICALLY STATING. IN
THE BILL. THAT THE PERSON IS
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A FEDERAL
WORK PERMIT. THAT SUBJECTS THAT
PERSON TO THIS KIND OF SCRUTINY
. THAT COULD QUITE FRANKLY
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS DO NOT
HAVE. A WITHOUT THAT LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL. THERE'S A POTENTIAL
FOR SOMEONE COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY. ILLEGALLY THE NEXT DAY
APPLY FOR PEACE OFFICER STATUS
AND AT THAT POINT THEY WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO WEAPONS OF THE
PAST ACADEMY. THEY WOULD- HAVE
ACCESS TO CRIMINAL INFORMATION
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. AND
OTHER- TACTICS POLICE TACTICS.
AND TURN AROUND AND USE IT
AGAINST US WHAT ONE DAY. SECOND
PROBLEM IS A LEGAL PRECEDENT
THERE ARE TWO UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT CASES THAT HAVE
BEEN- UP HELD SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT- DIRECTLY ON POINT
THE FIRST IS FULLY VERSUS
CALLING. FOR THIRTY FIVE US TWO
NINETY ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY A
CASE. NEW YORK STATE TROOPERS
MOST LIKE CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE A
STATUTE. THAT REQUIRES
CITIZENSHIP. BUT WE ARE THAT
STATUTE VIOLATED THE EQUAL
PROTECTION CLAUSE OR TO THE
MOMENT OR DISAGREE. AND THE
COURT- QUOTE THE COURT THE COURT
SAID THAT THE POLICE FUNCTION IS
ESSENTIALLY A DESCRIPTION OF ONE
OF THE BASIC FUNCTIONS OF
GOVERNMENT POLICE TO FILM THE IN
MOST FUNDAMENTAL OBLIGATION OF
GOVERNMENT TO HIS CONSTITUENCY
THEY ARE CLOTHED WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO EXERCISE AN ALMOST
INFINITE VARIETY OF
DISCRETIONARY POWERS. THE
DECISION AFFECTS MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC. SIGNIFICANTLY AND OFTEN
THE MOST SENSITIVE AREAS OF
DAILY LIFE AN ARREST IS A
SERIOUS MATTER. FOR ANY PERSON
EVEN WORK WERE NO PROSECUTION
FALLS ONE OF CLOSE GRANTED SO
CLEARLY THE EXERCISE POLICE
AUTHORITY CALLS FOR A VERY HIGH
DEGREE OF JUDGMENT. AND
DISCRETION. AND THE COURT SAID
CITIZENS ARE PRESUMED TO BE MORE
FAMILIAR WITH A SYMPATHETIC TO
AMERICAN TRADITIONS THEREFORE
STATE ME CONSONANT WITH THE
CONSTITUTION CONFINE THE
PERFORMANCE OF THIS IMPORTANT
PUBLIC RESPONSIBILITY TO
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE SECOND CASE CONNELLY SAME
SAME A- THE SAME ANALYSIS THE
COURT REALLY WAS IT WAS IT'S
CONSTITUTIONAL FOR STATES TO
RESTRICT THE SAUCERS- TO HAVE
CITIZENSHIP. AND IT WAS A
MENTION ABOUT ATTORNEYS AND
FORTY ONE OTHER- POSSESS OUR
PROFESSIONS THAT HAVE GOTTEN
AWAY FROM CITIZENSHIP. PERSONAL
STORY I AM ALSO AN ATTORNEY. I
HAVE A PRIVATE PRACTICE ON THE
SIDE. WHEN I'M ACTING AS AN
ATTORNEY I AM NOT A GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE I AM A PRIVATE PERSON.
I REPRESENT PRIVATE CLIENTS. I
DO IN IRAQ WITH THE COURT AND I
DO INTERACT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
BUT I'M NOT A GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE BY CONTRAST EVERY PEACE
OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA. IS A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE. IS HIRED BY
A GOVERNMENT AGENCY SO THERE'S A
CLEAR DISTINCTION. THAT THE
COURT HAS ALWAYS DRAWN. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
HELD THESE TWO SUPREME COURT
CASES. THIRTY SECTION. THAT YOU
CONCLUDE YES SIR THE CLOSING OF
THE BERRIES NOW WE CANNOT IN
GOOD FAITH. SUPPORT THE BILL AND
THIS WEEK WE ARE ASKING FOR NO
VOTE UNLESS- CENTER SKINNER NAY
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO AMEND THE BILL TO
ADULTS SPECIFIC LANGUAGES. THAT
WE ARE REQUEST THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN THE ROOM WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF US THREE NINE
SIXTY. SHE NONE MODERATOR NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
SIXTY. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND WE GIVE THREE IN
OUR QUEUE AT THIS MOMENT- WILL
FIRST GO TO NUMBER SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET TIRED OF
THE STREET WATCH AGAIN I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION WITH WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE TO
WITNESS. NOW GO TO NUMBER SIXTY
NINE. NUMBER SIX YEAH GOOD.
HELLO MOVED TO NUMBER FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ERICA HOW WILLIAMS AND MICHAEL
COLE SB. NINE SIX ZERO THANKS
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE ALL RIGHT I'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
AND- I DON'T SHE LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. OF THE
BILL OF CENTER SKINNER WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO ADD ME ON- SO ARE.
SO I YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF THE UP
OPPOSITION WHAT SORT OF BIG
PICTURE ON THIS BILL SO I HAVE-
SINCE I'VE BEEN AN ELECTIVE
OFFICE FOR ABOUT TWELVE YEARS
NOW I'VE ATTENDED- ALMOST EVERY
POLICE ACADEMY GRADUATION AT SAN
FRANCISCO A POLICE DEPARTMENT
IT'S GREAT TO GO AND SEE THESE
NEW YOUNG DIVERSE CADETS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING PART OF OUR COMMUNITY IN
SAN FRANCISCO- AND FOR A LONG
TIME- THESE CLASSES ARE ALWAYS
BUDGET AT IKE FIFTY FIVE. I
COULD THAT'S IN ABOUT FORTY OR
FORTY TO GRADUATE- A FEW WEEKS
AGO I WENT TO THE MOST RECENT
ONE OR THIRTEEN- GRADUATES I
THOUGHT BECAUSE IT THE CITY
BUDGETED FOR SMALLER CLASSES
BECAUSE THERE'S A REAL SHORTAGE
OF PEOPLE WHO THESE DAYS ARE
GOING TO GO INTO A POLICING AND
SO ON THE IDEA THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY WHO ARE
WHO ARE HAVE AUTHORIZATION. TO
WORK- HERE AND BUT AND ARE.
WHILE FIVE TWO PEOPLE ALL. AND
ASSEMBLY BANDS BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT. YET CITIZENS. I JUST THINK
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO PROHIBIT
THEM AND WE SHOULD GIVE. OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
FLEXIBILITY. THE BILL DO THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND IF THEY IF
THEY'RE SLOPPY ABOUT THOSE THAT
ARE IN ABOUT THE GREATEST
LIABILITY OF EVERY INCENTIVE TO
DO. STRONG BACKGROUND CHECKS ARE
GONNA GO THROUGH ALL THE
TRAINING THAT EVERYONE ELSE-
GOES THROUGH. AND I THINK WE
SHOULD GIVE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT ABILITY I ALSO DO
WANT TO SAID THE- OPPOSITION
THEN MAKE A REFERENCE TO
NATIONAL SECURITY AND THE PEOPLE
COULD GET TRAINING AND THEN USE
IT AGAINST US. LET'S BE CLEAR
PEOPLE GET TRAINING IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE HOME
YOU'RE GOING TO USE THAT
TRAINING AGAINST YOU KNOW. OUR
OUR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA- AND- I DON'T THINK
THAT. DENYING THEM YOU KNOW SOME
OF SOMEONE WANTS TO DO SOMETHING
BAD. TO SAY WELL WE'RE NOT GONNA
GIVE YOU POLICE ACADEMY TRAINING
NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE LIKE OKAY
I'M NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING BAD
PEOPLE GET TRAINING- AND A LOT
OF DIFFERENT WAYS. AND I ALSO
AND THIS IS A TRAGEDY. THAT ON
JANUARY SIX THERE WERE SEVERAL
DOZEN- CURRENT AND RETIRED
POLICE OFFICERS WHO WERE PART OF
THAT INSURRECTION. SO THE IDEA
THAT IF WE JUST LIMIT POLICE
OFFICERS TO- CITIZENS. DIED THAT
MEANS IT'S ALL GOING TO BE GOOD-
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT IF PEOPLE
WANT TO DO SOMETHING BAD. SUCH
AS TRY TO OVERTHROW THE US
GOVERNMENT ON THEY CAN DO THAT
EVEN IF THEY'RE CITIZENS AND
UNFORTUNATELY A LARGE NUMBER OF
CITIZENS DID- TRY TO VIOLENTLY
OVERTHROW THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT- SO THIS IS A GOOD.
BILL I SUPPORT A AND I MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR THE SKETCH
AND DEBATE THIS IS. SKINNER
TROUBLE. THANK YOU I'M IN THANK
YOU SENATOR ASKING FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FOURTH EIGHT YOU KNOW
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I HAD
NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE THESE FIRST
OF ALL IT'S BEEN AN EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME. LET'S JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT. BUT AS SOMEONE
WHO- AS JULIO AND I'M SORRY YOUR
LAST NAME I'M REALLY ON THE LEON
THAT'S RIGHT WITH A LOAN-
MENTION ALSO A DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANT PARENTS- IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND I THINK- I THINK
ONE OF THE CONCERNS AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO ABOUT- MOVING FORWARD HERE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
SO I HAVE THE ABILITY TO LIVE IN
MEXICO WITH MY GRANDPARENTS AND
MY PARENTS AND THEN WITH YOUR
BACK AND FORTH IN THE U. S. IN
HERE SO I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
LIVE IN MEXICO. AND I AM A US
CITIZEN AT SOME POINT OCCUR IS
THE CITED THAT I WOULD JUST KEEP
THE U. S. CITIZENSHIP- IN PLACE
. AND I AM ACTUALLY- I'M I'M
GRATEFUL I- I OFTEN SPEAK ABOUT
THE- THE LOVE THAT I HAVE FOR
THIS COUNTRY AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT IT IS OFFERED
AS FLOW THROUGH EDUCATION AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND I'M A
FERVENT ADVOCATE FOR LEGAL
IMMIGRATION THE REASON BEING IS
THAT I HATE I HATE. TO SEE
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE SHADOWS. IN
THIS COUNTRY. BECAUSE IT LEAVES
THEM VULNERABLE TO EXPLOITATION
ON SO MANY FRONTS. AND SO THAT'S
WHY I EAT AMID ADVOCATE FOR
LEGAL IMMIGRATION IN A REFORM
IMMIGRATION POLICIES IN THIS
COUNTRY BECAUSE I THINK THERE
ARE TRULY OUTDATED AND TALK
ABOUT OUTDATED- YOU KNOW.
PROCESSES AND- THOUGHT I MEET
OUR OUR- OUR IMMIGRATION PROCESS
IS OUTDATED IN THE WEEK WE
LEGALIZE WE INTEGRATE. ONE
MILLION IMMIGRANTS A YEAR
LEGALLY INTO THIS COUNTRY- THEY
ARE AT LOT OF LOOPHOLES AND I A
LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH IMMIGRATION
HAS AND MAKES A VERY LENGTHY AND
FOR SOME PEOPLE THEY'RE LIVING
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO. HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE
HERE BUT- MY MAIN CONCERN IS THE
FACT THAT WHEN WE HAVE
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE LIVING IN
OUR COUNTRY IT DOES LEAVE
VULNERABLE TO EXPLOITATION AND
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT. FEDERAL-
AND I THINK. I THINK THE ANGLE
IN WHICH WE SHOULD BE WORKING
TOWARDS MORE EFFICIENTLY WOULD
BE IN OUR IMMIGRATION REFORM
THAT ALLOWS THESE KIDS- AS YOU
THINK IT'S BECAUSE IT'S ANYONE A
YOUNG ADULT AS WELL- WHO ARE IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES TO BE ABLE
TO BECOME CITIZENS AND THE
REASON BEING I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO- TO- HAVE THAT USE
IT. THERE'S A REASON WHY WE
THERE'S CERTAIN- SPACES THAT WE-
WE REQUIRE PEOPLE TO BE EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLDER TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD
U. S. ITIZENS AND SO FORTH. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE
THAT OATH. TO BECOME A CITIZEN
OF THIS COUNTRY. YOU'RE SWEARING
ALLEGIANCE TO THIS COUNTRY AND
WHAT IT STANDS FOR AND I'M NOT
SAYING THAT MANY OF OUR OUR
YOUNG UNDOCUMENTED- YOUNG ADULTS
DID NOT CHOOSE IT WOULD NOT DO
THAT BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IF
THEY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT THEY WOULD DO THAT IF THEY
IF THE IMMIGRATION PROCESS ALLOW
THEM TO DO THAT AND DEPENDING ON
WHERE THEY ARE I'M I'M- YOU KNOW
I. IT MAKES ME CONCERNED THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS HIM TO PURSUE THAT
ABILITY TO DO THAT BECAUSE I
THINK IF THEY HAD THE CHOICE TO
DO THAT RIGHT NOW. THEY WOULD
PROBABLY DO THAT. BUT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
SOMEONE CHOOSES TO REMAIN A
CITIZEN OF A DIFFERENT COUNTRY
THE CHOICE. NOT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T BECOME CITIZENS THIS
COUNTRY BUT I CHOICE TO BECOME A
CITIZEN OF ANOTHER COUNTRY.
PERSON BECOMING A U. S. CITIZEN.
THEN IT MAKES ME QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT THEY THEIR HEART-
TO PROTECTING- IN- YEAH I WAS
LEADING HERE JUST BECAUSE-
DEMONSTRATE A KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE U. S.
HISTORY IN GOVERNMENT AND
DEMONSTRATE A LOYALTY. LOYALTY
TO THE PRINCIPLES OF THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. ANDY WILLING TO
TAKE THE OATH OF ALLEGIANCE. TO
THIS COUNTRY AND THAT IS A
CHOICE THAT THEY- THAT THEY MAKE
WHEN THEY BECOME YOU ASSIST
CITIZENS AND ONCE AGAIN I'M
TALKING ABOUT- YOUNG ADULTS WHO
CHOOSE TO IF THEY COULD BECAUSE
THE IMMIGRATION POLICIES WOULD
ALLOW THEM- I'M NOT SPEAKING TO
THE TO THE TO THE FACT THAT MANY
CAN'T OR HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
BUT TO THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD.
SO MY ANGLE AND MY CONCERN WOULD
BE THAT. WE NEED TO REFORM OUR
IMMIGRATION POLICIES AND THAT'S
I KNOW THAT'S A FEDERAL ISSUE
NOT A STATE ISSUE BUT WE NEED TO
WORK ON THAT END TO ALLOW THESE-
THESE CADETS TO BE ABLE TO WORK
YOU KNOW WITH. THE CHOICE TO. BE
LOYAL TO THE FRIENDS OF THE US
CONSTITUTION BE WILLING TO TAKE
THE OATH OF ALLEGIANCE ON THAT
END- BEFORE COMMITTING TO THAT
BECAUSE I'M JUST KIND OF
WONDERING WHETHER OR NOT. BY
PLACING IN THIS POSITION IN
MAKES THEM VULNERABLE. TO THE
INFLUENCES OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
THIS COUNTRY. AND THAT TO ME- IS
SOMEONE WHO ABSOLUTELY LOVES
THIS COUNTRY. AND IS SO GRATEFUL
BUT ALSO APPRECIATE AND LOVE THE
HERITAGE WHICH I AM. BEEN FACED
WITH IN WHO WHO MAKES ME WHO I
AM. I THINK AS A STATE WE START
. LAUNDERING JUST A TAD THERE'S
A REASON WHY SO MANY PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD COME TO THIS
COUNTRY IS BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
SAFETY AS WE HAVE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THAT KEEP US SAFE
WE'RE NOT PERFECT BECAUSE OF
HUMAN BEINGS MAKING WRONG
CHOICES OF COURSE WE'RE NOT
PERFECT BUT WE HAVE IDEALS AND
PRINCIPLES AND LAWS THE HELP OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS STAY SAFE. AND
WHEN WE STARBRIGHT KEEN THOSE
AND TRYING TO WORK AROUND THEN
WE START. READING LOOPHOLES AND-
THERE'S A WORD THAT I'M THINKING
OF IN MY- THE MEETING BUT I THE
WORD I'M I'M NOT QUITE COMING TO
MY TO MY THE FRONT OF MY- I
THINK HERE. BUT I'M AFRAID I'M
AFRAID. THAT WE START MESSING
WITH OUR WITH OUR PRINCIPLES AND
CREATING LEGAL LOOPHOLES. THAT
NOT FOR THE GOOD HEARTED
INTENDED PERSON BUT THE
LOOPHOLES THAT IT LEAVES US
VULNERABLE TO. TO THOSE WITH-
NEFARIOUS HEARTS. AND MINDS. TO
THE VERY STATE AND COUNTRY THAT
WE- THAT WE HAVE AT HAND AND SO-
ON THAT END I CANNOT I. WOULD
LOVE LOVE TO WORK AND SEE YOU
KNOW IF ARE. ARE- OUR OUR-
REPRESENTATIVES IN AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WOULD TAKE ON THIS
ISSUE AND HELP WITH IMMIGRATION
POLICIES- WITH REFORM BUT IN
THIS CASE AS FAR AS THE STATE
GOES AND- AND NOT FOR THE GOOD
HEARTED GOOD WILL- PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE BUT FOR THE NEFARIOUS
ACTORS THAT WE MAY HAVE. COMING
IN AND USING THAT AS A LOOPHOLE
TO- TO WORK WITHIN THEIR SYSTEM
NOT THAT QUICK CREATES A GREAT
CONCERN I DON'T WANT OUR SYSTEM
OF LAWS HAD TO BE- HI. GOSH WHAT
IS THE WORD I'M LOOKING FOR
ANYBODY. I'M SORRY COMPROMISED I
GUESS YOU COULD THE IT'S THE
ONLY WAY I CAN THINK OF RIGHT
NOW IS COMPROMISED I THINK
THERE'S- WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR POLICIES AND LAWS.
THAT MAKE US WHO WE ARE AS A
COUNTRY. ANY OTHER ASIAN
PERMISSION TO RESPOND YES
PLEASE- PRECIADO CURE-
SUPPRESSING THOSE BUT I WANTED
TO CLARIFY THIS DOES NOT ALLOW
THOSE WERE LIVING IN THE SHADOWS
TO BECOME A POLICE OFFICER. THIS
BILL ONLY ALLOWS THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIVING LEGALLY AND HAVE
THE LEGAL ABILITY TO WORK HERE.
SO THROUGH VISA GREEN CARD THAT
PERMANENT RESIDENCY BUT THERE'S
A VARIETY OF FORMS THERE'S A
VARIETY OF MECHANISMS THAT GIVE
YOU THE ABILITY TO HAVE THAT
LEGAL RIGHT TO WORK HERE. BUT
NOT BUT IS NOT FULL CITIZENSHIP
. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DO IT IS NOT OPENING
THE PROFESSION TO ANYONE WHO
HAPPENED TO COME HERE AND US AND
GONE THROUGH ANY PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO LEGALLY WORK HERE. THE.
TWENTY ANY ADDITIONAL COMES TO
QUESTIONS FOR THE GARLIC'S. I
WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER FOR THIS COMMON SENSE
MEASURE AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
NEFARIOUS INDIVIDUALS WHO FAIL
TO TAKE ALL OF OUR ADULT IF
THAT'S JUST SCARES YOU THEN
JANUARY SIX MUST'VE BEEN A
PICNIC BECAUSE IT WAS SPOKE TO
HAVE BEEN BORN HERE THEIR ENTIRE
LIFE. AND YOU WE HAD A POLICE
CHIEF FROM THE STATE WHO
ACTIVELY USE THAT TRAINING TO
TRY TO OVERTURN THIS GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT SO THE MERE FACT THAT
SOMEONE WAS NOT BORN HERE OR
SOMEONE HAS NOT TAKEN OVER DOES
NOT DETERMINE THE DEGREE OF
LOYALTY TO THIS COUNTRY OR TO
LOOK LOYALTY TO. YOU KNOW THEY
HAD THEIR FELLOW MAN AND LIKE A
STATE JANUARY SIXTH HERE AT ME
AND THE MAJORITY OF THOSE FOLKS
WERE BORN HERE AND NEVER TOOK
CALLED BECAUSE THEY WERE BORN
HERE IN IN AND OUT TO PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE AND MANY OF THEM MET
THROUGH MILITARY AND POLICE
SERVICE BUT THEY FELT QUITE
COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TO YOU. KNOW
TRY TO OVERTURN THE GOVERNMENT
SO IF YOU HAVE YOUNG FOLKS HERE
WHO- HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE MIGHT
NOT HAVE BEEN BORN HERE BUT THEY
DESIRE DESIRE TO PROTECT. AND
SERVE INTO IT AN AUDIBLE WAY.%
AND OUR OUR WILL TO THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE. I THINK THEY SHOULD
BE JUST AS WELCOME AS THOSEMANY
INDIVIDUALS THAT AS WE SEE THAT
WERE BORN HERE WHO. CHOOSE TO
OVERTURN THIS GOVERNMENT AND
FROM THE WORST TERRORIST ARE
BORN RIGHT HERE ON THIS. IN THIS
COUNTRY EVERY DAY SO. I
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU THAT NOTE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES
THANK YOU- I KNOW THAT WE WILL
BE WORKING AS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH. TO ENSURE THAT ANY
AGENCY CAN DO AN APPROPRIATE
THROWBACK BACKGROUND CHECK AS-
ARE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE-
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION SAID
YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT BE SOME
CLARIFICATIONS WE NEED BUT
CERTAINLY. WE KNOW THAT OUR
AGENCIES ARE NOT GOING TO JUST
RUSH TO HIRE. PEOPLE THAT THEY-
HAVE. IN IN THEIR ABILITY TO DO
AN APPROPRIATE BACKGROUND CHECK.
SO WHAT- WHAT THIS DOES IS JUST
READ. REMOVE THE OBSTACLE. THAT
YOU THAT YOUR THAT IF YOU'RE A
PERSON. WHERE IS THE LEGAL
ABILITY TO WORK HERE. THAT YOU
HAD AND WE OBVIOUSLY WILL AS WE
SAID AS IT MOVES THROUGH WORK
OUT ANYTHING THAT WOULD- WOULD
BE RESTRICTIVE FOR THE- THAT
PERSON FROM BEING ABLE TO
FUNCTION AS A SWORN OFFICER
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE INTENTION
IS THAT THEY COULD FULLY
FUNCTION. THAT AND WE WOULD BE
ALIGNING OURSELVES WITH A NUMBER
OF OTHER STATES WHO DO NOT HAVE
THE REQUIREMENT OF BEING A
CITIZEN AS THE AS THE THING THAT
- A PRIMARY- CRITERIA FOR YOUR
ABILITY TO BE A SWORN OFFICER
ANOTHER WORDS WE WOULD BE WE
WOULD BE OPENING IT TO ALLOW
FOR- PEOPLE HAVE THE LEGAL
ABILITY TO WORK BUT OTHERWISE
MEET ALL OTHER CRITERIA THAT WE
EXPECT. FOR SWORN OFFICERS. AND
YOUR CARD I ASKED RIVALS WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER WE I
WOULD DO PASSED BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
SB NINE SIXTY. BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD I'D SHOW BOTH FOR ABOVE
NO COM MARKER HI KAMLAGER AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE VOTES FORTY ONE FORTY
ONE THAT MEASURES OUT NEXT WE
HAVE SENATORS WIENER WITH ELEVEN
SB ELEVEN OH SIX.
KAREN CENTER WHEN YOU'RE READY.
BUT FOR THE RECORD THIS THING
NEEDS TO BE RAISED. RIGHT NOW
WITH MY LITTLE LIKE A LITTLE
BABY DOLL. PRESENTATION. OKAY.
SO WALKED INTO THE SAME SPACE
I'M COLLEAGUES- THEY'RE
PRESENTING SENATE BILL I'M
ELEVEN OH SIX THE FRESH START
ACT WHICH HELPS PEOPLE TO CLEAR
THEIR CRIMINAL RECORDS BY
ENSURING- THAT OUTSTANDING
RESTITUTION RESTITUTION FINES
ARE NOT A BARRIER TO EXPUNGEMENT
AND A FRESH START I'M CURRENTLY-
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE FOR
EXPUNGEMENT OF THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORD- ARE FREQUENTLY DENIED
THAT EXPLAINS GRANT- BASED
SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT THEY
HAVE ON P. R. RESTITUTION. THE
RESTITUTION THAT IS- THEN THE
ONLY THING HOLDING THEM BACK
FROM CLEARING THE RECORD AND
BEING ABLE TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE STABLE HOUSING AND A JOB
CETERA- WE KNOW THAT WHEN COURTS
THAT RESTITUTION IT'S NOT BASED
ON ABILITY. TO PAY SO SOMEONE
WHO IS. THERE POOR COULD A REST
- A REQUIREMENT IN THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OR EVEN MORE AND SO
THE PERSON HAS BEEN RELEASED-
FROM PRISON- AND THERE IS REALLY
NO WAY FOR THEM TO PAY- THAT
RESTITUTION- AND- THERE'S NO WAY
FOR THEM TO CLEAR THE
RESTITUTION- AND SO THEY'RE THAN
STOCK WITHOUT THAT. AND TO BE
CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY
WAY CLEAR THAT RESTITUTION
REDUCE WHAT THEY HAVE TO PAY.
THAT IS A SEPARATE CONVERSATION
WE KNOW THAT THE RESTITUTION
SYSTEM IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
VICTIMS ALMOST NEVER GOT. EITHER
ANY RESTITUTION REALLY ONLY GOT
A SMALL PERCENTAGE THE SYSTEM IS
NOT HELPING. VICTIMS BUT
PARTICULAR IN PARTICULAR WHEN WE
THEN I EXPUNGE RENT WITH AN AYE
RECORD CLEARING TO PEOPLE.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY OWE
RESTITUTION FOR MAKING IT EVEN
HARDER FOR THEM EVER TO PAY ANY
PIECE. OF THAT RESTITUTION. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY IT AGAIN THIS
BILL DOES NT REDUCE WHAT
PEOPLE- IT DOESN'T GET RID OF
RESTITUTION THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES- COUNTRY SOME OF
THE CONFUSION THE SOME PEOPLE
HAD ABOUT THE BILL. ALL IT DOES
IS SAY THAT A JUDGE CANNOT RELY
EXCLUSIVELY. ON UNPAID
RESTITUTION TO THE LIVE RECORD
CLEARING IF SOMEONE IS OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE- JUDGE CANCER WHERE YOU
OWE RESTITUTION YOU CANNOT HAVE
YOUR RECORD PLAYER THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW A PERSON TO GET THE
RECORD CLEARED. IT WOULD STILL
OF THE RESTITUTION BUT THEY
COULD AT LEAST HAVE A CHANCE TO
GET THEIR LIFE BACK TOGETHER AND
START MOVING FORWARD ALSO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ARE WITH ME TODAY BY PHONE TO
TESTIFY ARE ARE REAL LATER AND
SEE IF IT WAS A PUBLIC DEFENDER-
FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY- AND THEN THE
BELL BAYLOR THE DEPUTY. DIRECTOR
OF FREEDOM FOR YOU. WELL A
LAWYER WITH IS TO MINUTES EACH A
TOTAL MEMBERS TO FOR THEIR
TESTIMONIES MISTER. LEONARD J.
OF YOUR READY MAY BEGIN.
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND I THINK THE ELEVEN OH SIX
TODAY MY NAME IS ARIELLE LATE
FEES AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE CLEAN SLATE PROGRAM AT
ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE. AS PART OF THE HOLISTIC
MODEL IN OUR OFFICE THE DRAFT
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM ARE
PROGRAM REPRESENTS PEOPLE
SEEKING CRIMINAL RECORD. SB
ELEVEN OF BIG WILL ALLOW MORE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA TO CLEAN
THEIR CRIMINAL RECORDS AND
THEREFORE THE LEAD TO GREATER
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MORE PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE.
HELLO RECORD RELEASE PUTS PEOPLE
IN A BETTER POSITION TO SECURE
EMPLOYMENT AND CERTAIN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES AND
MAINTAIN STABLE EMPLOYMENT.
HOWEVER IMPACT OUT DEMOCRATS DID
OFTEN USED AS A REASON TO DENY
THIS RELIEF EVEN ARE COMMON WITH
OTHERWISE BE ENTITLED TO THAT.
AND- I FEEL LET ME KNOW THANKS
MISSILE AND REDUCTION OF
CONVICTION NOT BE DENIED SOLELY
BECAUSE OF OUTSTANDING
RESTITUTION OR RESTITUTION
FINES. AND RESTITUTION WILL NOT
BE A FACTOR IN DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY. THE NINE ONE RECORD
RELEASED ACTION SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACT THEIR ABILITY TO PASS A
BACKGROUND CHECK MAKES IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO FIND
THE ONE POINT. THE FEDERAL DO
NOT REMOVE AN OBLIGATION TO PAY
ANY OUTSTANDING VICTIM
RESTITUTION BUT THEY DO PUT
SOMEONE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
SECURE EMPLOYMENT. APPLE AFTER
WORKING WITH OUR PROGRAM TO GET
CRIMINAL RECORD VANITY ONE
CLIENT WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE
FROM A TEMP JOB TO A FULL TIME
PERMANENT POSITION. I CAME WITH
THE PAY AND- BENEFITS INCLUDING
MEDICAL AND DENTAL COVERAGE.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE MORE
PEOPLE ACCESS TO CLEAN PLATE
RELIEF LEADING TO A BETTER
CHANCE OF ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
BILLETE ABOUT THE LINE. WHICH
WILL BENEFIT BOTH INDIVIDUALS
WITH HEART CONDITIONS. AND OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU- THANK YOU.
NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS. SPELL IT OUT I SAID
AND- I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN SENATOR BRADFORD AND
BINGLEY ON ALL THE OTHER BEING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE FOR OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY THOUGHTS AND WHAT OF
THE FBI OH SIX. MY NAME IS FULL
OF GAVE ARMS AND I'M THE DEPUTY
OF FOR YOU CAN FIND A BARBARA
I'M TESTIFYING OF THE PERSON HO
IS DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
RESTITUTION I WAS ORDERED TO PAY
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
RESTITUTION FOR STAFF WHICH
AMOUNTS TO AN OUTSTANDING OLDER
OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WITH FINANCING FEES FROM CDC
ARE. COULD FRANCHISE BOARD
AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
ADMINISTERED THIS ORDER I WILL
BE PAYING THIS RESTITUTION.
ORDER FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
INSPITE OF MY BECAUSE TO THE A-
MEDICINE WORKING TO. BOTH YOU
AND ADULT INSIDE AND OUT OF
THIS. THE INABILITY TO CLEAR MY
RECORD OR OBTAIN OUR PARTY DUE
TO THE ONGOING PAYMENT OF THE
RESTITUTION I WAS ORDERED. HAD
PLACED IN REMARKABLE VERY VERY
YEARS IN MY LIFE. EVEN THIRTEEN
YEARS AFTER BEING RELEASED. FROM
PRISON. FOR EXAMPLE IN SEEKING
TO SECURE NEW HOUSING IN A SAFE
NEIGHBORHOOD A FULL BACKGROUND
CHECK WHICH RAN INTO TO MY
RECORD. MY APPLICATION WITH.
THIS IS ALSO THE CASE IN THE
CONSOLE REPLYING FOR THREE
POSITIONS WITHIN LEADING
CORPORATIONS WHERE I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO EARN WHERE I WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO EARN A HIGHER
INCOME. THIS BILL HOWEVER
REMOVES ONE OF THOSE BARRIERS.
THAT PREVENT THOSE IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION FROM CLEARING OUR
CRIMINAL RECORDS BY PROHIBITING
EXPUNGEMENT DENIAL WELL DO FOLEY
TO UNPAID RESTITUTION. WITHOUT
THIS BILL THOSE OF US WHO ARE
ORDERED TO PAY RESTITUTION
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE THE
EFFECTS OF SOCIAL IMPRISONMENT.
IN SPITE OF BEING IN THE FREE
WORLD WHEN I'M ABLE TO SECURE
QUALITY HOUSING AND OR BETTER
JOB OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO OUR
RECORD. I'M ASKING THE COMMITTEE
TO PLEASE SUPPORT S. B. ELEVEN
OH SIX AND GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY. A FRESH START THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW WILL TAKE TO A
WITNESSES HERE IN TE ROOM-
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK ISRAEL BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS I JUST READ THE
SHORTLIST OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
IN SUPPORT. RUDIN REBOUND. YOUR
AVOID A CENTER FOR THE ARTS ON
COMMON LAW. COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATE SERVICES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON DAN
AYKROYD ARMEL WASTING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREAAT COMMUNITY
LEGAL SERVICES IN EAST PALO ALTO
SAN FRANCISCO FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT RUBICON PROGRAMS CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING AND
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLYN
GOOSSEN FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE VOICING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS KELLY WALTERS
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN WE'RE A PROUD SPONSOR
OF THIS- OF S. B. ELEVEN OH SIX
ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO- STATE
THE SUPPORTER OF NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER JUSTICE TO
JOBS COALITION PUBLIC COUNCIL
AND FREEDOM FOR YOUTH. THANK YOU. CHRIS RESPONSES POSSIBLY GET
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY TRANSPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS A LITTLE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN SUPPORT
THANK. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
OH SIX. ENGINE NINE WILL GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
IT. FIND SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN
OH SIX IN A PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME- FIRST OF THE TO LINE
SIXTY SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION. IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ENTITLEMENTS FOR ON BEHALF OF
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS HENRY I'M WITH ALL OF
US ARE NOT AND ON THE- AND STOP
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF ALEX. TO
TWELVE. THANKS THE TIMELINE
SEVENTY THREE THEY STILL HAD.
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MEXICO
CAROLINA SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI CHRISTINA ROBINSON WITH
COMMUNITY HILLARD YES I'M DONE
AND WERE IN FULL SUPPORT. LIKE
TO GO TO LINE OF SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVERY MODEL
CAME WITH ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP
AND SUPPORT. THANKS A GOOD LINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
ONE LEAD. KIM STONE HE'LL BE
AFFORDED FOUR MINUTES TO MAKE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. ELEVEN OH SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH KEN STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN. LONELY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION-
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION DOES AGREE THAT
PICKED THEM- ARE GETTING THE
RESTITUTION THEY DESERVE AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
BELIEVES THAT REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT DEFENDANTS
COMPLETE THEIR RESTITUTION ORDER
TO THE VICTIM AND THE FINES TO
THE COURT. FAVORS DEFENDANTS AT
THE EXPENSE OF THEIR VICTIMS CDA
IS THIS AN IS THAT CURRENT LAW
DOES PROVIDE COURTS WITH THE
DISCRETION TO REMOVE THAT
RESTITUTION REQUIREMENTS MADE IF
THEY BELIEVE IF THE JUDGE
BELIEVES- JUSTICE REQUIRES IT
AND THAT CURRENT LAW STRIKES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE. THEREFORE
CDA MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
ABOUT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
HERE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION LEVEL SIX HEARING
TINA AND WILL GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES MODERATOR ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX. THE SENATE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO- COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION- YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE THE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THEY'RE NOT SURE IF THE
MEMBER SHARON A LARGE AND I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE QUICKNESS. NEXT TO THE
LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IBM AND
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL ELEVEN
OH SIX THANK YOU. AND IS THERE
SOMEONE ELSE IN Q. GREAT WILL
BRING I BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
HAS ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO S. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX. SKINNER CALMER.
I'LL JUST MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME IT'S BEEN
MOVED. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ON THIS MEASURE
MEASURE. HEARING TINA AND WINDOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I'VE
VOEPEL YEAH I JUST WANT
CLARIFICATION SO. WITH THE
EXPUNGEMENT PART OF IT. I MISS.
BEAR WITH ME UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIRTEEN DOWN SO THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GAIN
EMPLOYMENT. IS THAT WITH DO YOU
HAVE THE INTENT TO DO THAT
IMMEDIATELY OR AFTER A PERIOD OF
TIME. WHAT WHAT'S WHAT WHEN IT
SO RIGHT NOW- WHEN PEOPLE HAVE A
RECORD THAT HAS NOT BEEN CLEARED
THEY CAN GET THE BARITONE
PLACEMENT IN VARIOUS WAYS FIRST
OF ALL WE KNOW THERE'S A LAUNDRY
LIST OF TYPES OF PROFESSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE YOU ARE IF YOU
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE FELONY
CONVICTION YOU ARE SIMPLY YOU
CAN'T GET A LICENSE I THINK
MAYBE EVEN LIKE AS A BARBER OR
THERE'S ALL SORTS OF IT'S
HORRIBLE IT'S A SEPARATE THING
WE NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM HEAD
OF. SHOULD NOT BE PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO WORK
SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE A CLEAR
RECORD THERE'S A WHOLE LAUNDRY
LIST OF JOBS THAT YOU ARE
LEGALLY PROHIBITED. IN ADDITION.
THERE ARE JUST TIMES WHEN
EMPLOYER WHAT HIRE YOU AND EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE YOU KNOW EVEN IF
THERE IS BAN THE BOX.
LEGISLATION RATHER CANCER
SCREENING ABOUT THE BEGINNING
THEY CAN STILL SCREEN YOU OUT AT
THE END OF THE PROCESS. SO WE
KNOW THEM SOMEONE HAS AN UNCLEAR
RECORD IT IS HARDER TO FIND
WORK. FOR THE WORK THAT YOU FIND
IS GOING TO BE LOWER PAID. OUR
WORK IT'S ALSO HARD TO FIND
HOUSING. AND SO YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE IF WE WANT THAT AGAIN WE
CAN PUT ASIDE A SEPARATE DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER THE CURRENT
RESTITUTION. SYSTEM IS EVEN
SERVING VICTIMS IT'S REALLY NOT
IT'S A FAILED. DISASTER OF A
SYSTEM THAT. HURTS EVERYONE- BUT
IF WE IF WE ARE IF YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO REPAY TO MAKE
RESTITUTION PAYMENTS. WHICH TO
MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO GET A JOB HAVE HOUSING
STABILITY IN THEIR LIVES. AND
FOR TELLING PEOPLE KNOW YOU
YOU'RE GONNA KEEP YOUR RECORD
IT'S GOING TO BE A SCARLET
LETTER ON YOUR- BACK FOREVER
BECAUSE YOU POOR AND CAN'T PAY
RESTITUTION. THE CRITICS OF THIS
BOTH OF THEM IS NOT GOING TO GO
A- PERSONS. WORK OR VERY MUCH
MAYBE HOMELESS AND IT'S JUST IT
SERVES NO VALID PURPOSE AND
THAT'S WHY. AND THAT'S WHY
HONESTLY THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS
THAT THERE'S SUCH A LIMITED
OPPOSITION THIS BILL AND IN FACT
ONE. FOR A WHILE IN OPPOSITION
LETTER AND THEN WE SPOKE TO THEM
AND WE REALLY FLUSH OUT BUT I'M
WHAT THE BILL DOES AND DOESN'T
DO. IT WITH YOUR THEIR
OPPOSITION. THIS IS A PRETTY
COMMON- BUILT. SO JUST TO BE
CLEAR SO IS THIS ANY MEDIAN
EXPUNGEMENT OF THEIR RECORDS ONE
SIR ALF- IRWIN OUT OF YOUR TIME
WE'RE NOT EXPUNGING ANYTHING
BECAUSE THIS IS WHEN SOMEONE
GOES TO THE COURT ASKING FOR
EXPUNGEMENT. BECAUSE AS YOU CAN
SEE FROM ANALYSIS THERE ARE
CERTAIN- YOU KNOW THAT WERE
THERE CERTAIN SITUATION FOR THE
COURTS REQUIRED THROUGH GRAPHICS
FUN GRANT OR THEIR AUTHORIZED ON
THAT THE COURT CANNOT RELY
SOLELY ON UNPAID RESTITUTION. TO
TO DRIVE EXPANSION SO THAT WOULD
HAPPEN WHATEVER THE PERSON GOES
TO COURT- TO- TERRY SPONGE I'M
GONNA MAKE SURE I'M NOT THE
STATE ENOUGH YES THERE'S ALREADY
TIME. WHEN YOU CAN GO TO GET
EXPUNGED OR TO GET IT
RESENTENCED FIVE FELONY TO A
MISDEMEANOR VARIOUS THINGS SO
THIS DOESN'T CHANGE THOSE TIME
FRAMES. AND THEY'RE NOT A MEDIA
YOU HAVE TO SHOW SOME PERIOD OF
TIME WHICH YOU ARE THEY'VE MADE
WE'VE MADE CHANGES OVER THE
EXISTING HERE SO I DON'T HAVE
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD THE TIME
FRAMES BUT THERE'S A TIME FRAME
WHERE YOU HAD TO. BE BEHAVING IN
A WAY THAT YOU'RE NOT COMMITTING
MORE CRIMES SO IT WOULD BE. IF
YOU WERE WHENEVER PEOPLE WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE TO GO TO
WORK- TO TRY TO GET AN
EXPUNGEMENT. THEY COULD DO IT
HERE AT ALL WE'RE SAYING IS
THAT. THE COURT CAN SAY I'M
DENYING IT BECAUSE YOU'RE ON
PAID RESTITUTION. THERE WERE NOT
CHALLENGES TIME LINES ARE
AUTOMATICALLY GRANTING
EVERYTHING. OKAY IS THERE IT
DOES THIS PROVIDE. SO CANNABIS
WITH THIS PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO PAY THE
RESTITUTION IN ORDER TO GET. AND
QUALIFY FOR THE SPANISH WITH DO
YOU THINK THAT THIS WOULD AYE
REMOVING THAT THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD BE
TO CENTER BY SOMEONE AS YOU WORK
TOWARDS THAT BECAUSE WHAT WHAT
ELSE DO YOU HAVE WITH THE OTHER
CARE AT THE WHITE HOUSE. I DON'T
THINK SO I MEAN YOU HEARD A REAL
PURPLE CASE ON THE PHONE TODAY
SOMEONE WHO HAS LIKE BETWEEN
EXIT NICK I THINK A HUNDRED
THOUSAND EXPLAINS RUN. AROUND A
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESTITUTION
PLUS HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
OTHER FEES AND SHE SAID SHE
NEVER THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE
WITH HER FOR THE REST OF HER
LIFE- AND SO YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
. THE PRESIDENT ARM MORE LIKELY
TO BE IMPOVERISHED. THAN OTHER
PEOPLE FOR REASONS YET ON THAT
ONE TO BE HOMELESS. AND SO
THEY'RE NOT MAKING THESE
OVERWHELMINGLY PICKED IF YOU
LOOK AT THE STATISTICS. THE
PERCENTAGE OF VICTIMS RECEIVE
EITHER ZERO. IN RESTITUTION OR A
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THE
RESTORATION IS- THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY. OFVICTIMS RECEIVE
NOTHING OR VERY SMALL.
PERCENTAGE EVEN WITH THIS. YOU
KNOW ACCEPT SUCH A PENALTY HANG
OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS THAT YOU CAN
GET EXPUNGEMENT. AND SO RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE NOT GETTING PAID
OVERWHELMINGLY SO I DON'T THINK
THIS IS CHRIS ANY KIND OF
INCENTIVE NOT TO PAY. THAT IT'S
ALL INCENTIVE NOT TO PAY IT'S A
REALITY BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE POOR
AND WORKING WE'RE HOPING TO KEEP
THEM POOR BY SAYING. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CLEAR YOUR RECORD SO
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET A GOOD JOB. YOU MAY NOT EVEN
BE ABLE TO GET HOUSING. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
FOR OTHERS WITH DISCLOSURE. ARE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR CALM
WATER AND WHEN WE TALKED CALLS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK YOU
WE HAVE EIGHTY TO SIMPLE DO
PASSED CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL HONEST FEEL OF NO SIX
OF ELEVEN OF SIXTY PASSED
BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D CHOI BOGUE
. NOT VOTING. FOR THEM. OKAY COM
LONGER I COMMA- I'D SKINNER
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE THREE TWO
ONE THREE ONE WILL LEAVE THE
MEASURE OPEN- NEXT UP IS S. B.
THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY SENATOR CALM
WATER.
THEY'RE COMING HERE WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I AM.
THIS IS ALSO VERY LOW. I AM HERE
TO PRESENT MY DEALS YOU KNOW SB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THE
CDC ARE GIVES TO PEOPLE UPON
RELEASE FROM STATE PRISONS. ALSO
KNOWN AS GATE MONEY. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO COMPEL CDC ARE TO
CONTINUE ADJUSTING FOR INFLATION
FROM TWENTY TWENTY FOUR ON WORK.
THE CURRENT AMOUNT OF GATE MONEY
GIVEN IS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS AN
AMOUNT THAT HAS REMAINED ON
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. USING
THE MASSACHUSETTS INSTITUTE OF
TECHNOLOGY'S LIVING WAGE
CALCULATOR S. B. THIRTEEN OH
FOUR WILL INCREASE THIS AMOUNT.
TO TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE THE
TYPICAL MONTHLY EXPENSES FOR
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PRE TAX. FOR A SINGLE ADULT WITH
NO CHILDREN. CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
REVISITED THIS NUMBER IN NEARLY
FIFTY YEARS DESPITE INFLATION
AND SOARING HOUSING PRICES. AND
IS SOARING COST OF LIVING
HOUSING PRICES IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER AND AT THE TIME A TWO
HUNDRED DOLLAR CHECK COULD MORE
THAN COVER A MONTH'S RENT ON A
TYPICAL TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT.
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS BARELY COVERS ANY BASIC
NEEDS FOR RELEASED PERSONS. OR
PERSONS WHO ARE NOT INCARCERATED
AND WOULD COVER LESS THAN 15% OF
ONE MONTH'S RENT ON A TYPICAL
STUDIO APARTMENT LET ALONE FOOD
AND HYGIENE. PROVIDING A NEWLY
RELEASED PERSON WITH ONE MONTH
OF EXPENSES ALLOWS THEM TO
LOCATE A NEW JOB AND MAY ASSIST
WITH SOME OF THE MOST OF THE
POST RELEASE FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS. MANY FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FACE SUCH AS
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM FOR
ROLE CHECK INS. PROVIDING GATE
MONEY THAT IS AN APPROPRIATE
REFLECTION OF TYPICAL EXPENSES
FOR CALIFORNIANS IS CRITICAL FOR
THE SUCCESS OF THIS POLICY. AND
THE SUCCESS OF A REHABILITATIVE
PRISON SYSTEM FACILITATING A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION TO LIFE
AFTER PRISON BUT ULTIMATELY
INCREASING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
DECREASING RECIDIVISM. WITH HERE
WITH ME HERE IN SUPPORT IS
JACQUI MARIO A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE SISTER WARRIORS FREEDOM
COALITION AND JOSEPH A HOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE FOR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AND- ALL
RIGHT WELL FOR THOSE TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES APIECE TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN. FOR.
SCHOLARSHIP MARIE LOCUSTS. YEAH
OKAY GATWICK AREA. OKAY WELL
FIRST. WE'RE GONNA LET BURKE
CARRILLO CASTRO CONFERS
JACQUELINE. OKAY RIGHT HI- THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK-
FOR SB THIRTEEN OH FOR MINING
EXACTLY MOBILE I'M A WRITER AND
ARTIST AND ADVOCATE MENTOR
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AND MULTI.
FAMILY MEMBER VINCE THE WORST
PEOPLE COLLISION AND I AM AN
ADVOCATE AND MENTOR AT ARC I
WOULD BE RELEASED FROM THE W.
ACTORS ARGUED WON'T PRESUME THE
U. S. I'VE BEEN IN A DIFFERENT
OUT OF THE EIGHT FROM AGE OF
TWELVE AND I'VE STRUGGLED WITH
IS A BOOST. MOST OF MY LIFE. I
MIGHT BE YOU FROM CRAVING WITH
TWO HUNDRED. BUT FIRST TIME I
BEEN RELEASED WHEN I WAS THE WE-
SHOULD. NOW HOME TO BOTH YOU AND
AGAIN ALL TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS.
HE IMAGINE OFF OF HUNDRED
DOLLARS. I HAD TO FIND A IN THE
A JOB TRANSFER. TO GET THERE AND
BACK AND BECAUSE YOU AGING ALLOW
THEM TO BE HEARD FROM. THERE ARE%
VERY FEW TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
FOR WOMEN. COMING HOME FROM
PRISON AND THERE'S A LONG WAYS
WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE PROGRAMS I
HAVE. ONLY BEEN DOING AS WELL AS
I AM RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
REPORTED PUT TOGETHER. BY MY
COMMUNITY. THANK A COMMUNITY
THAT IS RIGHT NOW BEING THAT
WOULD BE TO BUY CALL THE LOSING
HOUSING THE PEOPLE. PHILLIP HOW
I ENDED UP- CASTRICUM BEFORE I
FINALLY FOUND A TEMPORARY ROOM
FOR FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. NOW
APPLYING FOR A GRANT THAT WILL
BE ALLOWED TO ON THE FOR
PERMANENT. HOUSING OTHER BASIC
NEEDS HAVE BEEN MET BY THE
COMMUNITY TO HAVE BEEN.
ORGANIZING GAMES. WHAT I GONNA
BY HIKING. PRODUCTS AND CLOTHES
. BECAUSE AGAIN I. WOULD READ
WITH THAT THE- AND I DON'T EVEN
CARE. FOR MY JOB. THANKS FOR
YOUR CAREFUL. THEM WHAT PEOPLE
ARE READ READING. ARE AS AS ME.
DON'T AN DON'T HAVE SUPPORT OFF
MANY WOULD END UP HOMELESS MANY
. ARE UNABLE TO CREATE A ONE BY
FOR THE- WE- LOSE STOP. WHAT IS
UP TO. IT REVIEW IF I. ACTOR
BEGINNING THE FALL THE PORT. WHO
SURVIVED CRIME. THAT THEY NEED
AN EXTREME. SPORT FOR THE
FISHING TRACK THE- SOME OF THE
TROUBLED WOMAN IT. END UP
RESTORING THE SURVIVAL CRIMES
JUST TO PROVIDE. FOR THEIR MOST
BASIC NEEDS AND THE CIRCLE CRIME
CONTINUED. INCARCERATION
CONTINUES IN THE CYCLE SHOULD BE
LOSING OUR MOTHER TO DEFEND
CONTINUES. ON THE GENERATIONAL
FROM MINE THEY DIDN'T IT IS ALL
BECAUSE OF THE WOMAN. WITH ARE
NOT. GIVEN A CHANCE TO. GET BACK
ON THEIR FEET TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS IT'S HARD ENOUGH. FOR
THE BOTH RIGHT BACK. ARAMBULA
DANGLING. FROM LA. GIVING PEOPLE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE DOLLARS FOR. A
RECENT RELEASE FROM PRISON WILL
GIVE THEM. GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO
MAKE A LIFE FOR THEMSELVES ONE.
WHERE THEY WILL FIND A HOME THE
CAREER HE'LL- BE BETTER VERSIONS
OF THEM OUT THERE BECAUSE IT'S-
ACTUALLY CHILDREN. BECAUSE NO
ONE NOT ONLY DO WE SUFFER BUT
OUR CHILDREN YOU TO. THANK YOU
FOR ANYTHING. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. HELLO MY NAME IS JOSEPH
I'M BOB OF BRITAIN UNITED
COMMUNITY SO THE VALLEY BUT I'M
ALSO FORMALLY WERE LIKE OVER THE
COURSE LACKING YEARS I'VE BEEN
TO THE WALL DOOR AND OF WILLIAMS
GIVEN TO DOLLARS. I'M PART OF
THE ACT AND AN ACCOUNT ON THE
BACK WHICH NEED A LOT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS A WAS YOUR WAS
STANDING UP TO PURCHASE BONTA US
A BUT THE IN THE MAIL FROM
DOLLAR MAY IN THE BY MY FAMILY
TALK ABOUT IT SHE ST BY. WHEN I
CALLED THE NUMBER LAST YEAR UP
WITH THE CITY OF STEEL THE OLD
RETURNING THIS AND SIMILAR
PROGRAMS ONLY TWO THOUSAND SO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLAR AND
THREE INCREMENTAL WERE A SIMILAR
SOME OF IT TO SAVE FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO BE
SPECIFICALLY. NOW FORTUNATELY I
HAVE BEEN IN PORT YOU HELP
PROVIDE SHELF OF THE TRUCK THERE
ARE PEOPLE WAIT TO TRY. TO THE
FIVE THAT ARE NOT AS- THE PAST
OF SB THIRTY NO FOR AND THE SIX
DOLLARS MY THEY CAN A CAR LET ME
. REPORTER WHAT ONES OUT LOS
LEARN ABOUT MONEY GETTING SB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR GOING TO DRUGS.
REPORT BUILDER CONCERNED ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY. SB FOR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE ROOM HERE TWENTY
TWO OO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IS
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. S. B. THIRTEEN OH
FOUR PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK AS PHILIP BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NOW MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA TO OUR
PHONE LINES DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN OH
FOUR ONLINE. IF YOU LIKE TO COME
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE END. OF THE LINE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE FLAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WILL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MEXICO TO LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE THREE
ELEMENTARY AND FOUNDER AND FROM
WORK YEAH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. THANKS FOR THE LINE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WOULD GO TO
IF I'M WITH ALL OF US ARE NOT AN
ALLEY HE- IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE QUICKNESS. NEXT TO
THE TO LINE SEVENTY LEAST BEHIND
. WE HAVE BEEN AROUND IN. AND- I
WOULD NEED TO LEARN AND I'M DONE
AND I'M IN FULL SUPPORT. GOT IT
THANK YOU. THE QUICKNESS. NINE
NINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS JEREMY HOW MAY
HAVE BEEN ISSUED JUSTICE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANKS TO THE TO LINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURKE FOR THE
GRAND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND ALSO CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THE QUICKNESS. MICHAEL KLEIN
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
JUST HOPE HE LEARNS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS IN STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
NEXT TO THE TO LINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GRAYSON IF
THOSE PEOPLE A YOUNG WOMAN
CENTER AS WELL AS THE FOUNDING
CO FOUNDER OF THE HISTORICALLY
INCLUDES. AND FROM WHAT. THANK
YOU. NEXT IN LINE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS THE
LEAST OF THE AREA I'M PROVIDES
AND PUNISH CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. IT IS TIME TO SOMEONE
ELSE THANK YOU OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO OFFICIAL OPPOSITION
LISTED IS THERE ANYONE HERE AND
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO. SB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR HEARING SEEN
NONE MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO
PHONE LINES AND SEE IF THERE'S
WITNESSES AND Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
LIKE FINE OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
FIRST TO GO TO OUR LINE SIXTY
THREE HE'S GO AHEAD.
LOCALIZATION A LOT POINT FIVE
TWO COUNTY WHERE YOU HAVE A LOT
OF PROGRAMS. CORRECTED FOR- ONLY
REALLY YOU TO HELP INTO SOCIETY
AND I DON'T. KNOW AFTER THREE
BURGER KING NECESSARY FOR THE
ARTS SO I'M NOT. SUPPOSED YOU
THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT TO LINE
FIFTY NINE IF I HAD. COOL
AFTERNOON THANK CALLING I
THOUGHT BY THE CITIZEN AND I'M
IN A POSITION OF THE BILL AT ONE
TWO ZERO FOUR. YEAH THANK YOU
THE QUICKNESS. ANY TIME THERE'S
NO NOTHING HERE GREAT WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO. THIS MEASURE BEFORE
. CENTER JOE VOTE. I KNOW I KNOW
I AM I AM GOING TO I AM JUST
LOOKING AS YOU LOOK VERY
SERIOUSLY. MIGHT ANY COMMENTS
THEY PROBABLY- SO THAT ARE COME
LONGER I. SO I KNOW IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE I'VE OFTEN-
THOUGHT ABOUT THE FACT THAT WHEN
OUR- SOME PEOPLE ARE SERVER TIME
THEY FINISH OFF YOU KNOW THAT.
JUST THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY'RE IN YOU KNOW THAT THEY
FIND THEMSELVES AFTER BEING
COURSE RATED SOME FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND- SOME OF THEM WHO DO
NOT HAVE. ANY FAMILY SUPPORT WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING THAT CAN IT
CAN REALLY HELP ON GET BACK IN
I'VE OFTEN THOUGHT ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE BEST HELP OUR-
OUR INDIVIDUALS ARE FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE LEAVING THE SYSTEM IN
ABOUT THAT'S WHY I'M AN ADVOCATE
FOR EDUCATION WHILE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED SO THEY CAN HAVE A
SKILL SET- THE KNOWLEDGE BASE TO
BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW HAVE OFFERED
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES ONCE THEY
LEAVE- THAT'S- IN SUPPORT. OF AB
. THIS IS SERVICES THAT CAN HELP
THEM PREPARE TO MOVIE INCLUDING
THE ABILITY TO WORK WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED TO SAVE
MONEY SO THAT THEY- COME OUT
WITH SOMETHING IN THEIR POCKET.
M. SO I EAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR YOUR YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I
EIGHT I DO WANNA DRESS THE
CONCERNS I THINK. EVERY
TAXPAYER. IN EVERY PERSON YOU
KNOW. OUR SENIORS AND DISABILITY
WITHOUT. A FIXED INCOME AND
EVERY OTHER INDIVIDUAL THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA THAT MIGHT BE
LOOKING AT THIS IT WILL LOOK AT
THIS AND THINK. WOW I JUST HAVE
TO SERVE TIME AND GET YOU KNOW
SOME MONEY AND- NOT BE ABUSED
YOU KNOW BECAUSE I WOULD HATE TO
HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE HIS BE
INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE TO SAY HEY
I I'M- I'M BROKE. BUT IF I SERVE
SOMETIME I'LL GET SITE AND HOW
OFTEN CAN I DO THIS AND- I KNOW
THAT SOUNDS REALLY REALLY. YOU
KNOW FAR FETCHED BUT FOR BUT FOR
SOME INDIVIDUALS AND I DO SPEAK
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE. ON THAT
LOT. I'M SURE THAT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO'D BE
VERY VERY CONCERNED. THAT- BUT
THIS WOULD BE ABUSED BUT I DO.
UNDERSTAND AND I'VE HEARD OF
THAT. THE DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH PEOPLE FIND THEMSELVES
AFTER SERVING TIME AND BECAUSE
OF THAT. AND I THINK WE DO NEED
A LITTLE BIT OF GRACE AFTER
SERVING THEIR TIME AND HELP. IN
GETTING BACK SO WITH THAT IN
MIND WHICH LET YOU KNOW THAT I
DO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY. GREAT ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HEARING
THREE. NO IT HASN'T. THE HOME OF
THE BILL THANK YOU CENTERS
SKINNER THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTERS SKINNER. WE HAVE A TO
PASS YOU REFERRED TO APPROACH.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OUT SB THIRTEEN OH FOUR. ONCE
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY SIR I'M SAID
. WHAT IT WOULD- SO I THINK YOU
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
TRUTHFULLY IT'S- SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO COME UP PEOPLE
SAY NO WHY SHOULD WE BE GIVING
FOLKS WHO- HAVE SERVED TIME IN
PRISON. TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
MONEY. AND THE REALITY IS IT'S-
EXPIRES WE SUBSIDIZE ALL KINDS
OF FOLKS- AND SOMETIMES WE DO IT
. ONE TIME WITH A LUMP SUM AND
SOMETIMES WE DO IT OVER THE
COURSE OF YOU KNOW MANY MANY
YEARS THIS IS A ONE TIME LUMP
SUM- IT'S- IMPOSSIBLE. FOR
ANYONE TO BELIEVE. THAT YOU
COULD COME OUT OF PRISON. WITH
ONLY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. AND
GET BACK ON YOUR FEET. AND TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS YOU WOULD HAVE
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS IN ITS
ENTIRETY. IF YOU HAD CLOSE THAT
SOMEONE BROUGHT YOU WHEN YOU GOT
RELEASED IF YOU HAD SOMEONE PICK
YOU UP AND GIVE YOU A RIDE IF
YOU HAD SOMEONE WHO IS BUYING
YOUR FOOD WHEN YOU GOT OUT IF
YOU HAD SOMEONE WHO MADE SURE
THAT WHEN YOU LEFT YOU HAD ZERO
DOLLARS ON THE BOOKS. IF YOU HAD
SOMEONE WHO MADE SURE THAT YOU
HAD A REPLACEMENT FOR ALL OF THE
GOVERNMENT ID'S THAT YOU EITHER
LOST OR THAT EXPIRED- WHILE YOU
WERE SERVING TIME. IN ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE EXPENSES THAT
COME OUT OF. TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
. TO REPLACE GOVERNMENT IDEAS
COULD COST SOMEONE AS MUCH AS
SIXTY DOLLARS. IF SOMEONE GOT
OUT AND HAPPEN TO HAVE KIDS OR-
A FAMILY MEMBER OR SOMEONE WHO
IS PROVIDING FOR THEM WHILE THEY
WERE INSIDE. AND THEY JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU WITH A
LUNCH OR DINNER. THAT TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS. COULD
EVAPORATE. AND IF THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO GET TRANSPORTATION
TO VISIT THEIR PO. IF THEY HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES- TO APPLY FOR
PARTICULAR JOBS OR TO GO ON JOB
INTERVIEWS OR TO EVEN GET SOME
TRAINING. THEY CERTAINLY CAN'T
GO NAKED. THEY HAVE TO HAVE
CLOSE- AND SO ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE EXPENSES. THAT WE
TAKE FOR GRANTED. AND THEN I
THINK MANY FOLKS THINK WELL YOU
SHOULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO
THAT I GAVE YOU YOUR FREEDOM.
WELL WE DIDN'T GIVE YOU YOUR
FREEDOM YOU REHABILITATED OR
YOUR SERVE YOUR TIME AND THEN
THAT WAS WHAT YOU WERE DO- THIS.
IS ABOUT. ACKNOWLEDGING THE FACT
THAT THE COST OF LIVING IS SO
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE. AND IF WE
DON'T WANT FOLKS. TO USE. MONEY
TO USE. IF WE DON'T WANT FOLKS
TO LEAN BACK INTO BEHAVIOR THAT
GOT THEM WHERE THEY WERE IN THE
FIRST PLACE. IF WE WANT TO
BELIEVE THAT- HEY YOU CAN STILL
BE POOR AND MAKE IT. THEN I
GUESS WE SHOULD BE OKAY WITH THE
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS BUT THIS IS
REALLY A KNOWLEDGE SHARING. THAT
IF YOU WANT TO GIVE SOMEONE A
LEG UP NOT FOR EVER. BUT FOR ONE
MONTH TO LIKE GET IT TOGETHER
THIS IS PROBABLY WHAT IT'S GOING
TO COST. YOU KNOW I WAS TALKING
WITH THE WITNESSES. BEFORE HAND
AND- JOSEPH SAID SO MANY MANY
TALK TO SAID. WHEN I GET OUT I
JUST NEED TO DO X. Y. OR Z. SO
THAT I CAN BUY A CAR. LIKE WHAT
AM I GOING TO DO TO GET A RIDE.
AND I WAS SAYING YES SO THAT YOU
COULD DRIVE AND GO TO YOUR JOB
INTERVIEW OR GET FOOD OR LOOK
FOR- YOU KNOW. HE SAID NO
BECAUSE YOU CAN LIVE IN THE CAR
YOU CAN LIVE IN THE CAR UNTIL
YOU CAN GET ON YOUR FEET TO GET
A JOB. IT IS SAFE HOUSING FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE. AND THE NUMBER ONE
. POPULATION ON THE RISE IN OUR
PRISONS ARE WOMEN IN THE
MAJORITY OF THE WOMEN HAVE KIDS.
AND SO WAS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
WE ARE SAYING TO THESE MOTHERS.
GO BACK AND DO WHAT YOU WERE
DOING BEFORE YOU GOT HERE. WITH
THIS ADDED STRESS OF NOT DOING
THAT SO THAT YOU'RE NOT
SEPARATED FROM YOUR KIDS AGAIN.
AND I THINK THAT WE'RE OFFERING
PEOPLE FAUSTIAN CHOICES. AND
THIS IS A ONE TIME INFUSION TO
SAY. I BELIEVE IN REHABILITATION
I WANT YOU TO NOT COME BACK TO
PRISON I AM GOING TO GIVE YOU
ONE MONTH'S HELP TO GET YOURSELF
TOGETHER THAT IS REALLY ALL THIS
IS THANK. AND SO WITH THAT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
BECAUSE THOSE COMMENTS ARE
EXACTLY WHAT OTHER FOLKS SAY AND
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR ME TO HEAR
THEM SO THAT I CAN SHARE THESE
EXPERIENCES. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
SCANNER WE HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS. APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A
THIRTEEN OH FOUR SB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD DIETRO
BOGUE HI JOE BOAKAI COM LONGER
AYE COMMANDER AYE SKINNER. AYE
SKINNER AYE WINNER. WHEN ARE I.
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO CAN WE LIFT
THE ROLE. I LOOKED CALL ON ON
FILE. SB NINE NO NOT IT WAS
ELEVEN OH SIX BY SENATOR WIENER. SB ELEVEN OH SIX SKINNER. FIVE
SKINNER I. FORTY ONE. S. B.
ELEVEN OH SIX IS OUT FOUR TO ONE
AND LOOK TO GROW ON SENATOR
BATES. SB TEN FIFTY THREE- THE
VOTERS WANTED TO SKINNER. NO
SKINNER NOW. IT'S ONE TO THREE
AND SHE ASKED FOR
RECONSIDERATION. AND THAT'S WHAT
MEASURE WAS I'M SURE. SB TEN
FIFTY THREE S. WEEKENDS THE
SIXTY THREE FIFTY THREE FIFTY
THREE I'M SORRY SB TEN FIFTY
THREE THE VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE I
MEAN ONE THE FOUR. ONE THE
THREE. YEAH IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
ONE ONE ONE THE THREE AND SOONER
BATES IS BEING GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION. WHEN THE THREE
. NOW WE'RE OPTIONS FOR OUR LAST
ITEM S. B. NINE ONE EIGHT BY
CENTER PORTANTINO HAS ASKED ME
TO PRESENT FORMING THERE AND TO
GO OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR CENTER
THROUGH A BOAT AND I WILL THEN
GO AND PRESENT OR- MISTER
PORTANTINO.
THIS IS LOVE YEAH I THINK I'M
GONNA FIND IT PERFECTLY. BUT I.
ALL RIGHT. CONSIDER BRADFORD YOU
MAY PRESENT S. B. NINE EIGHTEEN
FOR SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK YOU
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB NINE
EIGHTEEN ON BEHALF OF THEIR
PORTANTINO WHICH IS- DRESSES
FROM THE OBSOLETE- PENAL CODES-
PROVISIONS AND UPDATES FIREARM.
RELATED CROSS REFERENCES THERE
ARE CURRENTLY A NUMBER OF OUT
DATED CROSS REFERENCES ARISING
FROM A COLLECTIVE OF PASSAGE A
RECENT FIREARM FIREARMS
LEGISLATION INCLUDING
LEGISLATION AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND NOW ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROB BONTA. THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS CORRECT THREE SPECIFIC
CROSS REFERENCES THE FIRST
UPDATE IS REGARDING THE
PREVIOUSLY ESTABLISHED BASIC
AMMUNITION ELIGIBILITY. CHECK
FEE AND THE SECRETARY
REQUIREMENTS PERTAINING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RECOVERY
OF COST FOR AMMUNITION
TRANSACTIONS THE SECOND- IS
REGARDING THE PREVIOUS.
PREVIOUSLY ESTABLISHED PRECURSOR
PART FEES AND THE STATURE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT PERTAINING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RECOVERY OF COSTS FOR PRECURSOR
PART TRANSACTIONS. AND LASTLY-
LOOK- THIRTY WILL UPDATE. IS
REGARDING THE LICENSE FIREARMS
DEALERS IN LICENSED AMMUNITION
VENDORS WHO SHALL AUTOMATICALLY
BE DEEMED FARM PRECURSORS PART
VENDORS PROVIDED. COMPLIANCE
WITH SPECIFIED IN ADEQUATELY
CROSS REFERENCE REQUIREMENTS
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT ANSWERING
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
ACTUALLY AIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL'S SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL-
QUESTIONS IS ALISON MENDOZA'S
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. YOU'RE OFF FARMS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR BRADFORD
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
WITNESSES TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. EVERYONE ACTUALLY ERIC HALF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND-
THANK YOU FOR MOST. YEAH
PROFFERING THE THUNDER AND ALSO
SET A RECORD WITH INVENTING A-
AND THEN. IN THE LATE HOURS
THANK. DURING THE FAILED VEHICLE
I THINK EVERY TIME A FIREARM IS
TRANSFERRED OR HOLD MY LICENSE
DEALER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HE WOULDN'T NEED ONLY
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE PROSPECT
PROTECT THE FORMER PRODUCERS.
INVOLVED OTHER PROGRAMMATIC.
YEAH THIRTY YEARS AGO IT THAT
THE OF RAIN OFTEN NOTHING
BACKGROUND WITH THE MANAGER
COMPANY ELEVEN DIFFERENT.
NINETEEN DOLLARS ECONOMIC
SUPPORT. AS ALL THE REQUIRED AY
BY. AB SIX FIFTY NINE FIVE SEVEN
NUMBER AND WAS PRETTY GOOD ALL
RIGHT BYE TWENTY NINE ACCORDING
TO YOU KNOW THE JOKE INTO THAT
FACT. IN WHILE YOU'RE HE WOULD
REDUCE ONE DOLLAR AND MAYBE
USEFUL AMBER. THEY HAVE ONE OF
TO CLOSE THE THIRTY DOLLARS
EACH. YEAR BY THE OF DEATH
REPORT FOR MEDICAL FIREARM FOR.
FUNCTIONS IN BACKGROUND CHECKS.
I THINK OF NOTHING UNIFORM
REFLECT MORE DISPLAY REALLY TO
COLLECTION AT THE SB NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN. THE OUTDATED
PROVISIONS AND YEAR ROUND THREE
MINUTES PROPER. FOR TO THE
DIRECTLY. SACRAMENTO THE-
AUTHORITY OF THE- OF THE FROM
THE REGULAR AS FAIL BUYERS
BECAUSE YOU'RE CORRECT OPERATING
TO HEAR FIRE. DEPARTMENT OR THE. AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY. AS
WELL AS A COUPLE RECORD OUR AND-
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS I AND
ME FORWARD- I WAS. AND- MENDOZA
IS OUR TECHNICAL EXPERT SHOULD
MAY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW
THE RECORD HIGH. SO SHE WON'T BE
TESTED ONLY THREE QUESTIONS TAX
QUESTIONS PERFECT AND- SO NOW
WILL BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
. IN SUPPORT. SEEN NONE- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHTEEN
WILL BEGIN. YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
SUPPORT OF SB NINE EIGHTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. I THANK YOU MATTER IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CHECKING JUST ONE
MORE TIME TO BE SURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES WAITING
- IF YOU LIKE TO COMMENT PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. I DON'T KNOW I
THINK YOU THANK YOU MR MARC
MODERATOR HAVING HEARDFROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION DANIEL READ ARE
YOU ON THE PHONE LINE. YES I AM
. PLEASE PROCEED SIR. YES CARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD THE AND READ WHAT YOU
REGIONAL DIRECTOR WITH THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSITION TO DATE AT NINE
EIGHTEEN- THIS INCREASES THE
COST OF ELIGIBILITY CHECKS FOR
BOTH THE AMMUNITION- JACKSON
PRECURSOR PARKS- THIS STEMS FROM
MAYBE SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE- WHICH
EXPRESSLY LIMITED THAT MAX
AMOUNT THEY CAN BE CHARGED UNDER
THE DRUGS HE WHICH- POINTS TO
AMMUNITION AND PRECURSOR PARTS
OF WHICH DATE BACK. BUT THEY
POINT TO THAT WAS PASSED. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND BECAME
EFFECTIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. DESPITE HIS. IN STATUTE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS CONTINUED TO- CHARGE
OVER THE STATUTORY MAXIMUM A ONE
DOLLAR THEY'VE BEEN CONTINUING
TO CHARGE NINETEEN DOLLARS. FOR
BASIC ELIGIBILITY CHECKS-
DESPITE THE CHANGE IN LAW
DESPITE RECEIVING NOTICE FROM US
- IN ADDITION TO OUR CONCERN
WITH THIS THIS INCREASE AND COST
AND THE UNLAWFUL CHARGING. OF
PERSON TO SPEAKING TO- PURCHASE
AMMUNITION- WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE NATURE OF
HOW THIS LEGISLATION IS DRAFTED
IT'S POINTING TO A NOW OBSOLETE-
STATUTE IT'S ASKING TO READ TO
READ UP TO DATE ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- WE THINK THAT'S GOING
TO CREATE CALL- CONFUSION AND
PROBLEMS IN THE FUTURE SINCE
THAT SECTION IS NOW. A
DRASTICALLY CHANGED-
ADDITIONALLY- WE FEEL THAT-
THERE'S BEEN NO BASIS FOR THE
CHARGE OF NINETEEN DOLLARS OR
FOURTEEN DOLLARS- AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S A QUESTION THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IF YOU
LOOK AT THE WAY THE TRUSTEE WAS-
WAS ENUMERATED INFATUATED WITH
LIMITED TO FOURTEEN DOLLARS AND
IT WAS GREAT UP TO NINETEEN
DEREGULATION. AND HOW HOW THIS
IS ACTUALLY A WORK YOU CAN BE
FOURTEEN DOLLARS IS GONNA BE
NINETEEN DOLLARS. AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY IF THIS IS A P.
SHOULD BE PROVIDING A BASIS FOR
THIS BE WHAT GOES INTO OF WHAT
DATABASES ARE BEING CHECKED- SO
THAT WE ARE NOT OVERCHARGING
CONSUMERS WHO ARE LOOKING TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT. TO FIND
THE MANY PROGRAMS. OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AB AT ALL
OF SANTA QUESTION AND- ONE
RESPECT WHAT THE- THANK. THANK
YOU MISTER REED- LET'S MOVE ON
TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION
. SCENE NINE. THANK YOU WANNA
MOVE ONTO IT IS THIS WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
FROM THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
EIGHTEEN. WE WILL BEGIN. YOU
LIKE IT FINE OPPOSITION OF SB
NINETEEN HIM APPROACH ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE GO TO LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON INSURANCE
REMEMBER MANY MATURE ALL ACTION
ON CLINTON'S AFTER COUNTY AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION IN THIS
BILL WE SHOULD NOT BE FINANCED
OUR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT. AND
IT IS STILL DEFINITELY WORTH
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON I STRONGLY OF COLD
STEEL NINE ONE EIGHT AND I
SECOND WORK NINE ONE WHAT THE
PRIOR CALLER JUST SAID THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THE TO LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAN MCKINNON AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. RIGHT YEAH. AT
THIS TIME IS NO NOTHING Q. THANK
YOU MODERATE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CHECK JUST ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE- HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SURE IF
YOU LIKE TO FIND OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE SOMEONE ON THE
LINE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. OUR PHONE LINE AND YOUR PHONE
SYSTEM IS INHERENTLY
DISCRIMINATORY TWO OF US USING A
SHARED FILE THE ONE WHO OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND YOU NEED TO FIX
YOUR TELEPHONIC. BONE IN THEM TO
REPRESENT THE PUBLIC THANK YOU.
ARE YOU REALLY FEEL. EXACTLY.
NEXT TO THE TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VENTURA MEMBERS
THE SAMPRAS WITH GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIANS SINCE- A COLLEAGUE
MISTER REED WAS THE PRIMARY TEST
FIRE AGAINST THE- LEGISLATION I
WOULD REQUEST IF I CAN BE THE
SECOND. WITH ABOUT A MINUTE TO
HELP WITH THE TESTIMONY. YOU
CARE. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
YOUR TESTIMONY. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO NOTHING Q. WE'LL HEAR
FROM HIM ACTUALLY IS STILL ON
THE LINE. THE REACTS TO LOSE
SOME. IT WAS AN ACCIDENT. I
DON'T THINK HE HEARD ME OKAY.
I'M WHAT HE CALLS BACK AGAIN WE
WILL RECONSIDER. THANK YOU FOR
ALL OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
I'M DOING ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES- HOW
MUCH IS THE DOJ CURRENTLY
TARGETED FOR THE DROSE
BACKGROUND CHECK- LET MISS
ERRORS AND FOR THAT ARE. THOSE
TECHNICAL WITNESS MISCONDUCT.
ELIMINATED IN A POSITION TO
EIGHT TWO THREE THREE OF THIRTY
ONE DOLLARS IN THE- I'M SORRY
ONE MORE TIME HOURS. WOULD YOU
MIND REPEATING THAT ONE MORE
TIME I WAS A LITTLE HARD TO HEAR
YOU. SURE FIFTY IDENTIFIED IN
THE LADIES YOU KNOW PROTECTIONS. TWO EIGHT TWO THREE THREE S.
THIRTY ONE DOLLARS AND NINETEEN
CENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
I HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO
THAT IS- IS THE DOJ STATUTORILY
LIMITED BY THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN BONTA BILL AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY NINE. ACTUALLY LIKE TO
RELY ON THE LEVEL IN OUTLOOK
WRITTEN BY THE FACT THAT MANY
WHICH STATES THAT THE AMOUNT OF
PROPER COVERAGE AUTHORIZED BY SB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE AND A NINE.
FIFTEEN FIFTY NINE RELATED TO
INITIATE THE PROJECT OR HOW
DIRECTLY TO THE AMOUNT DIRECTLY
HOWEVER WITH THE WITH THE
DECIBEL CODIFIED NEW SECTION
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THE BATTLE
THING IF I RECOVERY. WERE NOT
UPDATED TO THE CORRECT OFFER ALL
THE VIDEOTAPES THE AUTHORITY
AFFECT THINGS HAVE NOT CHANGED
FOR THE CANADIAN HOUSES. AND
AGAIN PARTICULARLY IN OUT THAT
THERE WAS NEVER INTENDED TO
LOWER THE FEES THAT ARE ONLY IF
THE MISSION REMAINS IN EXISTING
LAW THE SETTLEMENT OFFER
EVERYTHING PROVISIONS RELATED TO
THE AMMUNITION MAKERS OR CAR
TAX.YOUR CURRENT ADDRESS HE
ADDED I THINK PRIOR TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF FIFTEEN SIXTY
NINE IN DOING FOR THE BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THE PROPER YOUR-
INFORMATION AND CHANGE. THANK
YOU. AND THEN- I ANOTHER FOR YOU
. IN WHERE WAS- DRAU SOMEBODY
CREATE. IN THE FIRST. AND WHY IS
THAT. AND THE FACT THAT THE
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE THE STATUTE
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WAS.
INTENDED TO BE UPDATED AUGMENTED
BY DRESS ALL OF THE IN MEMORY
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THAT WAS
INTENDED TO BE COVERED. BY THE
P. CARD AT THE TIME OF THE OF
THE BACKGROUND. CHECK A FIRE AND
FORGET YOUR CHARACTER. OKAY IN
ONE LAW QUESTION. HOW MUCH DOES
IT COST TO COMPLETELY COMPLETE
AN ELIGIBILITY CHECK ON
AMMUNITIONS ARE PARTS. I'M NOT
SURE I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION I
THINK WE'LL BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU. BECAUSE I'M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE IF I IF THE
QUESTION IS IN REGARDS TO THE
STANDARD TECH. BASICALLY CHECKED
THE ACTUAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PERFORMING AFFECT THE WORD HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU. AND WHAT
IS- SO JUST SO THERE'S A
STANDARD A BASIC WHICH ONE ARE
YOU AWARE OF. WHICH ONE DO YOU
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF IS A TECHNICAL
WITNESS. THANK THE EIGHT EIGHT
RECORD FORMING THIS TRACK IS
THERE SOMETHING SPECIFICALLY
FROM FROM OUR DIVISION OF
OPERATIONS WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION FOR YOU. AFTER
THE HEARING. OKAY AND SO ONE
MORE TIME THE STANDARD BASIC AND
WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE. IF FOR
ANY NATION CHECK PURPOSES THERE
IS THE STANDARD AND THERE IS THE
BASIC. SO THERE'S TWO. AND AS A
TECHNICAL WITNESS YOU'RE NOT
QUITE SURE ABOUT THOSE TWO. AND
THE QUESTION RELATES TO WORK BUT
DEFECATION BUT I WOULD WANT TO
BE ABSOLUTELY SURE AND CHECKING
WITH OUR DIVISION OF OPERATIONS
BUT IT'S NOT WHAT THE PHONE
LINES TODAY. OKAY SO NOT AWARE
OF THE COST OF THE FEE THAT
CORRECT. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION BELIEVE THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED. IN RELATION TO THE
THREE AND A HALF IN POSSESSION
OF THAT INFORMATION THANK. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WELL NOW-
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OKAY SENATOR RUSSELL JULY TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL FOR
SB NINE ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU.
AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION. IN
ORDER TO GET A REPRIEVE. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR SKINNER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS COUNCIL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND S. B.
NINE EIGHTEEN. SB NINE EIGHTEEN
DO PASS BRADFORD BRADFORD BOTH
NO NOTE TROUBLED NO COMMAGER
COME LIKE RICE SKINNER SKINNER I
WINNER. WINNER I'M THE VOTE IS
FORTY ONE. THIS BILL IS- HAS
FOUR VOTES AND THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BECAUSE HE-
PASSED THE GAVEL BACK TO OUR
HERE. MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA FOR THE DAY SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INVESTORS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THIS PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AND IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE- PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HEARING TODAY AND I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION IN THIS
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDAS FOR THE
SENATE PUBLIC. UGH THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY. COMMITTEE AND WE
STAND ADJOURNED.